I think I'll go in the corner today as if there's some sort of exiled beach over here.
It doesn't really matter if I'm in the corner or not.
I think I'll accidentally hide my runes in the bottom right widget if I go onto the
that side so we're not going to go right in the corner for once.
A Christmas mirror, honestly, I don't know.
Right, I've just been prompted that I can put YouTube ads on, which I think means
a stream's up, first of all.
Hello, America, hiya, hello.
You know the funniest thing about being a little bit late to streamers?
Is that no one goes, oh no, she's cancelled because it's not even conceivable that I'm
not streaming.
That's my favourite concept, instead of like, oh, she's late, she must be sick, she has
to cancel type thing.
It's like, nah, she gambled away the house.
She hates us, she does, like, it's actually rather entertaining.
Good morning, good evening, and good afternoon, do we have some good fucking use of yellow
headquarters a day?
If I'm not mistaken, and I don't want to spoil it, so I need to go look for it to make sure
it's there, and T, yes, it's there, and T minus four hours.
None other than Azura Dooley has been successfully monetised on YouTube, bips out in awe, round
of applause for Azura's milky titties, she's been monetised, and now I'm allowed to talk
about what the fuck happened with Azura's monetisation, she got denied monetisation,
and I had to make poor Azura read a script, and she, in the script, she was like, hi YouTube,
well, in her voice, hi YouTube, I am Azura Dooley, a creator from America, I am a YouTuber,
so I did not show my body, I can't do her voice, but poor Azura had to like, do this
super serious freaking video for me, and I had to like, screenshot her channel, and she
had to be like, and I play video games, and it was so annoying, because obviously you
had to use normie terms, so poor Azura had to be like, and my fans are so excited to
enjoy my membership stream, and support me via super chat, because we were trying to go
for like, if you monetise her, you'll be in the money, because you had money, money, money
at the end of the day, so Azura did that, and we had to send in the appeal all behind
the scenes, because obviously I didn't want to be like, one of the talents who'd been
freaking denied monetisation, that's awful, an entire month for her to get monetised,
no, bad, however, I do have a slight announcement about that Azura stream, you read it right,
it is handcam, and she's also taking doodle requests, that money is gonna help her move
out, don't I make myself clear, that money that she makes, yeah, is gonna help her move
out, okay, so I don't want to see one fucking gritty day comment, I don't want to see it,
it's gonna help her move out, and what happens if mummy Azura moves out, mummy Azura is free
to make even more content, okay, so anyone that, oh Azura, you don't do ASMR, no plays
on your channel, oh, so you don't, you don't, I'm doing enough ASMR, guess what, if she
moves out, what do you think happens, hmm, hmm, right, put two and two together, what
do you think happens when she moves out, she makes more content, put your money where your
move is, hmm, hmm, that's what I thought, that's what I thought, that's terrible, my voice
is broken beyond repair, unfortunately it is cracking, the original plan was none other
than 12 hours of Elden Ring, I can't believe I'm so sorry to announce this refling, she
moves out, my cock goes up, honestly all the bleeding hearts agree with that, is that a new
mantra for the bleeding hearts, she moves out, my cock goes up, that's terrible, I'm
hilarious, hmm, are you getting a roommate, funny you mentioned that, I actually said
Azura, she can come with me if she wants, and, and she was like down for it and I'm
like, well there is a problem of migration, you know that tiny little problem of like
packing up your whole life and moving country, she can live with me, oh live with me if you
want to come, Streamer House is real, we, I've not been funny, it was discussed at Vail or
Headquarters, the possibility, however, the money you need and able to run a Streamer
House, you basically have to accept there's a deficit debt already on top of how to run
the company, now very thankfully the way that this company's structured, there's really
not much overhead at all, again, it's free to produce thumbnails, the girls can stream
what you want, it doesn't cost me $5 for Azura to put up an ASMR stream, you know what I
mean, obviously the models cost a lot of money but that deficit gets paid over time,
like I'm going to have ASMR role play come out and a lot of them are going to pay off
some of the things, imagine all the months from now, literally could you imagine us banging
on each other's door like, I'm trying to record ASMR, stop, well I was going to say something
highly inappropriate there, stop banger-basting yourself for Twitter audio, I'm trying to
record ASMR right now, yes, imagine if she moves it, well she actually did message me,
but you didn't hear this from me okay but this is Inside Our Secrets, she messaged me
and she said I'm really looking forward to doing YouTube role plays, which I'm really
glad about because I'm worried about overworking them but she's on the same page, she's got
her July audios to record first, which she should hopefully, well she's fucking getting
steaming the night, I see steaming right now, she's getting steaming on box shot roulette,
you guys are going to, I don't know if she's played it before but whoa that game's kind
of hard to wrap your head around a little bit, but would I say that to them honestly,
I don't think you understand that being under the umbrella of a slang makes you really comfortable
with people, like it just does, like I feel really comfortable around the girls, I feel
like I could show a picture of my floof and be like just something to look right here
and the girls would be like mmm I ain't you need to get that checked out, like I think
that's the degree of comfort, like if I had the wee hang on my wee bit and I'd be like
ahhh, so yeah, for me anyway, yes I am not comfortable, how does it, how does it freaked
out please with you, oh no, oh no, this can't be, oh no, we're at 8000.2 subscribers, oh
no, this can't be, you can't do this to me, oh no, right, one pound free food, right,
all looks good in the neighbourhood so I think we can get started, is there anything
that I missed whilst I was passed out asleep, anything, oh I need to be able to see, now
I know brightness 10 bad but so if it was barely visible, I can actually still see that
at the one but I feel like the stream can't you see it so obviously for stream reasons,
no don't discard that, I like it, I just say hi, I don't wanna spoil a good game here,
so we have played the base game before and we've just never played the DLC, actually
don't know how it gets activated, oh no, I think we did Samurai last time, why is Wretch
need to, I confess there uses, see I need a two handed heavy hitter, a warrior is a two
handed heavy hitter I think, you have to defeat this character to IS, I'm going to totally
remember, I think warrior, I want to do two handed like wha bam, slow down, are you squidding
me right now, no you're not, just tuning in, are we actually shocking strongy, I thank
you for the five delay lover, I feel you'll be fucking ecstatic cos there was monetising
during our celebration stream today, I bought this fricking shocker and in order to connect
the bluetooth, it wants my phone number, not gonna be nasty but it's, I mean I know things
already have my phone number, blah blah blah blah blah, I like tick tocks in a container
on my phone, blah blah blah blah, but it's like no you're not allowed to progress without
giving us your actual number cos we're gonna send you a verification code, I'm like a verification
code to shock myself, I don't trust it, I don't, I don't think it's right, and it's
actually really fucking weird cos that's not how technology should work, yeah I already
bought the software, oh sorry I already bought the hardware, but the software is behind a
verification code, why do I need to verify with my personal phone number in order to
shock myself, so sitting on my desk fully charged to the left, literally shock caller
wants to know your location, I'm like why the fuck do you need to know my location for
me to go like, I'm sorry to anyone that's severely disappointed, I might buy a burner
phone unironically just to fucking use it, right we're gonna go warrior, I like it a
bit, what body type bravo is a waman, yeah I'm a waman, wait why is she two-handed, wait
her dexterity, her intelligence is ten, wait I want like a warrior beast, do I want a warrior
is a dual wheel dexterity built, didn't that samurai, wait so is that vagabond, strength
fourteen, but dexterity's not really high, I just want a tank, vagabond is heavy armour,
I came from that let me hold the ASMR, you're in for a rough ride mate but thank you for
watching I do appreciate it, I do appreciate it, buying a cheap burner phone is it, yeah
literally, hero, I want a hero, I can be a hero, oh there we go, I don't want a shield
though, I want dual wheels, we'll change it later type, what is her name, oh is my controller
dies already please don't do that, my name is, if I'm a two-handed warrior it sounds
like I'm really good at giving, guys I'm a two-handed warrior, fondle abyssum, do you
guys actually want fondle abyssum, fondle these two-handed, yeah we'll do fondle, we'll
make sure you rip and piss, it was a good name, I don't care why I know it's fondle abyssum,
right that was a good name, that's what I thought, I have terrible news, whoa, you close
it, keeps it, oh that's correct you can get a wee extra cheeky thing, the golden seed
enhance sacred flas, imps to do thy bidding, a cracked pot that somehow mends themselves
a container for thrown items, wait you can have infinite items, what did he say, someone
said get the seed, you would want me to get the seed wouldn't you, I see how you do, I
am inclined to believe that gold seed is actually the best thing, five sacred branches charged
with the euling power said to originate from the demigod maquela, that's right, not the
seed you brought in girl, wait is it not, see, yeah the golden seed, no see, see, he said
golden seed, right, base template and appearance, are we even bothered about this stuff, what's
that, honestly that's like the color of me, just make the hair black, that's actually me
like right now, cause I don't know, let me sip my tea to see if it's cold enough here, okay,
oh actually me, a reef lander, a face from a far away isolated land of reefs, wink wink,
I know it says reeds but I'm just gonna say reefs, where blood is a familiar say, reef
flings, I think that's uh, check it out, whoa, we need to make it a bit bigger, we need to make
sure it claps, it was destiny, pale women jump here, how dare you, right, we'll do it, we'll be a
reef lander, it'll literally be for real girl, right, and then detail the appearance, what's my
voice, are we really bothered about any of this, some folk are bothered, I'm not really that
bothered, cause literally the first thing we do is slap some armor on us, so yeah, Fondula has
been created even though she's in my image, but look, this goes out to Fondula, you were a fantastic
name choice, I'm sorry I couldn't make it happen, okay, sorry Fondula, couldn't make it happen,
no, before anyone else, yeah, anyone in Gen2 have a funny name like that, no, no, I didn't, oh can you
hear, the fallen leaves tell a story, so crying
the great Elden Ring was shattered
in our home, across the fog, the lands between
rise ye tarnished, I still remember that, rise ye tarnished, now queen marica the eternal
is nowhere to be found
and in the night of the black knife, god win the gold, who's first to perish, I just start swinging
violently, run, soon marica's offspring, demigods all, Stacey Milken, I thought Stacey Milken was funnier
than Fondula bosom to be honest, I mean, I guess it is Fondula bosom, I hardly even know her
the mad taint of their newfound strength, sorry we're dropping the lore, triggered the shattering
oh Keran beat is so good if I had a cs go player, all the names are reserved so, if I get a cs go player
I'm calling her Keran beat, I already have all the assets
oh maybe I should get a mercy to post a thing about that in the timeline, it's like time traveller
goes back and kicks a rock and then like alternative universe and then I'll show you what Keran's assets
uh mercy's assets
rise now, you tarnished, rise now, you dead, who yet live
the call of long lost rich speaks to us all
oh why the games insist on white freaking screen
or a loom, chieftain of the badlands
the ever brilliant gold mask
fear the deathbed companion
a lonesome dung eater
boom we don't like it
gold mask is literally me, we're autistic, oh this gold mask got the tism
stroney are you peeling in reeflings, I can shake the dust off
of, yes, yes this is a stream snipe game, yes sorry I'm sorry if I didn't explain
follow the call would have been better
if it doesn't present it, no there's no feeling, sorry
if it goes on an attachment they can get it
I have been breathed to lay
cross the fog to the lands between
to stand before the Elden Ring
and become the Elden Lord
right I'm slurped my tea but yes this is a stream
sniping, how is someone dying right here, press E
how is someone dying here
bro what did you take poison damage and just perish, right can I even remember how to play
this game, oh my god, wait why is it giving me keyboard, stop giving me keyboard input, please
only give me controller input
stop giving me keyboard input right now
oh no, why are you giving me keyboard input
chapel of ant, why are you giving me input, stop it, subtitles are on that's fine
no, yeah how do you
why is the interact, wow
oh I just, it was just on sheet, oh god
it's, wow, big and then
okay
hold shield, big swing, short swing, big swing, okay jump, what does X do, okay
what does B do, oh B back off, B for back off, okay it's been a while, I'm a bit rusty, I'm a bit
rusty, see, oh why is it a stream sniping game, it is a stream sniping game
oh
you can change to show only control, yes I did, I'm a smart B
but oh don't you dare, you jump off ahead, oh he's, he's, he's, oh it's Ranny
all right hold on let me finish my tier else this isn't happening
yeah game sound is very loud
even the ambience, right we're just getting selfs, don't worry, don't worry, we're just getting
master volume but it's too loud so shove it down to a sub, is there anything in particular
that would be good, music is good but S effect's way too high, right put that down by five
I don't know, this is a whack
this is my voice whilst I'm whacking and doing combat
wow much better, we want to hear more of your voice, okay there we go, we tested it,
everyone happy, nice, nice a lot better, okay let me finish this tier else it's gonna go cold
did I miss anything, well there is no voice, oh well from the
the people, listen it's just X swing, exactly that's the S effect you're getting, nothing else
because I'm not out to start there, you need to get a multiplayer password as well, yes I cannot
call you in yet until I unlock a site of grace, would anyone like to site of grace, wow look at that
the pretty firefly, I know it's not fireflies and it's from that but you will not believe your eyes
lit up like a firefly, bit up the world as I fell asleep, what will the password be, probably
Reef, R-E-E-F, if you hold Y and press right bumper you can two hand the axe, why right bumper,
actually get your factually right, wait you can beat people up with this, take this and this
wow, yo, okay let's see, hold on let's unequipped, no sorry wrong thing, let's unequipped my shield
for the purpose that I wanted just two hand with the axe, how does one take off a shield, unequipped
well, oh I forgot how this shape works, equipment, equipment, obviously there's equipment and not
anything works, why would you, right I'm un-equipped it and then take the axe, what was it, you can throw
punches in this game, oh my god imagine him waltz by a punch, um zero death shield bash run, I think
I bet you there's, I used to watch Elden Ring content and it used to be like one,
one mage versus like three Rannas, like that kind of thing, it was like three Rannas versus like
18 Elden thingies and like you know like I don't know if you've seen those videos, I just used to
watch them and be like huh I'm so entertained right now, it was complete brain rot, Elden Ring brain rot
what was your cheat code, hold y and then press the right bumper
oh there we go, I was holding the left bumper, wow, oh my god I'm actually a one-handed, well
two-handed warrior, oh my god right I've almost finished my tea
and then the weathlands, oh I need to get a piece of paper to make sure I make it as fair as possible
now before I'm going to start fighting with the accusations in my head, before someone goes
favoritism would you rather a streamer that doesn't interact with you,
does they play video games with you and does they make an effort to have you on stream,
yes or no, no you don't want that, so if I accidentally let someone in when that someone
else hasn't even been in, has anyone any fucking accusations, right and I even got a piece of paper
I'm actually gonna have to go get a piece of paper, do excuse me for a moment little
everything, I don't have the paper
well I don't even know
so
and actually the piece of paper has uh it's actually an old piece of paper that I used to use to track
the girl's scripts, do you want me to leak some content because I'll do it right now
I'll do it right now
oh there's like I could only leak Azur's apparently I only wrote Azur's on this for some reason
uh oh hell oh I don't need to
okay I gotta live strong anyway she yells please stop shouting I'm getting all hot and bothered
yeah it depends on the leakage I've got a plot theme when
in August Azur has a giant test audio apparently I don't know if I wrote it or not yet
um September she has a reach around for
she has bulk worship as well in September hopefully that was well well this little piece of paper says
this is a big uh leg bump bumping leg bumping
holy shit I have the what this has notes from the interviews that I gave the girls
no way I wrote everyone's time zone down oh my god I have the other
I have two other applicants that didn't make it through time zone because I was trying to see
oh my god yes someone from Japan almost got in someone from England almost got in holy
wow this is an old archivable piece of paper that I picked up just to write everyone's name in it
don't throw that away keep it no it's got information of people that weren't even talents this is old
is your uh hyper fixation is cooking do you get favorism that's so specific no no one gets
favorism my reeflings are a little squid like looking thing and everyone's the same and you
all look the same and no one has any difference and that's the way it should be shouldn't it
yeah veal or history is worth millions I'm not so sure about that you give me a bit too much
fake now if oh my god that was so cool right so if I use left trigger I use my auto right we
are gonna get absolutely walloped here how do you run in this game hold down a nope let's jump
hold down x that's oh it's hold down b we are gonna get walloped cheeky thank you for coming
I remember no I am not fighting this freaking boss I don't know where oh shit maybe oh wait it screamed
me to death
did I miss something a lot of poison damage or something
a scream a siren scream I'm literally a siren
are you squid mirror now
bennix brian I can't join until much later sadly keep mama safe fellow reeflings oh seven
um I think we're doing eight hours today unfortunately I need to get work done I have
terrible news about what I achieved yesterday after stream uh I ended up rotting in the bath
I'm all clean and I smell like lemon now at least and my hair isn't greasy
um
torrent torrent hello America hi
don't worry torrent fortune is on her side
we found her here after all
wow
that's my one of her kind is sure to seek the elden ring
wow even if it does violate the golden order
um
my personal conspiracy the horses named torrent to make it harder no I'm pretty sure that
I'm pretty sure they got proven
dev team was like yeah nah cuz we spent too much time on this and love and effort and I mean
sorry this game quality well then again Japanese work history everyone works overtime for free so
that kind of but hopefully maybe the soft form uh soft form soft wear wear form soft form wear
something something like that um okay down on the d-pad to heal
uh tutorial area is down here just the like spin on the camera is actually rather strange
brave tarnish take the plunge of learning and remembrance recall the art of war and your
words but yes I absolutely am going to take this because it's
switching items use egg oh my god like the camera's rather old
form soft I said everything but what it's called said everything but what it's called
catchphrase
right wait have I got a man I look badass I go away hold on barbarian women for gentoo
and oh my god it's one hit because of the two-handed boss feels good man
oh my god yeah yeah yeah garden sure sure sure I ain't garden nothing garden's nuts
she's swinging wait hold on I missed I missed I missed
honestly Azura kind of already covers that I got a third concept back um which I'm quite pleased
with materials and every corner one you'll find fruit and flowers mushrooms and butterflies and
various other materials these materials can use for crafting I cannot for the life me remember
if I crafted anything is there something back there I think there's a bad guy back there oh no
it's a two-handed big boy parry this you little shite oh I love two-handed what the heck
what the heck it's so easy you just break everyone's stance and my toes are out this is
the best why was that bothering where samurai sorry last time I'm a samurai and a warrior in one
I'm a strong samurai oh I'm good to get in bud
oh my wait whoa oh sorry I thought I still had a bit of health there oh my god I love two-handed
skills and habits have abilities and skills use your left trigger to use your skills oh my god
oh please
crouching crispy oh that's right I need to lock on to enemy I got it
I am one mommy don't need her carry no I don't please don't think uh me going through where the
enemy is at this enemy please do not think that me uh success success but doing the tutorial
is actually an indication that things are going well for me and I'll be all right it is not
stance breaking charge right trigger uh and right trigger while jumping that's my favorite
oh my god oh my god I love it here oh my god oh my god the stake of marica upon dying
you will be revived at the last side of grace that you visited however if there's a stake of
marica near where you died you can just be revived
so if you tell me I'm excited to play this game with you again
I'm just a wee bit excited right where's the boss oh wait hold on let me lock on let me lock in
hold on a minute press right trigger immediately after a block to do a guard yeah yeah yeah yeah
blocking sure sure blocking ah you're not actually supposed to freaking oh yeah yeah yeah you can kill
me first time okay maybe two-handed warriors literally always for me because why was that so easy
okay I should have been two-handed from the start is the game a bit loud
sorry maybe in the fights it gets loud let's let's have a little invest immigration of the
audio said that put it is quite loud okay it's now five
this is the talking whilst combat and things are being enabled
strutting wants to hold it two-handed can I I mean I already shrug it my hands and you know
generic length strength oh how do I do gestures again I can't remember is it off on the d-pack no
it can't be the d-pack that has to be something else
wait I can hold that oh that's how I look I don't have enough for two-handed no refling are you sure
my hands are actually pretty small I'm not gonna win in start menu on the right
oh is this just oh my god oh my god our journey begins all over again it's amazing isn't it
unfortunately we don't have a key to explore this yet but don't think we won't
let me put my headset off of it because I think my headset's quite low actually
I've got a clip to gesture
can I do it already can you guys already come in my game will we take on the horse guy
oh rise up my little reef flings oh my god we're gonna see
yes oh my god it's been so long it's been so long
and in the end it did matter because I can
right uh uh right okay hold on hold on right multi-player yep that's good
uh set a password and it's gonna be capital it's gonna be reef in capital letters okay
reef reef you're not trying to solo the bosses no see this is the best part about my stream okay
you you get to carry me through the entire game you can leave a gold summon sign to play
oh no wait
does that not have it yet is anyone here I'm looking for a gold but you I might not have
unlocked it because I don't have you have to summon us from the signs you need another I am
man man I hate it here what do you mean I can't have my reef
get to the building pass the sentinel okay we're gonna talk right here
oh yes tarnished are we come to the lands between for the Elden Ring
hmm of course you have no shame in it unfortunately for you however you are made of
um no I got my reef lens and I'm gonna run a train on them
your words funny man mean nothing to me to the round table hold you are fated it seems
to die yeah yeah sorry your words mean nothing to me funny man right where's
can I right we're going to go to the church
uh but we need to avoid the horse guy
because I look all the dead blood as opposed to live blood but I guess blood's only live if it's
inside the user that created the blood no actually that's a lie because you can
you can put blood in other people that's your blood as long as you're all negative or you're
sure the same blood type do you know if you're all negative yeah you have the most valuable
blood type and oh wait I forgot wait hold on hold B to run yeah hold B to run yes yes
I have a rune flag go to the right go to the right where is he oh right we're in the church
see here is the church and here is the people something else and it rains so it's steeple
but I don't know how it goes because I never remember anything and he's make all fun again
I've completely got somebody here and I'd admit at Smith and Table you can spend some runes and
things to strengthen your can I strengthen it right now
I mean is it a waste if I strengthen it right now oh it goes up so much it's not
additional items required well you know what I tried hello wait is there a sign there is a mark of
grace wait this guy says okay oh yeah I need like a crack pot or something to craft so
oh hello oh hi you're a tarnished I am I can see it yes I am but I can also see
that you're not after my throat no thank you then why not purchase a little something yes please
I am Carly purveyor of fine goods I too am a purveyor of a sort maybe just the pair of
purches oh a little gold I remember it's this
reveals co-op in hostile okay we need a thousand souls don't worry reeflings I'ma get you out of
there I'ma get you I need to just go kill the bad guys that are over here I'm pretty sure they're
really low level yes there's soldiers over here I'ma get you reeflings I need to buy it I just need
to make a little more money all right sorry souls not money hey you you're getting jumped
okay that's how much we're at 600 souls you guys can see my soul count which is good
all right we've got guy here
wow we did it we did it we did it we did it and the thing is when you guys come into the
lobby please don't hurt the turtle or the way of life that are nice though because we don't want
to hurt anything that doesn't mean us any harm okay because we must respect nature we have to live
with them so um oh my god does that mean I get to see you now I'm gonna wait oh god what's that you
play Elton ring the complete wrong way that the dev team doesn't want you to play it don't care
don't care get to see my reeflings don't care yes yes yes please please please give it give it to
me Rachel show it to me please uh can I spawn you guys in here hold on hold on let me get up let
him go let him go
oh no are you here reefling
I assume everyone using the code is a reefling right what did that say eight what did that say
eight her or something I do need an enemy reefling if someone wants to be an enemy please do come in
because I don't want to be invaded I get scared of being invaded um norm uh of the cross and calm
can someone be a mean reefling so I don't get invaded and we can enjoy our play time you can
summon two friendlies but I need one enemy I need an enemy I need a lot of enemy need an enemy
enemy reefling enemy reefling I don't see a red I don't see a red the multiplayer password is
refold on let me uh actually pin that in chat I need an enemy yes I need an enemy
enemy enemy give me an enema sorry I'm so excited right now right let me pin the password in chat
password me
me
I did it enemy you're not an enemy no you're good what are you giving me a hero's
wait you're leveling me up this is cheating ah enemy reefling I got enemies what's your name
ah
okay all done wait eight par what's your full name where are you eight eight per
h dealer as an anti each dealer that's my unique name
oh everyone wants to be my enema I don't think they do it oh more wait octopus head oh because
we're reefling oh my god wait how did I put it on my head equipment head
and then I need to drop these because I actually picked up too many
oh squiddle gang squiddle gang right had I dropped the head though
uh go to inventory
did I drop drop lead discard oh I don't have a drop feature I do have a drop feature because
I was how would the reeflings how did be able to do that oh my god we have coconuts that can
talk to each other I forgot about that I spanked wait why is there a fight music
because of the red reefling
oh you're activating the fight music right well we go beat up this horse guy or is that a terrible idea
uh
maybe that's a terrible idea how about we make our way to the first lake town I think that's safe
we'll leave the horse guy and come back to him and absolutely wall of home how about that
octopus gang oh I can see some children oh look see look there I don't know if you see an instance
in your game but look those are the soldiers they killed to spawn you in
look at all those chickens right whatever we're doing it let's go cool wow what was that move
oh my god he literally goes and all the attack comes out he goes uh
I don't want to hurt you but you want to hurt me right leave me alone I'm not going to hurt you
I don't want to hurt me right I believe there's a town over here
I know I was probably supposed to be attacked but we're just gang ganging up ooh there's whatever
this is a little Marco is that boar still targeting me it is look we're trying to do
the reeflings oh my god look at the spark he literally crossed them across the map
we're reading and pillaging we're reading and pillaging
oh there's a bad guy here okay why you're using magic this is so cool oh my god there's the big
baddie let's get him go ouchy I hurt my tummy but it's okay it's okay I hurt my tummy a little
oh my god yeah take that um head off hurt all of that well go away oh it's an enemy too oh no no no no no no
I got over excited I'm sorry reeflings no don't disappear um steak of maraca we walked past
I got too excited I got too excited I know the reeflings didn't fail I'm sorry I got too excited
death upon die yes I did need to die okay let's try again I you know you didn't fail me
oh no I need to buy more
I did wait I need to go back I need to go back to the man to get more hold on
okay you're next I need more reeflings
I need to go back to the shop
um get a crafting item sir yes sir I will I someone gave me runes to claim so I'm gonna
claim the runes and then we should have all the bits and all I need is someone following
no there was an animal that's what I heard there's an enema enema enema give them a
um right I need to stop saying that word
okay let's try it wait weren't you well you're back care to buy something did you know I passed the
way how did you know right no claim the runes first on my inventory right sorry hold on
yeah goodbye for now uh for for literally two seconds right in my inventory I have
big big room oh my god that's 50,000 bro we're not even gonna have to do any level
enough we're gonna be clearing areas so easily don't click oh don't
sorry sorry you're right don't claim them I'm so sorry I may have wasted a little bit of it right
right container required for crafting I am crafting a paw and then give me a couple
I can get four of these sure and then I assume these items really aren't much of an upgrade
oh no it doesn't compare to my current where does it no hmm I am crafting okay I can never make
items so oh I can make these for free already what are they
oh I didn't need to buy anything that would have been cheaper if I bought the same oopsies
like it was an honest mistake it was an honest mistake right I am use let's see what replays
I got oh there's an enemy replay right you'll get you'll come in an enemy
right at the same time yeah but you need okay I need to make sure I don't die because I don't want
to waste 90k runes apparently you can see uh norm oh you actually came in no what
I know I fucked up but I do apologize but like um what happens is the list gets reset
something since like you came in before
and then but yeah at some times it doesn't like display your thingy my barber oh my god wait
you're doing oh you're naked are you doing that Japanese thing tiny commission does that not
bring you in uh you're trying to come in he's doing the thing he's doing the thing he's making
oh there's a new one you're right okay we got the game no this time I better not mess up and
actually use my healing potions because I have a lot of souls on me next I agree so you receive a
maiden replays the veteran protecting your queen no I got over zealous I was like in the middle of
a fight and I didn't heal what's this oh you're ballooning oh my god you're using a tombstone
as a shield that's outrageous that's funny though is anything whoa you look funny too oh my god
you're the gen two oh we need the coconuts so we can talk to each other I don't have a coconut
yet I don't have a coconut right let's go let's go hit the town let's go beat up all the purgards
but they're aggressive to us so I don't really feel too bad I don't know why they have such a
problem with the tarnish like shot color there's no shock color because um for some reason I need
to hand over and get a code in order to use the hardware that I bought and I don't really understand
why I would need to do that um so I don't really trust it I am going to try and get a burner phone I
think uh just to be able to shock myself or I'll look into another caller because yeah I don't know
why a company needs my actual phone number just so I can shock myself in an app like I don't know
I don't know if you guys know whoa what was that oh I saw you charge that up
uh I mean I guess if the board is aggressive I'll let you do it
burner phone seems smart yeah please insert your social security number to literally it feels like
oh there's kind of cute wherever these are
uh it was like a Chinese company sorry to be that freaking weirdo but like legit it's
like a Chinese company and I'm like why the fuck do you need my phone number for me to zap
myself like no I don't I don't I don't trust it right okay let's be vigilant we flink let's be vigilant
let's be whoa gang violence oh shit
wait are you punching are you doing punching only refling oh I'm at stamina out I forgot about a
stamina bar I didn't even remember that was a thing oh my god we're getting slaughtered leave that
rippling alone he's mine not yours okay I need to get my xp back ow I just got wallet
leave my rippling alone
did we do it no no no yeah
oh no no more more more oh this is the map I remember it's the map of Lindgren we're in
the location Lindgren oh there's my life thank you I got my souls back uh isn't there something
at the back of here I'm pretty sure there is I'm like 99% sure there's an item back there
oh no there's no wait there is I didn't eat like a first thing what is it
it's a flea are you I'm not gonna lie that scared me that scared me there's an underground
cellar okay wait let me heal up oh wait why is it swapping oh x to heal up on whatever the
eye is uh a cellar is like over oh I found it
take me to cheer oh is this where I get a turtle talisman I think it is I think this is the
portal hello little portal oh what's up storm stomp uh western it's so creepy a wet the knife oh no
you're blocking the way oops I like how I can't go through you know what's going on up here
if any of you nervous I receive okay I'm going to claim this gravestone but I think it despawns
you guys already oh but um but I need to level up thank you for helping me clear out Lindgren
is there anything in the back of this one oh wait this is the front of it there is
long great sword is that better than what I have equipment
I can't read that
uh
why does this why is the 54 in red next to 106 why is it in red so this weighs more
why is it in red number in blue is better than what you're holding yeah so why does it say physical
power 54 oh negative 54 lack of dexterity oh okay okay okay we're getting there we're getting
there in the end right let's oh no what's that how did you even coordinate that that doesn't make
any sense how you all figured out how to do that what's I'm freaking mucking about how do I wait I
can't activate it why can I not activate it send them home I don't want to send you home
can I I can't activate it when you guys are with me I don't send you home I don't
know
oh they send themselves home
oh they have to send themselves home I don't know the saver saver saver oh well they didn't form
oh right okay you guys have to go with saver
vanquish enemy groups vanquishing an enemy group replenish your flasks I do like that
mechanic adding skills with a waystone knife you can use ashes of war that grants a new skill
add affinity with the knife you can use ashes of war to grant affinity to your
armor this way you can alter interest curious I'm not smart enough to understand half of the
things going on but it doesn't matter because I get to play with the replay and we get to experience
when you see her she'd be so in a brothel sorry I said that greetings
traveler from beyond the fog I am melana hello
wow look at that for the course
I offer you an accord
have you heard of the finger maidens
they serve the two fingers offering guidance and aid to the tarnished
hmm but you I am afraid are maidenless no I've got my weapons they're literally all around you
women look behind you turning rooms into strength to aid you in your search for the elton ring
you need only take me with you yes my lady to the foot of the earth tree
I accept then it settled summon me by grace to turn rooms into strength
ah another matter yes madam I bequeath to use this ring yes
I
use it to traverse great distances it will summon a spectral steed named torrent
torrent has chosen you
treat him with respect yeah I see as I accidentally fall off glass all the time so now I turn my
rooms to strength oh my god we're gonna touch
my hand rest upon I got my feet and everything for this for a better moment share them with me
okay your thoughts your ambitions so what happens if I do strength the principles you would follow
strength is just straight up attack and that
so what I want to put it in strength we bit of vinegar
and a wee bit of day that's pretty little with arcane that's magic
faith is low endurance and I need 10 dexterity if I want to upgrade the weapon okay I can do that
I mean I can do quite a lot considering how much runes the refunds gave me you need 10
and
fit it all into strength I don't mind getting my xp bar a bit bigger the reason for higher xp
so I don't fuck it up and then keep de-sinking and then we have to keep calling in more refunds for
more reinforcement and bigger bigger yeah strength and dexterity are both attacked just on different
weapons okay so I'm strength because of the way I'm handling that yeah okay yes please
um what a blast add a blast uh yes add a blast add a blast yeah I don't have enough
those things right so now I can pop everything
oh no oh whoa whoa whoa it's getting too much from pouch in the main menu you can equip six
items to your pouch four of those items can be used without opening the menu just press y
in this in combination you're giving me far too much information at once hold on we need to equip
torrent no not use equipped so equip it from here
okay
okay okay right let me pop all my runes and then we'll call in the reflings and then we're going
to storm the castello oh my god I'm like I this is going to be such an easy guy we're going to be
doing the dlc section of the game and like five hours at this rate
that's fantastic use select multiple oh my apologies uh use the selected number all five yes please
oh my god I didn't have to do anything
and talk about a princess carry right uh strength strength and strength and strength and strength
and strength and strength and strength and strength and strength brah I'm already in the freaking
sixties right let's do like and then some more in health because I don't want to keep desinking by
accident the strength and health do you want to be like the dlc um a wee bit but maybe not too
much because uh this is going to be like back-to-back endurance streams a sneak fling it's a little
replaying right a sneak fling welcome man who are you you're just a fella quite literally you're
just a fella man you're just doing your thing but I need enemies I need enemies when y'all there's no
enemies where are my enemies I need an enemy weflin I need you to invade with the password
reef and then it means we're safe to explore as much as we want what are you doing are you oh is
this a hug but really weird you look like a medusa statue with your outfit but I think that's
the other enemy enemy refling off oh no we're gonna get invaded oh no okay there we go enemy
you have no enemy oh well I need an enemy refling and I think the dlc recommends level 150
oh no that just means you have even more time with me then while we play the dlc and the base
game well you didn't have a base game safe fail no I wanted to go from the start it's not an adventure
if you're already finished half of it wow you look scary oh you got jellyfish shield look at your
jellyfish what is on your head though I can't make it out because you're all red you look like some
sort of bull I'm not sure what your head is isn't new are you medusa because you just made me stone
hard oh what's this oh a bouquet of flowers oh but isn't this not a super good weapon shouldn't
I not drop this for you because I can't use it oh that's the guy that calls us made unless
into I is wait you want it back because it's actually a decent weapon for magic players
and you only get one you only get one a match oh oh no the more thing why I got three I don't
have to be anything right will we storm the castello are we ready ready steady on your mark get set
three two one go start in the cast oh shit I just I just locked on to the reef one
start in the castle start in the castle it's a suicide mission but we're gonna
I forgot I completely forgot oh no leave my wavelength alone
oh he's down he's down jump on jump on leave every person I'm fucking it up but that's okay
stop sniping then fight us like a man ow wait hold on I need to recharge my stamina take this
we did it we started the castle oh there's a wee item for me and pick up here what is that
it's a golden ring so we can level up even more rattle them boys make them scared uh
sniffling you might need to heal a little bit because you're half health I don't know how many
push uh how many flasks we have but you need to be careful because if you did spawn I can't get you
oh
teamwork two wheels good luck sucks to suck
um what's up here I can't quite recall I think it gets a bit windy up here yep it does get
windy up here but that's okay I feel really I feel really brave because I got my replays
it's cool okay up the hill up the hill we go as we storm the castello
I've got a sword it's four two huns I've actually got an axe
okay surprise wolves apparently uh uh I'm helping I'm helping see did you see me slay all those
wolves ah there see I slayed them all I did it all myself I didn't even need any help for all
hmm you want a minimum of 40 health for the dlc I comprehend I will keep that into account oh no
but you have to go you have to go if I activate this I'll go talk to the lady in the shack I
remember a lady in the shack but what are you a keystone star oh I need these hello oh no don't
be scared everyone's been grafted yeah you won her game with me they crossed the sea for me
they fought yeah it's not only to have their arms taken actually quite like her color scheme
blonde hair with red and white that's a quarry oh no he's falling down for her taken and stuck
to the spider did you know only the invader has to leave for you to bonfire oh no invader is that
true when you think about it mister invader refling you're all on your own I'm heading to store
and ticed by the one in the royal that makes it but I don't have your it's scary you know having
your arms I want to be like why would you want your honor but I'm missing but okay is it true
oh no it's true my poor invader reflings have to get kicked out and back in again every time we find
a thing uh refling tisker refling tisker I actually that's actually pronounced tisker
did you not know that tisker okay oh wow what is this no not I am crafting
sorry equipment what did you give me I need decks there you're 15 to hold it
let's go oh my god look at your outfit oh what's this wow great sword wait I'm gonna be too weak
to hold it this can't be true I need 12 things there stink
uh what more oh my gosh oh marica's ruin wait but isn't that no like super rare
how do you get more of her ruin and more than one game what are your stats uh yeah
they are here my statistics are 28 53 strength and we're only like one minute into this game
refling talk about being a sugar daddy honestly right shall we storm the castle again
are we ready are we steady oh wait hold on he picked this up what is this I've never even seen
this cousin ever played to hand it I've never seen this iron
what are you oh my oh my god oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry I was too busy flexing on this thing
I'm so sorry uh what do I do hold y and press right bumper there boom just like that
I'm so sorry little refling I just gave him the biggest spank of his life okay now we'll storm
the castello are you ready on your mark get set three two one go I'm already running out of stamina
but it's okay I'll level up my stamina soon okay maybe I should slow down a bit for this enemy
ahead right well I'm gonna use my ultimate
he's in the air oh no refling no um invader refling you'll need to be careful when we engage in
fights though because I'll end up walloping you I'm sorry you must be careful you don't want
walloped again I'm gonna hurt you too much music's a bit loud wow
music down to four music is down to four tell me how you think that fine you find that
astrony min max calls yeah don't make me hit you I'll do it no leave my
oh my god I have so much oh sugar that takes all my stamina okay I definitely need some uh decent
uh
oopsies we're just getting a wee bit of a barrage don't worry it's just a wee barrage we need to
go around in school who is doing that stop it you're hurting my vehicle don't be so sick
what is something shooting at me from there uh I'm not gonna bother with him
wow okay
shall we uh ferris okay everyone back out so everyone gets a fair chance to go again
go again everyone please back out little weaklands if that's okay you guys too because
you've got to take me to the castle and we have forged the castle and then we give everyone a fair
chance touch grace the government okay here we go oh no I'm sitting down oh well it's not a bad
thing if I sit on you I guess okay oh I would like to ask who is sitting on me who are somewhere
just someone's on me uh level up oh I can't level up but that's okay oh I can't level up
because the rifling gave me a ton of runes many reasons give me some I've got one of these
22 wow I've got one of these
I'm not even gonna have to play this game properly I'm all
up
oh my god oh my god why are you 80 000 oh sorry I forgot to do the multiple one
this is crazy
oh my goodness right someone said I had to be for a health in order to do the dlc
so I will keep that in mind when I level up right now
and I mean it means I like have less likely to die
right we got to 42 and 53 strength yeah that that looks good minimum 48 ideal 60 12 dexterity
12 dexterity
level 42 I know talking about being carried wait so is this weapon I have
uh is something else there what would you say that that says 70 but this has an
a fire ultimate
wait is that there oh wait no this is way better magic value
a great sword is better than
wait hold on press y no no hold on okay well we're just reset to get another flash glip sees I
pressed x by accident okay now press y and then press the rate bumper there we go
drill wheels like that okay let's get it uh I don't recognize your name can you get to come in
wow right I wrote down your name I need an invader did we need an invader reflinger for
doing a boss I mean I guess probably
and you come I will have my greatest refling warriors and now if you lose I don't know what to
say look I ain't get a video game so I'm just here for a good time can an invader come over
the the fence at the fence like that that wall can an invader come through it I don't I don't recall
I don't think there's any invader refling at all but that's okay it doesn't have to be
I think because we're about to do this uh okay oh wait there's not even a thing for it can you
guys oh no wait are you guys gonna disappear if I activate the cutscene you guys can't follow
because you have a gate there oh no I didn't think this through I didn't think this through
in search of the elder
emboldened by the flame of ambition
honestly me when I get off the chair after a good stream
but yeah that was a good stream stream session oh wait sorry that sounded I didn't mean to make
it sound like that please reflings please reflings can you come in reflings come in right now
I'm scared okay I still have the buff I still have the buff okay let's see how this works
leave him alone he didn't deserve it oh no
beat him up refling violence refling violence
oh he's got a hammer who's he locked onto not me
oh I missed sorry sometimes I think my sword's a bit longer than it actually is
oh I'm getting critical on him I'm not doing the least amount of damage you guys are the ones
with a debuff I just I maybe need to level up the great card leave him alone
take this let's go we did it we absolutely realized the first four I'm the one achievement
for doing it I didn't even do anything
oh I didn't even do anything oh you're starting on him you're starting on him
we did it it's so easy it was so easy
oh this is fantastic thank you so much reflings I'm literally have like happy tears in my eyes
right now this is ridiculous
I'm like so leveled up I'm really so high up
yes I'm fit to face the challenges I get carried to the entire cube
had to measure from the very start there's I'm nearly oh I'm like crying happy tears right now
I can do it for you guidance I can give you to the round table whole gathering place
okay round table I'm not the the round table that's fantastic by grace okay yes let's go to the round table
I think lower wise I'm supposed to
wow I've never seen anyone beat margaret at fast you're so good at this game
underscore a pass thank you this day tan actually I'm so good at this game oh my god I can hardly
breathe right okay um what happened here I introduced myself to everyone oh I see you've just arrived
yes I'm new here welcome to the round table hold hello I'm corrin hi corrin yes I teach incantations
the strength granted us uh unfortunately I'm not into magic so probably it'll be our only
conversation but I thank you for being kind enough to explain yourself to me like what you do in
stuff not like explain yourself to me you're not in trouble I might counsel them ensuring order
against its proper form writing rule over men yes yes by the way do you still see it
the guidance see I can't see anything out of this helmet I'm gonna be honest uh I don't really see
you do wonderful news most tarnished are blind to it these days you are something of a rare breed
rare what do you say care to learn an incantation of the two fingers
nah I'll be okay I think uh well is the shop over here I think there's a shop here
if I'm not mistaken like hello oh you don't you don't speak because you're a husk um
do we need anything I don't even think we need anything you guys have literally sugar
daddied me an elden ring so I'm waving away my happy tears I think you guys have sugar daddied
me so much an elden ring whole strict take an appearance of a cooperator oh I quite like that
of a host of finger breeding mentioned okay I'll buy the keys for you increase memory slots
that's for magic people though answer requests for summoning from hunters when invaded request
the aid of a hunter grants the blessing of an I don't even know what that is can I open you
please the door and then the message okay that's got the dung here inside my memories are slowly
coming back of this game are you getting in no you're not you don't talk oh she doesn't talk okay
that's fine can you get a fourth person in with the white requestering no I don't think so hello
who are you I don't really recognize you he must be you here I'm well just call me de allos the honor
of one's house holds little import in these lands yeah have you met a young woman named lanya on your
travels lanya she's my servant but fickle was the way that the lady that we met and she's good
has gone if you find her please be sure to tell me okay sure uh right we need to talk to the smith
hello
you're a new face I am no matter it's all the same yeah lay out your arms let's get smithy
he uh does not mess around is this already got an ash of war on it it doesn't should I even bother
it like lord no no thank you I will go say hi to fear and then I think we're jumping straight back
into it hi fear hi hi greetings great champion called by grace hello I am fear hi fear circumstances
have compelled my stay at the round table hold great champion would you allow me to form something
a really restrictive cap on the number of players that can be in a session share with me
some wait gs3 can have six people doing so will grant me the warmth of a champion and you
is that she means cat yeah she's cat do you think vulgar perhaps where I come from
it is a secret you can have friends like this in Elden Ring where you guys carry me through the game
that'll let her hold me that I get much of a debuff if she hugs me
I think the debuff goes away if I perish right
uh I can't remember yeah hug her okay hello my thanks great she quite literally steals life force
doesn't she
hello oh my god it's us at the convention for real for real oh yellow oh head pat on the
you are very warm use a wee bit of max health but I get a blessing for it what you felt light up
inside you was a boulder kins blessing a ball back in but a fleeting thing I am afraid come back
to me should you require another okay I will take you in my arms as often as you need okay
thank you for stealing some of my life force but you know I got something out of it so it's okay
where's it Elden Ring teaches you to avoid the comfort of women real
real what does it mean use it what is this is this dlc I don't ever recall interactive with this
there you go you got a few books scattered around yeah you did some late reading darling I bet you are
great late reading these okay I think I'm interactive with everything I can
unless I miss someone in the great hole I thought Gideon was around here big gitty
did you know at the time
you did I open you I do open you the door is blocked hmm I thought Gideon
are you not good oh Gideon's in this room here okay that can't get access yet but that's okay
we don't need it okay let's zoom out where were we last yes we were we're at
margit the fell all men yeah you just passed them open
do I need to talk to him or can I go for it can I just go next can we just go next does that look
you need to get to the next grass something oh this one to work actually now that you're
seeing that out loud to me oh I'm so scared to move without you guys
so you're storming the castello I think I don't know when the next one is but I'm scared because
you guys aren't with me oh thank god I've never been so happy to see a saint grace of my life
oh my god literally the fear that's why I wanted to do the heart rate monitor about freaking loss
that I can't find it I wanted to show you like no I actually get terrified when I'm trying
uh can I actually you know what I'm gonna do something really smart are you ready for this
wait whoa wait can I not I quit I forgot how to I quit
oh
that one can I put something on it
yes and then if I hit y and then left
I see reflux uh cutie oh
I don't see you can we are there I am there I am so I need to like write your name down and
then I can summon you in or else it's not gonna work gab you were an enemy though
actually I might have to write who's an enemy because it's not really quite the same
did I just make a noise
okay I'm gonna put a little red next to your name if you're an invader I'm so sorry but I can't
recall who the other invaders were oh wait I can because of the way I've done the list
harmony was an invader drake was an invader gar was an invader
which means oh no
then am Sean was an invader oh no well I tried I tried okay I'll just put a little note that
you're an invader if I think you're an invader just to be like oh well you haven't actually like
played I'm sorry I'm trying my best was refling Tisker was an invader oh
wait no my list is wrong then why did I fuck up so badly oh wow oh my god Lordran
oh my god you know we're not even gonna have to play this game we're just gonna like wall of them
how many whoa wait have you duplicated items 99 have you duplicated items or have you like
just gone absolutely nuts are you in love with this game be honest how much you play this game
how much you play this game yeah how are you giving 99 dooping isn't hard oh is it like a
duplicate getting diablo 2 treatment oh what does that mean I don't know what that means sorry
me and my friend duplicate items to save women ah okay what why are you oh oh you're like that
npc that doesn't want to talk huh yeah yeah see how it is uh are do I think I go in here and talk to
someone and come over here would you hello you you're tarnished aren't you um um yeah I would advise
against taking the main gate into the castle oh no why it's tightly guarded by hardened old
yes I recall try the opening right here uh-huh the guards don't know about it
you'll breach the castle undetected
uh very well I will heat your warning thank you yes that's the spirit you're just the kind of
tarnished that I like yeah that he's I pray for your success oh thank you that's very kind
that means a lot if you would like to know what we're looking at right we've got ready to go
we use the safe spot examine the summoning pool wait is this how I summon you guys naturally
huh I yeah uh okay nice and easy a little bit of parkour replays I'm sure you can
get her done nice and easy I don't want anyone falling off the map you can hug the wall if you're
unsure if you have it if you're a bit clumsy you're if you're a bit clumsy what oops I jumped down
oh it's the birds yeah yeah yeah good luck me is there more
I don't see anymore let's go we're storming the cat oh
it's already a great site but the purry fun's gonna have to go again you've only just been here
wait maybe yeah do we do we give you a little second chance uh whoa whoa whoa
sorry oh is that you said no please let me stay right if the refunds keep me alive you're allowed to
stay oh whoa oh whoa don't fall off the map you look so close to the edge you try to give me a heart
attack you get mommy a heart attack okay every time someone dies in a castello that guy steals 30
percent of their runes really that's kind of cool uh is there any enemy refund enemy refund
give them an animal the throngler okay we'll get you in sorry I'm so sorry to the other
bifling you literally got two seconds uh but don't worry I'm literally playing for like eight hours
so please don't be like oh no I couldn't get cold in no and then that's the thing and then
tomorrow wait that's where we spawn
that's the bridge oh we were looking at the castello literally we're playing today we're playing
tomorrow they're playing the day after we're playing the other day please don't think you won't
have an opportunity to come back in again okay and I'll I'll make the argument right biflings have
to make sure I don't die I don't want to die I got a shield marge leather oh oh bifling I'm so sorry
I didn't realize you were so close to me sorry I don't know I'm not really used to having a long
attachment like this um you're gonna have to give me a few seconds to figure it out oh my god I'm
getting like all the XP when you guys kill as well ah my tummy hurt I it appears I'm a little bit
hungry whoa look I'm oh I'm slow rolling because of my inability to do things
cheeky bits of slow rolling I can't open you I can't no you're not I can't oh no I just remember
whoa bifling are you okay oh are you okay
was that a bifling are you okay did you mean to do that
yeah you're fine jeez louise you're giving me a heart attack okay I got arrows jeez
what are your biflings it's not okay literally I'm a blink and you guys are falling from the sky
biflings I can't control you all at once there's too many I'm being overloaded oh there's nothing there
I just remember that I have to do this fight alone
oh there's gonna be enemies there is there any more enemies up here whoa that statue is that an
enemy yeah I don't fucking trust that sorry right I need to be a big girl now
I'll be right back refunds I'm sure I'll be fine I'm sure I will
I'm sure it'll be fine I'm a big girl I need to press B to dodge I need to press B to dodge
oh no swing motherfucker all the biflings can help wait I thought you can come in this room
how did you get in how did you do that I thought biflings can't come in this room
are you clapping you wait how did you get in here though
I'm so confused I thought you couldn't come in open this motherfucker thing
how did you do that when there's a will there's a way they can enter as soon as the cut scene
literally you spawned out nowhere I was like oh how do you know
we got the key so we need to go down into this door
bifling's gonna tell you something embarrassing because you're watching the stream right now I
don't mind exchanging this knowledge and I audibly farted in one of my recent streams and no one
caught it and I don't know how no one heard it because it was so loud because my little booty
cheeks clapped so I was a bit surprised I know I I feel so bad because I was like wait how did
no one notice the braptubers were supposed to be rejoiced skimming through the balls this instant
no no no no no I don't what um I don't know how you guys didn't hear it I honestly don't know there's
a wee thing over here one second brap guys archived evidence no I feel really like um like oh no that's
not a of me because I should have like told you when it happened so we could all giggle well it's an enemy
okay much better oh riefling you're in the way please be careful darlin
invader riefling you might have to stay behind just a few meters okay I don't want to hurt you by
accident and I almost got pushed off the map oh where are you you're a brick hammer a hammer made
of brick and mortar that's what I like to see right
playing the game for the first time right now it is kicking my ass any reef leaves to carry me to
sad face oh thank you for the tip boy um I'm actually sure there'll probably be reeflings that
are willing to help you out I think wait no I've already been here no I need to climb up the ladder
again oops I was supposed to go left not right I'm sure reeflings will help you
just make sure you make sure your coat is reefed
quite possible sun suppression did it stop I'll check again where I did it but you that was
scary don't do that again you might myself clear that was scary and I like 100% sure it was audible
but we maybe because like my room creeps all this oh that's an enemy that no one heard it or just tell
he's always make a reefling multiplayer quick yeah yeah yeah we have reef reef is it r e e f reef
like me uh no there's nothing on the edge because I've explored the edge before I think there's a
knight in arm my thought you were an enemy reefling you have to be careful I knew there was this bad
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa ouch he's beating my ass I need to hit him there we go get
staggered uh is there anything down here nope just imminent death let's not uh fight gravity today
multiplayer passcode is weak yes that is the pinned message for anyone who is lurking and you're
like huh whatever however we stream sniping this game um the password is reef and in multiplayer
um and oh there's a bow and arrow man how'd I get across
this
I don't know I actually don't trust that how'd I get close
this I mean if someone put down a marker there
one more ow kick me
and there's your chance of your big show yes if you're lurking and you don't understand how Elden
Ring is technically a stream sniping game we have a multiplayer passcode here um that's not at all
yeah it is top right the it's reef and fill capital letters and every sign or mark of grace
you're pointing go down you want me to go down oh reefling's showing you something
what is you what are you showing me reefling show me show me show me show me
what are you showing me oh mark of grace yes this is how uh you can stream snake mean by
mark of grace but the problem is oh you give me tons of flowers so I can make more the only
problem is I can only have two good reeflings at a time and then one naughty reefling at a time
but that naughty reefling means that we don't ever get in trouble wait that I despawn
hey how can I get uh did other reefling perish
uh other reefling oh where did you go oh no you were right there uh
set up a group password please sorry that's a group password
if you set up a you'll more likely see messages summons things and right okay reef again
what's going on wait you're not you're not a reefling wait am I confused
the dance are you not a reefling oh no
something
oh no what happened wait that was wait no it's because there's no invader reefling okay
that makes more sense I was like oh no we've got a rogue reefling
oh no okay let me get a rogue reefling in right now sorry and you come I need safety
I go so confused I was like reefling why are you attacking me the whole point is we
get to play together what why are you crying screwing on the corner
protect the princess oh that was so confusing because I'm like why would why would anyone be
a tinkerton like that that's not right oh right okay and then where's other reefling
other reefling are you in here or done need to summon another no he must be upstairs are you
upstairs reefling hello other reefling are you here there's only one yellow where the heck is
the other reefling are you up here hello I've lost them I can't I can't keep track of all my reeflings
I'm a terrible mother he died the dude no I spawned in a new one but where's the other reefling
there's an enemy there
oh no oops oops oops
wow wait is that in there oh no you're friendly sorry oh it's just
am I going crazy you spawned in an invader not a replacement did I not no I thought
ash arrow was the replacement because there was another reefling am I going I'm losing it
I'm losing it I'm not gonna make it wait we need to go back to the ash of spawn to get another
reefling I'm not going crazy am I going crazy
oh I can't spawn in a new why are you an alien oh my god you look very
ghastly yeah okay thank you sorry I don't know what happened
it lists how many reefling friends are alive on the left side okay
oh my god I'm backing it up I'm backing it up on the reeflings wait you need to block me so I can
back up on you you ready back it up hey hey I'm backing it up I'm backing it up I'm backing
we gyrating us that's going to word oh is it squitty is that what you're no it's not
pretty isn't it why are you two you're two-handed some big boys some you don't have a me to act uh
right is it this way I'm supposed to go or is it the other way I'm supposed to go
lead me reeflings you know the game better than me oh it's this way okay okay let's go
attack reeflings attack oh dear lord there's oh they have kegs they have kegs they have tnt
I repeat they have tnt the birds have adapted the birds have adapted the government has upgraded
the the drones oh no right stay away from the tnt reeflings oh my god oh my god oh my god there's
so much going on I'm just avoiding them I'm scared oh uh she broke the table with her dump
wait no I'm not to go that way wait I'm gonna go down wait what's over here
hello I'm a smithing stone I'll take it I actually don't know what level my current weapon is
I don't know if you give me a weapon it will always default to level one or does it default to
whatever like smithing level you give it oh a gold group oh is this a drop down
well that's that's pretty much that's a drop look yes drop down we out me uncle me uncle
oh there's a church oh wait wait wait someone post the copypasta someone post the copy right
reeflings we're congregating I need to do my thingy someone post the copypasta it was like
deer reeflings who art in heaven halloween I come or something like that I need to give a ceremony
oh but I don't have it on hand I don't know if someone has it or not but I will I don't uh
ceremony oh you're praying at the altar oh no you broke the two okay it's fine reeflings don't know
the wrong strength sometimes um ever mummy hallowed be thy name like yeah the the prayer one and it's
like leaders to temptation it ends with leaders to temptation okay neo before the altar I will
I will bless you all with our ceremony has someone got it uh um I can't look at marshmallow either
because I'm not laid
okay I'm sure someone's like doing a really quickly getting it up I'm sure I have faith that
the reefling oh I have a sweaty armpit oh my god I'm getting so embarrassed by me you guys I'm sweating
through my armpits I haven't sweat that much too much
hallowed be thy name is I king number okay our ceremony is in session here ye hear ye
our mummy in Villalor horny be thy name her kingdom come her bidding will be done on youtube as it is
on patreon give us this our daily nut and forgive us for our cringe as we forgive those
who cringe against us and lead us not into celibacy but instead deliver us into temptation amen
amen okay you guys now have the nut blessing the next time you know it will be amazing
yay okay we have held the ceremony let's go wow let's be above you're not a real knight in
shining armor I am because I have a bit ah because I have beaks or you didn't hear the news I have a
ginormous course oh got the nut buff literally nut buff granted oh wait is this the wrong way
I think this might be the wrong way I don't know whoa you're purple that's gonna be wait the other
yeah uh I can't remember well these over here if I'm being money
there's an item there's a cheeky gold room for you yo why he purple okay he's leading us with the
light he's our gay uh there should be oh no oh no can we snipe him from here does anyone have a
crossbow or a bow and arrow can he like wow rafling did he just jump down rafling oh goodness gravy
right call for backup call it ring the guards the guards are pretty rang oh ow ow ow ow ow ow my ears
okay geez rafling scared me I didn't really want to jump down
Oh, yeah, we flaked in on him. Oh, yeah, take that. Oh, yeah
Wow touch blood
Are you the guy that we kill a lot? We got handed
We're is it left or is it right I feel like you guys know them. Oh no follow the purple right follow the purple guy
Follow the purple. Okay. Follow the purple
Wait, hold on to me. I'm here right purple refling will lead us the correct way
Okay, we go
Oh, we all need to get on this
Let's go
Oh, sorry. I need to activate it. Sorry. Sorry. I didn't realize you couldn't
That's not nice
Oh, I see in school berries. How was your rave session?
You guys have a little rave together wait
I know this place. We've been here before do we go up the stairs now?
Where's purple refling? He's already going high snow berries. Did you enjoy getting steam in what I see?
I see nobody read. Hopefully I see gets enough hydration. I don't know. I guess like we go up here
Hello
Welcome on and I'm currently doing a stream sniping game which is elden ring. Oh surprise surprise
um
The reflings have already overpowered me an astronomical amount. We're just exploring the first castle
Unfortunately, I'm a bit all turned around and not sure where to go. But you know what?
It's about the exploring we made along the way. Wait, is this a dead end?
Have I just taken us to a dead end? That would be very thin, but I'm glad the snowberries enjoyed your rave. Oh, yeah
Steaman is one way to put it. Is she blackout?
Does that need a message her?
Hmm, you're making me nervous. Does that need a message?
Yes or no? Hi radius welcome. We're running a train on this castle. I'm to jump, but this is so dangerous
Oh, no, I'm not a fan of heights, but I'll do it for you refling. Oh, no, she is okay. No, she's fine. Okay. Okay. I won't message her
Okay. Okay. Follow the purple. Follow the purple. Easy. Easy. Follow the purple. Gentle. Gentle. Gently. Gently. Follow the purple
Refling, no
We've lost our first refling. This cannot be. Wait, do I have an emotional gesture?
To say goodbye to
I'm so sorry. No, no, not like that
We lost our first refling to gravity rip rip refling. Okay. We'll we'll we'll keep going. We'll push onwards
I don't clap at him. That's not nice
Fill the dexterity check. Oh, right. We'll follow and we'll get to the next location
What? What? I'll I'll be in the corner so you can go ahead purple refling
What?
A
What we're currently
Are you squinting me right now? No, there's no shock. How's the shock collar being used?
So we flying
No shock collar
because
Something very strange. What? How did you do that?
I need to get good at the game with you guys, honestly
The shock collar is requiring me to give me its phone number to use the software and
I'm going to have to buy a burner phone to get it operational
Um, or I'm actually probably just going to buy a new brand of shock collar because there is actually no reason why
I should have to give personal information to click that on a freaking button of our shock collar
Um, are these birds aggressive?
No
Uh
Are we going the wrong way?
Honestly. Oh wait. Oh wait. Pick up the thing. Pick up the thing. Sorry. There's a thing there that you pick up
That's like, but thank you bro. The legend a claw talisman
How do I click talisman?
Oh
Wait, no, it's an equipment
Uh
Enhances jump attacks. Okay. That's pretty perfect considering all I do is go. Oh, yeah every time I get an enemy. I mean
Give it all her info
Yeah
What is the password for it's how you stream snipe me and elden ring
So I can have two good reeflings and one bad reefling at a time
Okay
But you need to put down your mark at a certain location
So unfortunately, you do have to have already played the game. That is a big jump big jump
Uh, thankfully it goes to stamina damage. Um
I
Top down here. Okay
Uh
Oh wow
Wow, we are getting deep in these catacombs
Oh, we need to do this one. Okay. Well, I did buy uh like four stone dying level 75 already
I may or may not have been gifted just a little tiny just a wee amount of runes just to get started. Okay
Like it's um
What?
It was just to get me started, you know, like I didn't really oh
I actually dodged that. Okay, but I didn't well
I mean that worked out fantastically all things considered and it was I just needed a wee bit, you know
And the refunds were very kind and gave me some some very happy to see
Whoa, is the enemy right right there? I don't want to get pushed off the map
Okay, follow purple reefling
Are we is there something out there or is it just that guy that stands on the shelf?
I'm looking nothing. Okay. Just checking just checking
A small it was just a small loon of a million runes. Okay for a level one player. It was a small
Small runes. Oh, we did like a big basic get back to the bus. Okay
at the
And maybe we can get a new wishlist
Something's going on back there. I don't know what
Uh, this is like an entire battlefield
Oh, no, I ain't good like that. Oh, I'm not good at this game like that
I'm not good at this game like that. Okay. Okay. Hold on. I actually gonna have to use my brain
We're gonna keep doing jump attacks. Okay
I need to restore my stamina bar. That's fine
You're next. Goodbye
Oh
Something just got me. I need to heal
I was healing stop it. I was healing. Wait. I just whacked that freaking pillar. Stop it. I'm healing
Is that are we good? I think we're okay. Maybe I don't know
I don't know. I need I can't tell yet. Whoa. That's the baddie
Oh my god
The game I would not have gotten very far with that. I have one more class
Be careful about a cheeky HP, but it's okay. It's okay
Protect refill and mummy. Oh, there's a portrait. Hello
The prophecy painting. Oh, I do love a good prophecy. I have been that prophecy V tripper. I do love a good
Uh, I would 100% entertain a prophecy V tripper
Don't care. I love it. It's good. I love prophecies. I find them absolutely fascinating when did you guys see June?
Wait, is there gonna be a reference here if I touch this?
Is there any reference here?
I was gonna see I'm wondering. I think you guys might be at the next grace site. Okay. We'll do the next grace site
I see your future. I predict you will in three two one
Are you spewing on me? What is why does it not hurt me?
It puts me asleep
Sleep wait, but sleep didn't even put me asleep. It just like did explain
Uh, I'm gonna have to sit down because I need to replenish all my class
V tripper that's really into divination. Yes. I'm definitely open for that. That's stuff like
Right level up wait
Wait, did I crack all those rooms?
I uh, I did not crack all those rooms. This is gonna be ridiculous. I did not crack
Are we ready?
You can't get banned for this stuff. It's not that kind of game where they're like, we're gonna ban you, right? Surely not
Surely it's not that kind of game that gets you banned for this silly stuff. Yeah, I didn't think so. Oh, no
A million a million of pop
No, we're gonna be so
But it's perfect because that's exactly what I want
Oh, this is fantastic. Oh, no, sorry. I didn't mean to use a singular one
I don't think it's gonna make much of a difference in the grand scheme of things. All right, let's try that again
Use an event
Forms so severely deals with hackers in their full game
Hmm
I guess if you're really into like the multiplayer aspect of like, uh, 1v1 in someone I can see how it might be annoying
Are we about to hit 10 million?
I think we are
Wait, is that 11 million? Hold on, let me do the
Wait, am I being Papaga?
Uh 11? Oh my god, 11 million runs on our person
Bruh
Oh my god, that's like that's insane
That is insane. Thank you so much
Um, yeah, I think we can go up a few more levels
Right, so what did someone say 60 vigor and then strength and then what a few in dexterity, maybe
Endurance, I wouldn't mind because I like swinging my sword. This is fucking ridiculous. We're still going
80 strength
Oh, we can get 82 strength 40 endurance get that 60
Endurance faith and mind
Faith isn't too handed. Am I mistaken?
Are you trolling did I read it trolling?
And the rest on whatever you plan on the put all the points into faith. I'm lying. Please don't do this
Okay, one hit Malena. Hopefully I I think we're gonna one hit her but if strength is
Right stamina is gonna go up quite a bit, which is good because I'm kind of like oh my god. Wait
I
How much can I it keeps going?
It keeps going we can max out
40 endurance is a soft cat, okay, so just do that
A
More endurance
Don't get 40 on that
Vigor soft calf is 60. Is it?
80 is a hard cut for things. This is the highest level. I've seen someone have
Brov literally now didn't even earn any of it
You have 15 million you can max out everything. Okay, I giggled it. Yeah soft cat on 60
Okay
So we'll do that and then what put in endurance. Oh, no, you said endurance is also got soft cat when I'm like, sorry
someone said um
60 and 80 strength
So there's not really I have 106 hours on my character in your higher level than it already
What can I say the reeflings love support in me?
Ryan
You are now a higher level than I am. I've been playing for 130 hours
Get rekt origan. Thank you for the five get rekt
So when you say soft cap, do you just mean like it hardly improves anything?
basically
I seen that's what you mean. She already beat the game
Okay, so it hardly improves it
They didn't change anything. Oh, this changes my max equipment load though. I kind of want that because I'm doing heavy rule
Okay
Well, why do you have a thing on it? Why does it have a ring around it?
What
Is that a president of the united states in my video game right now?
And you come mr. Richard
Nixon the president of the united states
um
I do
I was absolutely mortified. I thought that said something else there. Oh my god. I need my glasses on now
Let's not do that. Oh have a red. I need a red
just a fella and
And
Who came in first? Oh shit everything's out of order
Right you came you came
Why are you naked mr. President?
Oh my god, can you actually fight
Are you doing is it don't dog Zori or something? I can't remember the name
My beloved all we need to get the coconuts so we can talk to each other
That's basically have diminishing returns to hire the stat the fewer benefits for more of the stats
Get them into rent to six there 80
Dogeza, dogeza, dogeza. I'm trying to imagine how you say it dogeza
Oh
My game just crashed am I still streaming pc are you okay?
PC are you okay? Are you okay? Why are you screaming?
Why is my pc screaming?
Okay, I'm still streaming okay
Oh no
My my pc couldn't handle the ink of the uh reeflings injecting into my bloodstream
We still here and see you girl you just got banned stop imagine if I was the first freaking runescape player to get banned
For like mass levelling up and form soft is like you're not allowed on our game anymore
Could you imagine?
That would be ridiculous runescape player
You're still streaming wait runescape
Wait, what did I say? Wait, what did I say? Did I say jagged?
Yeah, I hope I didn't ruin that wrong game you said runescape. Oh, sorry
Elden ring. I don't know what I think. I don't know what I said
Sorry
Maybe I need to get a cup of tea what how long it's already been two hours. It feels like an hour
Okay, wait, sorry
I need to scrub out everyone's name that I just wrote down there because you didn't actually get a chance to play
So I'm taking your names out of the paper. Okay
And then I'm starting a new list at the side, but because
Right
Right, I'll summon. Okay, actually that's kind of lucky that you're there. I'll see if I can find president
Uh
Oh
You can roleplay as Milena
I unfortunately can't find president nixon
Uh, I've got yeesh
And then see if we can get Milena. I don't know why my piece my game crashed
My beloved I'm gonna get everyone in and then I'm gonna very well at least you didn't get banned. Are your stats still good? Oh
Uh considering how long my hp bar is on my stamina. I think I'm actually gonna do a bit. Um
Wait, why can't I see other refunds?
I've only got one refund right now
Sorry one good refund pardon my friend
Is the game trying to connect why can't why can't I only summon one refund?
Huh what's going on here
Need to redo it again summoning the bad refling ends effect. Oh, I comprehend. Are you kneel before me?
Uh, you
Did you just give me your shlong be honest?
Oh, I heard that I hear it. Okay. Yes, you can call in
right
Hey, what was that a
you have such a
Funny and long name, right? I'm gonna very quickly make a copy see I will literally be like four minutes
The reason I always say four minutes four minutes one
The kettle takes forever to boil
It takes forever. Okay, please everyone. I highly recommend get up. Have a little stretch
Get yourself some snacks and some juice if you like if you do need to go to sleep
Please don't worry. I will be here when you wake up unironically. This is an endurance stream
You know damn it's not connecting. Oh no
I'm wondering if something's bugging out fire grief
You try and grease me up be honest. You try and grease me up. Huh? You try and grease me up in 4k in 4k
I held up strong. He cut open 4k. Hmm. Hmm. Yeah. Yeah
Okay, I think this area is a bit funky
You're the only one that shows off as well
That's so strange. I think this that's wait. I'm getting a I'm getting a vision
I am like 99% sure I've had issues with this summoning area before in another life
I'm going to very quickly make a cup of tea. Please do get up. Get a wee thingy. Um, is this an endurance stream? No, it's just eight hours
Let's be honest here. We already know it's not gonna be eight hours
Right, I'm gonna very quickly make a cup of tea. I'll be right back. Okay. Please get a snack
Please get a drink. Please stretch your legs. It's very good for your health and your circulation. I will be right back
I
The music no, it's crazy
Um, right, you couldn't make it
Look at all the pretty gems going just for you, right?
Yeah, your connection. I don't know why you're not connecting to me nemesis. Wait, why is your why is?
20 20
Two zeros in a row. Why would that be?
Why would that be blanked out? That's so confusing
Sometimes
I've got a little blueberry muffin to keep me going until I get some food
Strani, how have you made the most cursed
Company for class
Strani, how have you made the most cursed company for class? I don't understand what that means. Okay
All right, wait 69 is muted in this game of allure
I take a bite of my little uh muffin
Oh
The uno club turned into jack box, which is now talking. Okay. I guess it never worked out. Yeah
Oh, my god. Yes. My gen mates are playing uno today. Literally all together. Please do check them out
Um, it's kind of emmy's little send away like uh, we miss you. We love you. Uh, please come back
We we're gonna be so sad while you're gone. Um
Um
I don't think I could pick the gems up. No, these are like for cost. Um
No, they're doing that so it must wait emmy is leaving. She's going on all the day
We're not all the way
No, they're not going live. Yeah, it must be someone's uno probably isn't working then should it
Sorry, I don't really like to go on discord whilst I'm streaming because I don't
Oh, they're all in voice chat together. I'm so tense. It's a go in. Oh wait, they're not streaming yet
Okay, we we have ubi soft hate going on right now
We have ubi soft hate apparently ubi soft is a
Not working for them
Uh, right ubi soft hate absolutely absolutely decimated so they've tried it for some reason they can't connect to one another
Yeah, the server's got all of them. I think yeah, even though they're all in the same region
Ubi hate, yeah, okay. Sorry. Let me finish my muffin really quickly
Oh, I never put my light on
We don't want to be in the future but don't acknowledge her in America also me on day one you guys want to see my toggles
Actually, I paid how much for these toggles never use the bloody things
Eh, none of this guy replays. What are you doing?
I just get so into it though. I'm sorry. I'm like so into it
I'm like I can't if my hat goes off to vtuber's that are like
And like change their toggle without even having to think like I don't even know how you do it
Like what the fuck is going on out there?
Like genuinely don't know how you do it like
Like how the fuck do you do that? I am in the moment. I do not have time to be like
Oh, right. This button is how I activate the the question mark thingy. Like I don't know how to do it
Pain a smiley on the hotkeys for the toggle
No, I have oh, I don't have to smell it have the names like this is called love because it makes my heart's love heart
Makes my heart's makes me
Unlike I've got
You said what
Someone say anal
Anal
Um
Yeah
I'm such a fake
Actually, you can't call me a fake vtuber. How much have you fucking spent on the vtuber community?
I will not tolerate any slander such as this
Actually, that's where I draw the line at the slander. You can call me a bad vtuber
But you can't call me a fake one uh with the amount of money I'm fucking putting to the
I'm down for it
Toggles are useless because uh, we know what face mummy is making already. Well, just teasing
I'm just teasing through this entire stream
But yes, uh, my daughter should be going live soon tm question mark. I don't know what's happening, but
I can't even figure it out, but please do watch them. I'm doing endurance. I'm going to be here all week
Okay, we are stuck on this game for the next few days and when I say stuck
I mean you're stuck in the wall and I've just come across your stuff
Yeah, I'll make myself clear
You thought some people do have like so I can like
Puff my cheeks automatically like I'm puffing my cheek. I'm sick of my tongue. That's automatic
I can also go angry. That's automatic. I can also go sad
All right, open my like this is all automatic
Anything beyond that is what is called a face toggle. This is a toggle
This isn't going to come on if I like look a certain way in the tracker, you know
um
Like again with a blush. This isn't going to come on so
That would you be playing shadow of urchie? Is that the name of the dlc? Because if so, yes, we are playing the game
The base game
But well, I say we play and you guys are carrying me through the base game so we can do the dlc part
But yes, okay, we're playing switch ways at that door
It may be this door
Oh, look it isn't this door
Don't be filled with flings
Oh, we got sonic the hedgehog up in here
Do you guys actually see the sonic the hedgehog movie? I didn't
Don't tell it. Don't tell Amy from my yumi plus that I didn't see the sonic
Uh
Movies she's like obsessed with shadow everything they're sonic and I'm like thing
I thought you know, I thought I was like pretty deep in it doing the like sonic heroes
I don't know what we're doing. I'm just following you guys. Sorry. I'm going on a ramble. You guys are gonna have to actually
I'm getting distracted like oh, that's an enemy. I thought that was the reason
Okay, it turns out you can't actually break the big killer things were oh
I need to stop doing that. Okay. You're glowing blue. I need to remember
Glowing blue. He's a friend to you. Oh, you're a fine warrior
Oh, you're a warrior too
Me I'm a warrior
Even though I I get
I get reeflings to kill everything. Is the dlc any good? I don't know. Oh, no, sorry. You said the dlc is good stuff
How utterly repellent this is I think the girl who haven't served her she was giving the shunt tails
They're gonna play you know, I think they're swapping because there's issues with Ubisoft
Wait, was that supposed to do something? Sorry? I don't know
Uh-huh. I ask you call upon me the winds run foul with his uncertain father would permit me to fight
Oh
Well, um, I've already got reeflings, but I do appreciate the offer. I really do. Please don't think I'm
Not thankful, but um, I'm pretty solid to go. I'm not gonna lie
I'm alive pretty solid you follow the jet follow the lanes. Oh, I would get kidnapped so easily. I'm not gonna lie
Just exhaust the dialogue
She gives you a charm too. Did I need to come back after I've done a godric
She gives you something after you kill the boss at the round table. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Sorry reeflings. Sorry. Sorry
I'm coming back. I'm coming back. Don't worry. Don't worry. I'm being a silly silly billy
I've been a silly billy
With mabic silly billy
Wow, oh, we have a boss fight boss fight boss fight boss fight boss fight
She followed the reeflings gemstones to get the seeds
Ha
Oh, no invader reeflings. Oh, you're already gone. Wait
Huh, are you know an invader?
What you didn't have uh
You didn't have to actually leave. I don't know why we could do that. Oh, please candy
Uh, someone says the grass to the right
That no the grass to the right
For reefling they just can't be near you at the grace site. Oh
Okay, boss time surely I will mess this up
Traverse the man
Cut scene. Oh, I need to drink my tea. Okay. I'll drink it in a minute after this fight
It's gonna be really long and hard my tea dragon
There's a true born air
Let me thy strength. Oh kindred
Deliver me unto greater heights
Well
Oh
Oh, I hate long arm
No
No, you kneel to me. Oh god reeflings for the love of god
Reflings, please. Oh, thank god. Right. Okay. Now we can do it now. I have backup. I'm not scared
Who's the aiming for first?
Thank goodness me. I have a lot of health. I don't I can't see who he's aiming for
Am I being potato? Oh, it's been a while since I've played short
Oh my god, absolute gang dialysis. I'm out the way
Okay, I'm out of stamina
Wait cut as we are
Me after she keeps she keeps looking
Oh
I thought like that
I've begun the wrong profit. We only knew it's running
Oh my god, oh, I don't like this
But I have to
Ah
He's got raw as well
He really said
How does this attack work? It's been so long, right? Okay
Oh, does he if I stand on the scorch maybe
Leave him alone
Me getting flattened like a pancake with the reeflings finish them off really just some it's going to sum up this entire stream. Let's go
Oh no
I took my med
I had to take my meds. I had a sore head. I'm so sorry
Thank you. Thank you. You're the one who carried me through the ghost fight
For the ghost fight. Wait, you guys don't disappear
No
I was like, wait many guys done the great rune by
The great runes you receive by the by defeating shard bearers have lost their
Beneficial power however their power can be restored at divine towers through the lands between sea
Oh, that's if you want to learn more spells and stuff. I think
Is this another one where I can't see you guys here?
Go to the round table and collect your rewards
Can't level up yet. Okay round table
Then I'll do it from there. Yes. No, okay round table. Wait. So I don't go back and talk to her
Is she not going to be there anymore? Is she going to be at the round table? Oh
Well, I'm gonna go to the round table. I didn't realize you guys even cleared that out for me. You guys did so much work
I didn't even realize you clean cleared that out for me. Uh lady
Warrior lady. Oh getting in. Hello. Oh, this is a rare occasion. Hi
I can't remember the last time a new tarnished made their way to the round table. Yeah
I'm new here as your senior
Oh, no, we ain't doing that. Cool. Hi shit. No, we're on the same level. Sorry
I believe in communicating as peers and nothing more. Please don't don't give me that shit. Allow me a word of advice
As your senior you are a mere visitor to the round table
Okay, this is why we do peer and peer talking not like adult on child or like this like you're older than me
I must respect your type. No
Don't ever speak to me again
Uh, oh, we can see the fingers
Hello
The 43 levels from the logic
We're so doing that first. What's Johnny's current level? It's like what? Only four more levels?
Look there the fingers
To welcome you shard bear let their wisdom wash over you
Great Elden Ring
Root of the golden order
Anchor of all lands
Giver of grace
Wellspring of all joy
Until it was shattered
The tragic corruption of the order has taken its toll
Across the realm
Life lies in ruin
Fallen two pieces
foul curses
And misery spread
Unabating just so thank you
What about this
The tentacles trembles Johnny
Wait my mouse was closed it again
Oh
Wait does the DLC get affected if you do the madness route or does the DLC kind of just override whatever choice?
Of its kind
Is DLC new game plus? Okay. That's my question. Is the DLC new game plus or are you supposed to do it alongside the main quest?
DLC is separate entirely
This is one thing curious. Hello
The rapture the rapture really of all things. I mean
I
No way they gave the fingers a seat no one feel well. This is what the damn thing size is
Brian
Since I was busy picking up a new family member dog in Texas
Did you know they have a bank called central bank of texas my soul left my body when I abbreviated that
Wait, what's wrong with the little you don't want central bank of texas texas?
You don't want me a central bank of texas here. Just a little bit. I won't make it hurt too much
Thank you
For the tip that's actually such a good acronym for it though
Does anyone interested in some central bank of texas?
Can I write who?
The warrior lady. Where the heck is the warrior lady? You're not the warrior lady
It's not new game plus. Okay, where's the warrior lady? I cannot for the life of me remember that's fia's bedroom
Towards the merchant. Okay merchant merchant. I do know where the merchant is
Is she the quiet one that never spoke to me? No
Do you really not talk at all? Wow you you really don't okay curious. Um
She's not in the merchant's area
No
Huh, oh I have a medium rule now. I don't have a
Oh
That's all crazy this is gideon's room
She's downstairs by the smith. Okay jacob plant. I am on it
Excuse me just coming through again
Downstairs by the smith
Hello
Are you behind this?
Yeah
Are you in here lady I use this
Oh another one, sorry, sorry, I never saw it
You don't she mustn't have moved yet. Maybe I need to progress just to weave it for those in
Oh my god reeflings is the kitchen where I get oh no the table. Sorry
It's I was going to say it's the kitchen where I feed you from look
We've got all these lovely cuts of meat for you
We've got beef
We've got well there was carrots, but now they clips through the floor because they destroyed the table
And look with all these potatoes I can make you some homemade chippies because my dad taught me how to make homemade chippies
Um see like this is where I do all the cooking for you
Make sure we have omelets in the morning or scrambled egg because we get chickens from the farm and we've got a nice
fire to use for it
see
And look there's like a little pot of soup see I've got wait. Isn't there not a historical like continuous pot of soup making or something like that?
I can't recall
um
And I've got the assassin's prayer book which totally helps me do something
Yeah, probably not uh, I have no idea uh, if this is a crossbow my memory serves me correct
Yes, I do remember things sometimes like oh, I'm sorry for destroying the dine and hall
I'll very slowly walk out. Don't want to destroy any more of the uh perpetual stir. That's right. It's like a thing that keeps on going
Yeah, they had come, you know pots back in the day. Sadly. They were all destroyed
Um
Try another way. Okay, right the lady isn't here yet. That's okay. We're gonna continue adventuring
Uh, where do we continue adventuring at?
No
Is it through the castle we go or is it south we go now?
Godric's grace. Okay. Godric's grace
Go Doric the Gratis
In the castle. Okay, we go here next. I actually don't know where it's a lot I guess
I think France had one of the oldest 200 years that's constantly me going and then once it went dry then it went
I think a lot of stuff got scrapped for ironwork for the world war. So lost a lot of history to that stuff
I press y and I press left
Shit I have to actually go forward on my own for once
Okay
Oh, you're not an enemy
Oh
Craven to the bowl
Hello
This weasel was
Godric was always looking down on me. Yeah, he got a bloody deserve thanks to you
Yeah, I'm glad. What are you though? What goes around comes around
He had an ugly heart an ugly accountants. Uh-huh. I don't know what countenance means, but yeah, yeah, I agree
Oh, like your temporary I am discovery
It's like so specific
Hannibal what the
Is your profile picture? Thank you for becoming a member
What is that Hannibal feather?
What is your profile picture? I can make out the pose that Nicki Minaj pose
Oh
Someone from the group defeated a shard bear. Let's go grip. We're so proud. Right. So if I go back
I'll go some guys were literally but I'm like, is that a character? I don't recognize it
It's a meme about
Omniman
Right, wait, can I get you guys in here then?
Come to the grease that is called
It is called the secluded secluded cell come right now right on the spot
Can I not get any
Hmm wait wrong way wait, sorry, sorry, sorry wait hold on wrong way apparently to keep going ahead
I'm sorry. I'm low IQ
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm faster faster faster faster the old
You need to go through the entire a of this area. Okay. I comprehend
Wow open humans
A chair
I can have the reeflings prey at my feet
Uh, hi there summon you in so we can pray at my feet. Is it here? Did I just see it?
I can't get attacked here, right?
Is that fake door wall?
Oh, I actually can attack. Uh, I guess I'm like super safe here
Uh here he is
There's some sort of event coming up
I can't oh no, I couldn't attack but I couldn't attack in there. How strange
What did that mean?
Hello
Oh, no
Why is there blood?
Hold on hold on. I'm on my own. We need to we need to play it safe. Okay. It looks like I need to jump down
Okay, but why was there blood back there?
Shhh
Why is there blood did someone just perish there for the fun of it? I should buy a grape
Maiden dear maiden, where are you? Please take my grapes
Madness has to up this thing. Huh
Huh
I don't know what enemies are all and that guy that died there just just trolling around
Uh, okay next grace day
Come on. Uh, next grace day. There's a lot of blood there. Oh, I see it. I see it. I see it. I see it. I see it
Le Uri Neia of the lake, okay
Oh, it's just a few reflins waiting on me over here just a few
May chaos take the world. No, I wouldn't do madness, right? I'll get no TV fling in first because I don't want to get attacked
I hate getting attacked
Um, did you disconnect?
No, apparently you've been in before
You've been in for
What does that mean? What does that username mean?
I've not had you in before
I don't know what that meant. What did your name mean?
Had you
Were you a little reflin all shy on your own out here? You're so shy a little refling because you're scared
Uh, we don't hurt
Okay, there we go. Me thing
Oh, no, did you DC? Wait
Have we had you before?
No, no
I wonder
I'm checking all my names. How many names we've got?
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 stream snap and replay
Oh, you're in a red dress. Check you out
Red dress go look look fresh the bed
My beloved my beloved I will need to get coconut
um
Oh, there's a church down here. I wait. Can we even reach that? We can't
Normally, there's something good at the churches that are pretty OP
I think we discover the church and then we'll follow the grace site. It's telling us to go along that bridge there
Ooh, we have a purple bear
They are 13 years
In mesmer years mesmer who's mesmer identify yourself
What's going on?
Wow, I have an offering land octopus
Are you trying to impregnate me be honest?
I stay critical here. We can have another flat. Oh geez sir. You don't look very good. Are you okay?
You're tarnished, aren't you? I am
and
perhaps
Believe it or not
ice for a small
Oh, uh 10 runes. Sure. Well, bless you are a true. My name is topes. Hi, Tom
assuming you're interested only
Uh, I don't really need to learn spells because uh, I have I have full faith in the
Uh, my weaponry
I don't need to believe in magic
If uh, if my two-handed sword has anything to say about it, I don't think I need to learn magic
Um
Is this the wrong way?
Well, I follow the reeflings. I trust them with my heart. So
uh
I'll just go in a la dee da dee da little exploration
It's just a sword a sword is just metal magic. Yeah
Reverse to the intervals between significant floods and Venice. Wow. I just know that
I just thought meant knife maker
Oh
Wait, this is how we continue down the hill. I was just gonna go through a straight beeline. I think ready reeflings on your marks. Get set
Wow
I love it. I love it
Oh, my gameplay isn't interrupted with frustration. I can one shot the area
I'm progressing a nice linear pattern with the
Unplayable
Careful of the reefling. I don't want to whack you with my meaty swag
Oh my tea. Sorry. I forgot I had a cup of tea. Okay. I'm gonna I'm gonna walk around a little bit
You guys are gonna have to like super protect me though because I only have one hand
Sorry if the camera's a bit funny
It's already getting cold
Well, I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying. I'm so sorry. I don't have the fucking accuracy
Oh, I need to turn turn. Okay. We did it. We did it
Okay, oh, there's a gentleman here. Oh and as we horsies here. Hello
You're new around here
So I put the tea in the thermal honestly, I'll consider it. No, don't don't perish on the fire. He's kicking himself
He's making himself calamari
He's thought that reefling. No, there's two calamari now
He said mommy eat me, please
Hmm
What do you sell my good man? Well you sell
Um, nothing of interest to me. I'm sorry
Oh, wait. No, I do want this. I want that for when we go into scary places
Hmm
Okay, if I press start and then I press this one
And then I put on this then I can light up the way just
Love me so love me reeflings
Simple you don't really sound that British Brian. I'm gonna be honest
Nate great. Thank you for the five. Love my sword. Love me reeflings
Who goes there identify yourself that wasn't mean you can't prove it
Okay
I'm almost finished
Do you guys want to like go ahead a little bit just to get a feel for the enemies because I'm still trying to drink my tea
Oh
My god, I'm like, oh, it's like so hard to turn the camera and move
I need to like make sure I'm behind the steps of the reefling though. So I don't get work
Oh, that was a tiny bird. That was an eight out of ten
That's not eight out of ten. That's like a four. That was a little a little
Okay, okay, the reeflings are protected. I can do this
I'm doing it. I'm doing it. I'm following the reeflings with one hand. This is getting a bit tricky now
Whoa, whoa, whoa
Okay, okay, I finished I finished I finished I can pick up the map the map the map the map the map
Um
Oh my god, my game just froze there. Did you see that it literally just was
I literally when things have too many bills. I cannot do it
lie
Nia
Lie or Nia. Okay, that makes more sense. Sorry. I have to break everything down or else it doesn't work
In my head
Lie or Nia. Oh, so good wrong. Okay, right. Okay. I still got it wrong still got it wrong
Princess treatment mode literally right. I've got two hands again
I'm ready for a fight
Whoa, what did these do here? I don't like
Whoa, help that reefling help that reefling right now. Oh, whoa
Oh
That reefling didn't need any help at all actually in fact if anything I'm the one that needs help
Why he's late now for fireworks?
Baby
Lie, you're Nia. Lie, you're Nia. Lie, you're Nia
Yeah
Making the reefling sell the dirty work. Well, the princess sits her tea honestly
Shocking because he's like, wait, is that reefling fine? Yeah, that's reefling fine
We're going on an adventure adventure adventure
We're going on an adventure and the place of the map I can't pronounce
So we're just gonna call it the lake but jeez you're so fast
We're following the lake
I got uh
Flowers and I got uh smithing thingy my boba
I like her friendly fires and on for friendly reeflings because I would be in a world of trouble swinging this sword around if you guys were getting physical
Uh
I don't know where we go
Is there an enemy we're getting a bit too open world here
I think there's some sort of boss battle in the water. Is it a boat? Is it the boat guy a mariner?
Hmm my memory is failing me. Okay. This looks like a boss fight. Whatever this is. Okay, maybe not
Maybe it's just the render distance
So do you actually do the emboss in the dlc? Yeah, we've not played the dlc. I've never played it before I only came out two days ago
Or are they?
Whoa, I hear noises. Wow
It's a baboon
Cheeky thing. What do you drop? Do you drop string?
What?
Here for replay
Where are they coming from? They're coming out nowhere
Oh my god, I love how long my sword is as well because it means I can actually hit things with it. What?
Dragonfly. Oh no, not dragonfly. I'm mad at myself
What do we do? I'm gonna follow you. Okay. Let's say we're all agree we're going this way
What? Is it beating me up? I'm so confused. Is this thing trying to suck me off or something?
I don't know. It keeps flapping about my head. I can't get it
I'm gonna beat this shit with that mosquito. Did you get it?
No, it's being us
We can't kill a mosquito. Okay. We did it. Okay. Let's god that thing is massive. That's a big
Yeah, are you celebrating? Oh, I see it. I see it. Oh, it's gone
I thought that was the boss. Can he be the boss?
Oh, I missed. You didn't see that. You didn't see that. I missed just a little bit. Okay
Oh, I got more of my ovaries back. Yeah, give me my ovaries back. Give me the book
I need them
I need them for when uh
Gentle
Wow, okay, we're going up here. Oh, there's a great site and there's also a crystal bug
I love collecting all the flowers in this game
Little mushrooms and all that. It's so cute
Uh, right um
Where are we to go?
Look how freaking fast
It's so big
Okay, I follow the reeflings. Where are they?
Oh my god, they're gone. Oh, right. They're there. I was like, uh, did I just despawn them? Uh, uh reeflings help help help
Okay
I've heard the mosquito
It's like, hmm, doesn't that seem a little overpowered just for that? Okay
Anything
Right, let's get ready to rumble
Ladies and gentlemen
Aren't my feet getting cold in the water the lake? I feel like that'd be a bit chilly. Oh, there's a shack here. There's a house
Reeflings, it's the farm. Oh no, our farm got flooded. We're gonna have to restore the farm together
Oh, no, we're gonna have to put our love and joy into something and then and then when it's all finished
And we're all happy and we'll be happy. Oh, no
Oh, no, my ancestors the love
I know I don't want to start anything. I'm sorry. I just thought I was curious that you were kicking so much food
I hear boss music. I assume that's
the reason
I can never as always
Actually, it kind of sounds like the harry pot. Wait
Is it harry pot or is it avenger?
What one's that?
Is that marvel? I think that's marvel
Oh the avenger scene. Oh, that's what it is
We're making the game thinks we're trying to hunt in this perfect one. I'm like, no, look at the third one
We look one. Oh, there's a wee building to the left, Reeflings. There's a little thing to the left
Oh, that's a busty crust station or a crusty bust station. Okay
What's the difference between uh, lobster with the boot job or something?
I can't remember
Thank you for the five
uh, lunar sky wolf
Brian says like there's actually a Brian tester if you do like if you take on Google like take speech
um
Twitter
Twitter maybe like uh, don't know
There's like a program that already has Brian and you can type in what you want to say to make sure he says it right
Um, like sometimes you have to spell words a bit differently because Brian gets a little bit confused
I'm I'm sure there's a joke and I've already forgotten it and I used to tell all the time
And my dad's fucking sick of hearing it. It's like what's the difference between
Oh, what's the difference between a dirty bus stop and a lobster with a boot job
And then the answer is one
A crusty
Bus station and one's a busty crust station. Very good
Ta-da, I don't know if my accent made that like 10 times harder than it needed to be to understand it. But yeah
Yeah, what's the difference between old bus stop and a lobster with implants when it is a yeah, I said wait wait hold on hold on
What's the difference between a dirty old bus station and a lobster with breast implants?
One is a crusty bus station and the other is a busty crust station
Oh, thank you. Thank you. It's a good joke. I love it
Mmm
Um, I made some clips yesterday after stream the youtube clip until but it's only a minute
Uh, yes, it's still
useful
We are going to there's actually an anonymous person
Who's been dropping us files on the girls like highlight files with the girls
They made one for mercy and from not mistaken. They made one for
Oh, it's the maidenless guy
Uh, a highlight rule for Emmy
But we're going to test of putting up like short three minute videos of a stream highlight and seeing how that gets received
And if it does well or not, if not, then kind of clips that are for shorts only might be the best way
Uh, what am I supposed to answer? Wait, hold on. Hold on
Ah, there you are the great rune and had your audience with the two fingers. Yes, I did
They didn't seem right
I mean
Fingers are the fingers
You may go that made the wisdom of the two
Oh, he's not happy
Do his quest line it helps for DLC. Oh, sorry
The two fingers seem off
Your intuition serves you well
My doubts had been piling up. You see
The words of the two fingers cannot be trusted. What's the difference between a light bulb and the pregnant woman?
You cannot screw light bulb
Oh, brian will stand up comedian you are. Thank you tk for the five
I appreciate it. Thanks for the needle
Harbour no love. So this is how we do the dlc. That's the part that irks the most the fingers have no love
Oh, I have a
Festering bloody thing
a means for circumventing the draw of the two fingers
Give it a try. Won't you and if it please you may we meet again? You also need to do kaolin
Hope's for you
My mannequin
That's what I had to do. Yeah, did I do it right? I need to go see him in kaolin
What are you doing? Are you mottin gotta use the fingers a couple of times now
I would do
Look for bloody feral thing gods
Well, can't agree to the go under my skin costume. I'm looking this one
Uh
Am I going crazy? Oh, it's right there at 10. Wait, I have to invade
I
Have to actually hurt people
But I use the fingers and then talk to him again. Oh no
You can just invade. Oh, I have so much points on me though. I don't want to lose my points
That's my next level up
The heck is this
The ruse church and a little like a ruse church to me
Where is the
Question
The strongy have a mean tag on play though. Yeah, I felt safe all up all wrong
It's with an eight
Right, we're just gonna do it
I'm just gonna do it. So what you or can't use it. Why not?
Right. Are you guys ready to watch me go attack some people?
Or you can just do what the creepy maid almost did tell you
You can kill magnus the beast thought and
Wait and ride blood ruin instead. Don't have to do the same game. Wait. Who's that then?
Magnus the beast claw that guy way at the end of the main games
She does indeed yeah, I felt cephalopog wrong
It's supposed to be cephalopog, but then I realized because I spelt it wrong. That's even more on par for me
I
It's an mpc in bed. Okay. Okay, right replays
If you guys the spawn wait if I kill you right now replaying does that count?
Are you want to sacrifice your flesh to mummy?
I'm not gonna take your flesh. It's fine. I don't think it counts if I hurt you someone says it's an mpc in bed
So I'm not gonna hurt you right
Mmm, is that you offering yourself or is that you say no?
Wait, I thought right so that kick the reef ones out and then use that for a finger
You have to invade him can I invade you guys?
Okay, right, okay get replays, please leave and then we're gonna skip to this next part go to the next grace
Uh
Yes, the next grace I know where that is. Yes. Uh the next grace. Yes
Grace grace grace where follow the purple reef
You know the finger is player
Well
Why don't we just give it a roll either? We'll win or lose. It's not really a big deal
Considering how many runes you guys are feeding me
I
Losing still counts for the quick. Okay. Thank goodness. I was nervous
It was one of those things where like you have to win against people who play this game and have a major interest in being
Only
Oh, there's a chair. Hello
Ace rained atcha
Is an hatch a hatch it would be better than what I have
No, it's a different category. It's like a magic type thing
It causes frost build up though. Oh, I do like to get past them a bit
What's wrong?
Oh, it's just terrible and everything though. I just get worse
um
Okay, we're we're doing something. I don't know where the next three players follow the purple reef going
Magnificent later on when you go up an elevator out. Oh, we're getting a little lean
I see it. Okay. So claim this and then go to pvp and then
Wait, how come?
Okay, so now I click on the finger
Oh, no, this can't be
Invasion
Bose
Uh, wait for old finger use
Uh, attempting to evade another word select the bones both near and far
Yes
Uh
It might take forever my internet crash trip
Oh
No, wait, I I debuff myself because I
How do I undo it
How do I undo that?
Here you are
Oh, no, it's only going to put me against swiss because it's like, oh you're level kabillion
You're so high level. You're not going to get any matches. So how high level am I? Oh, no
Okay
If that's the case, we might as well just enjoy the
I don't know how to reset it
Do you think if someone's gonna think I'm a swear
What did that do
Do anything
Severed finger or rest of the grace. Okay rest of the grace
Okay, so the npc's in game count however
Uh, I don't know what thing takes me out of it though. Um, um, um, I don't know where the furrow finger is
Hopefully it's a replay
Oh, no
I'm in limb grave
Things don't hurt me
Wait refling
Hi, I don't I don't want to hurt you
Refling
No
No, I'm not fighting
No, I don't want to fight. Holy stinking. Let me leave. That's it use can't use
Uh, I don't know what I am. Let's me read
I just honestly know a big deal. I'm not paying
Uh
Use the finger
I genuinely
Not the famous Ion use the finger
Under monitor menu
This
Oh, whoa, what are you doing, bro? Let me go. Let me go. What the fuck?
Man, don't be a bunch of pussies. Just let me read
Uh, I don't actually want to fight. Okay, that took me so long. I do apologize for that. Holy, they're so weak
I'm so overpowered. Why would the game put me in with them? I feel bad. Right. So that counts as one
So do it all over again. You need to do it two more times, right both near and far. Okay
Do it three times
I I love that due to your huge, uh
Vigor they couldn't kill you
They aren't used to have people having that much xp
Yeah, so even though I'm like mega leveled off, I guess they didn't really hear that much
I thought yeah, because I thought the servers were going to be like, no, wait a minute
No way those flowers are nasturtiums
I recognize the lily pad leaves and flower color from anywhere. We're literally on nasturtiums. Look at the lily pad leaf
No way we're on nasturtiums. That's so cute. I didn't even know they had them in this game
Okay, I press star I press multi player. I press the finger. Whoa, that was a bit too quick
I press star and then I get the heck out of here. Bye
Hi
So level 200 and like zero plus weapon you're matching people with similar levels and weapons
So that counted one more time one more time
You know what it is
I think they're matching you with people with the game weapons current upgrades
So they basically can't even hurt you with their stats. Okay, that's funny
I'll take that. I'll take that
Are the girls streaming? Did they manage to do that club?
Who knew my underpowered weaponry was all like that
Oh, that's a block with this honestly
That holds down. No that holds down
No, it just looks like a weird power stance thing
How is that an ulti? Is it boosted? Oh, it's boosting me. It's giving me a boost. I can see the gold on me
I think you can only have a 20 plus or below
Okay
Okay, we only need one more I boost your poise too, which is why it stopped you getting staggered. Oh
Stomped then heavy attack it does a follow-up
Oh
That's so sad. It's fine. Let's try it out. I'm feeling confident after those those two people tried to beat me up
Right, so give them a stomp
Oh
No, I don't want to fight you now you got too much HP
Oh wait, am I going to stop searching for enemies if I mock it up
If I start up face if I start beating people up, I might even go have any
Why is there always
He doesn't like it
Necessary eight on my head
Necessary out my head, but be wary of strong four
You can just do a light attack near the critical area
Yeah, I'm still searching it better be
What is it coming over?
I don't know like it looks like it's giving up
Come on. We need one more world to invade right. Let's admire the nasturtians
The reason my nasturtiums are so awesome is they can actually grow in really poor soil quality
Something so beautiful can start from uh, even without the best conditions just like a weekend
As no one is perfect and you don't have to be
You get nasturtiums are like that too
And they have lots of big green leaves to get all the nutrition for their pollen
Their seeds are actually really interesting. They have very round bulbous seeds like in a circular
Seed it's actually really pretty to watch seeds of an nasturtium form
Um
I'm gonna go try and sleep. I'll try and join when I wake up, which will be the next stream
Considering we're only uh, what the three of our mark. I'll see you when you wake up. Okay
If anyone goes to sleep probably after the what
Five hour mark, then maybe I might not be able to see you
But after that I should
Um, I will get some uh actual food. I have been
So clogged up. I'm starting to get annoying the reason why I'm meme about animals so much
It's because I'm like two steps away from giving myself a freaking animal
And because I'm getting sick good night. Sorry. That's probably the last thing you want to hear before you're about to go to sleep
We're gonna have dreams about you
Sorry
The plan is to skip sleeping. No, you don't need to skip. We're literally doing this back to back to back to back
I have told the girls
Well, I've actually not told them. I probably should put a message in the discord and just be like
But once Amy goes away on holiday, this is her last stream. So I'm gonna I'm gonna send her a nice dm
I'm just gonna thank her for all her hard work. She uh earns. She has rightfully earned her vacation
Um, she's done a few things in the background to make sure the pinpals are well fed
And then after that, I'm just gonna put a message in the discord and just say
Hi
strongy here
I'm playing with the reef links for the next foreseeable day week
Uh, do not interrupt me. I couldn't care less if you get yourself in trouble. You're an adult deal with the consequences
sent
That's what they're getting from me. That's literally all they're getting from me. You will deal with the consequences of your actions
By yourself. Bye. I'm not your I am not your mom. Do not come to be for an answer. I am with the reef links. Bye
That's it. That's all they're getting
Yeah, this has been a long time coming
To do elven main and get the dlc together, which is so fantastic. So quick we get to do the dlc as well
Um
Yeah, I actually need to put up my screen for tomorrow
What is going on with that? There's like some weird mirage effect going on with my
Oh, come on. Just invade one more person one more
It's turning into a bout rule run one more. Please read things one more
Sorry, I'm gonna make some emotions like
I did the melena cosplay you saw the castello
Oh
Sorry, I missed you. I do apologize to anyone who
I can't grab but please don't worry. I'm playing for the next like literally five days or something
Uh
Let's going up staying up all night with mommy only if it's healthy and you don't have work or something
Is that a weekend? I don't know to get to the dlc. You have to finish this quest
Mog
We need to mog mohoog
And then go to kaolin and kill radahan. Yes, we can absolutely do that. Oh, I do not like that radahan
I have kayaking with my dad at seven from you would be sharp
It will be absolutely oh, come on one more. Give me one more. Come on game. Give it to me game
Show it to me, please
Try it again
Come on, I want to play with my reef lens
Get them servers up right no
And put me in someone's
Silly we game so I can immediately leave and meet the requirements of the silly maidless twat bag
If you ever get upgraded you should try to upgrade your weapon. Yes, uh, we will come across one naturally through the lens
Through the lens in between. Oh my god. I'm talking like a real elden ring player as if I'm gonna get my handheld
Look sometimes I deserve to get my handheld
Maybe after the oh my god after the series I should make an audio for twitter doing something nefarious
But I should call you the tarnished one
whilst I
Finish the game
on twitter in an audio
I'll just call you tarnished on the eye tarnished get to me tarnished come on tarnished one. Whoa
You're the elden king ring
I'm up over now
That war is gonna you yeah, come on war give me my seat take this war
Main list no more did you activate it again I did
It's not having it use
Oh, no, I deactivated the
Why did you guys boost in all that?
Give me a break. No
Give me a rena
Give me one more
I
So this is turning into are you searching with the reef password?
It doesn't go away no matter what I do group password one reef multiplayer password reef
Send a cooperative
Oh, is that one of you guys is someone getting me coming in
Is someone getting fondle of booze. I'm coming into their game right now. Is this support? Is this is this not a reefing?
I'm scared. I'm scared. Give me up. Give me up too quick too quick
Okay, don't recognize you. Bye
Sorry, you're not reefing don't care. Bye
We'll just cover that grave site though
Okay, we have done the quest. Oh, it's the same guy. Was it?
Okay, rip flings I summon you back to the good times
I will also lead the wave with my light on the head
Who's refling have we got
The
What is your name?
Did they they didn't censor reefing did they?
That can't make sense and you come asterix thing
What?
Very strange. Oh nixon you timed out right you come in you come in right I need invader reefing. Nah reef is safe
Queefing your name is queefing
Here you come adversary my adversary
Figured sleeping first is the strut then I'll have a better chance to snipe in when more reeflings have already played a bit
Are you whimpering?
That see I wanted to post
Firework torture
And I want I want you to sound like that one coconut do the coconut again
After we do post firework torture
That's what I want to hear
Do it just a fella you're still online you were in earlier
Oh no
President Nixon
Again you timed out
Where is
Wait president
Of the united states of america you timed out again
How are you having such terrible luck mr. President?
Don't you at all have really good wi-fi there? Oh my god. Wait. I need the butt slammer more
Can we do a save quest and get the butt slammer more so I can slam when you guys lie down like this
Oh
Per per per president nixon. I don't know what's going on with your wi-fi, but
In you come
Uh, I think I feel
I don't know why
We can give it to you. You can give me butt slam
President Nixon has mcdonald's wi-fi
Uh, we're we can copy it and like just hand it to me
Give it to me refling give it to me
Can do any of you guys have butt slam you had you did a butt slam
Do you have like something you can give me to slam it to me?
Why is your your head weird? Do you look like the bad guy in nightmare before christmas?
I'm the hoogie boogie man
Release me now or you'll have to face the consequence
Look at this. Look at this. I can't believe my eyes
Look at this
I really am so surprised
I can't but somebody has to put it on a zero weapon
Um, okay, let's progress to the next area. I'm sure as we fling come and go someone will have their ability to give me butt slam
Wait, where's enemy refling gone?
Is enemy refling gone?
Oh, there you are silly guber. I can see you
Okay, no, I'm sure as time goes on someone'll learn me butt slam and I'll butt slam use every time you come into the lobby. Okay
Uh, there's a lot of blood ahead, so I'm getting nervous. What are you?
Oh my god that beatles faster than me
People can I perish you?
No, that was long enough
Okay, you guys are absolutely lacking it already. I'm here for it. Oh, take this
Oh, no, he's flying. Okay. We don't like flying. Don't fly please
Oh, sorry. Sorry. I didn't mean to flash. I didn't mean to flash
What?
Oh my god teamwork almost coming off
It's okay. I'm allowed to be out somewhere. Who's the target?
I'm going for a seat
Wow, we're doing it take this small
Oh
Why am I locking on to a fee? Oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh like that kind of hurt a little much a lot
Oh my god my flash probably heal me. I have so much health
Oh refling. No, don't perish to the dragon
Okay, we can do it. We can do it. I'm running out of stamina, but we can do it. Don't fly off. Don't fly off
Don't fly off. No, don't target me. That's even worse
The camera isn't picking on his leg
The camera isn't picking on his leg. Okay, there we go. No, he's one HP
I'm gonna have to upgrade my flash ability
No, don't pick on me
Wow
I literally felt that burnt my butt cheeks there. Gee
Wow, that was fantastic. Are you beating up Beatles over there? Oh, we got dragon heart for doing that
I knew dragon power
I remember there's a key behind the dragon
What tear drops scarabs there are both crimson and cruelly crue
Cerulean
Peer drops scarabs defeat them to replenish blood. Ah, that is quite valuable. Actually, I quite like that
Rather fond of that. Hello. I'm sorry you can
But thank you for the key. It's of great importance
and helps
Go back to the church the original church in limb group
refling
Hello
Hello, am I alone again? I'm scared. I'm scared teleport me out
Uh, no they go to the bad church this one. No, that was a shack
Uh, I guess we're gonna be riding torrent
They killed the boys. No, don't make me alone
Oh
Wait, maybe it would actually be easier to travel downwards to the the temple. I think it might be easier to do that
Scared mom is a thing. Yeah. Okay, let's get on torrent
Let's get our headings. We need to go a teeny bit like this
We'll just be line it. There's no such thing as enemies. They're not real
And it's not just because I'm scared that I don't have my briefings with me
Um
Church question mark. No a little to the left
I'm trying to see it through the through the trees
This is a building
A little to the left again
We're drifting course a little bit
That's okay because it's not always linear
That's like life life isn't linear either. Ah
But we are here with you good, that's what I like to see
Because I'm just terrified to play games on my own that aren't made for children
If the game isn't made for children, I don't stand a chance. Uh, how do I get off work?
Thank you torrent for all your hard work
I'm keeping you safe. Hello. Oh lambkin
So please lambkin. Oh, that's an adorable me. I'm glad that you're enjoying my there isn't a sheet flow
But if we ever had a sheet youtuber lambkin is adorable
You have a taste for noble blood
I wish to anoint you a proper inductee
A knight to serve luminary mow the lord of blood
And establish a new dynasty
Luminary mow has strength
vision
and of course
love
so
What do you say my lambkin?
Anoint me
Okay
Yes, who would have it any other way?
now
Take this. Thank you
Lord of blood
Slaver favor. Sorry for your final trial. I'm putting my glasses on. I'm sorry
with a maiden's blood
Normally this ritual would involve
And recanting the wisdom of the two fingers. Wow, everything's so big
Wow, you guys are so big
Chance so easy to read now
you
Forget it
This guy seems a little tough. Okay. What do I do next? Where is story's removed toenail when you need?
Wait, why is me talking to this man my removed toenail?
The guy seems kind of sus. What could possibly go wrong? Exactly, right
um
Hi, mommy. I was always big. Hi
Next you need to go to the four belfrys to get the maiden's blood. Keep talking. Hello. The cloth is your final trial
Okay, okay. So kit with the blood of a maiden
The blood of anyone's maiden will do
Oh my god, this game is actually a lot more detailed now. It's not that blurry
I think why I say it's uh failing a little bit
Is your final trial the blood of anyone's
Uh, wow, you're so big now the first time a woman's ever said that to me. No
That's actually a really funny call. Let someone clip that so I can send it to that either
Arisa, she's actually made me too short. I just need a
Go back to where you started to the game all the way back here
in this church of
And summon so we can leave go to the temple quarter gray
or like
First church of
Go back where you fought the grafted sizing guy
Nano in the castello
Temple something in lunaria temple
Up here temple quarter
Temple quarter
God, I fucking love having my handheld. I'm not gonna lie. I don't want it right. It's just me
I don't understand people. I don't like backseat game and backseat the fuck out and be inside me while you backseat on my back
Soon his quest line will trigger some PTSD. Oh, no
Clipping while live is a pain in the butt. Is it actually the beginning of the game is the destination, but
We need to do that. We have to go to the four bell for you to be finsely. They're your best Ronnie. I always do
Okay, we flint time who's gonna shine
Get the enemy and we've got a few enemies got a lot of enemy
Oh wait, all right. Have you been in before?
I'm checking my list. You haven't actually been in before at all
and you come
Hey, come
Eat the coming. Yeah, I'm sorry
I shouldn't say stuff like that. I'm just a bit excited. Okay, I can actually meet you guys
Yes, it is. I'm gonna miss part. Oh
Can you not open up like a second browser?
Um, we have had oh well, I hit I hit yes. So I'm gonna put a little thing next to your name
Because I had to where the heck is your name if I don't wrote your name down
He each her
Wait, I've scratched out your name. Oh, well, you've got a little thing next to your name and then here we go
I recognize your fit
We did have you in I'm pretty sure is there any other refling that's not had a chance
Ty Lord I
Ty Lord you did come in but quite a while ago. Oh, sorry
Oh, I picked up a helmet. Oh, I'm getting fitted out. I'm getting kicked out
I
Yeah, yeah, you're allowed in you're allowed in no questions at absolutely no questions or issues at with that at all
How do you join so Elden Ring unfortunately do have to have played it before and
In order to wait you give me a great sword. I already have a great sword you goober. Wait, you're just giving me everything now
Oh, I'm getting armored up
Oh, no, wait, it did the summon bro could it work? Wait, no it did
Wait, who's
Thank you, you're welcome. Wait, am I going crazy? Did someone not get in right? Who?
Who was first?
um
Ty Lord you're the first you got we you got we thing next to your name now
Oh, we're gonna blast it
Hit our crew
Can you stop that?
Are you blessing us too even though you're the enemy?
Wait, you want me to joe wield?
You can do it
Hello, am I strong enough to joe wield?
Oh wait, I can't do anything yet. Oh wait, no I can't
I'm not used to them they're messing up my eyes
Oh my god
Wait, why is she not using the other one?
I'm just holding the other one
Oh my god
Oh my yeah
Oh
I'm
I'd come die, but I've no go around to finish an elven ring
So probably die immediately. Oh, you don't you don't have to be like MLG pro. Literally. Oh, there's something over here
a
lords on streets
Oh
I think I am
A chariot hell
Whoa, shake me up. I'm getting all pimped out. Oh my god. I'm a literally a Barbie doll. You guys are dressing me up
I'm a blonde pimple girl and well my watermelon girl in the fantasy world
You can kiss
You can play
Oh, I can't only
I can't only the
The octopus head because we're weak ones and like I know the fit doesn't complement but come on
Are you oh my god
That's so scary
Oh, wait, do I have that? Oh, there's an iron
Rotten grave keepers look. Oh, you drip. Okay. Let's check out the drip. Let's check out the drip
Uh
I think I know why you wanted me to wear this. Oh my god. Wait. I look so good
Look, I've got my belly out and everything
Oh
Don't do that. I'm scared. How do I even have that item that can do that?
Look I have a belly does anyone know how to teach me belly flop yet. I don't think so
Come on strongy. Let's go party
Right shall we head next maybe flings guide me for I know not what I'm doing
Okay, I'm following great career. Oh gate rear
Sorry either way is fine really. Um, the sword I gave you has but slam on it
Wait, no
Wait has but slam on the weapon tree
Wait, how do I use it
Reflings lie down right in front of me right now. Laying up and lie down. Do I make myself clear?
Lie line up and lie down
This is ridiculous
Ah
Okay, okay, you got it. Okay one
refling lambda
Next refling. Do you have lie down? You might need to put it on. This is ridiculous
I tried to join. Okay. Wait. Oh, do you not have it? Okay. Fuck it. You're going inside
Okay, I'll put mother weapon on I'll try and bonky guys as you come in
You have been bonked. Let us progress forth
Thank you
She's crushing his pelvis
Oh dear god make it stop
Yeah, I'm just following you guys. You guys are taking me this way. So I think we're going this way
I play on ps5 is elton ring cross please
It may be
Lucky is refling alive. Oh, no. No. No. This is what also happens at the convention, too
There's the alanie up on the floor put a little pillow under your head and sun
Uh, oh wait, sorry, there's refling's taking me to the left. I I think there might be a grave site up here a grave site
a safe site
Uh, okay. No, we're all converged on the same path. So I trust you
Elton ring doesn't support cross platform. Oh, I'm so sorry if you're not a pc player. I apologize
You're singing they're like sirens, but not me
She can my head man
Lie down for your daily milking and give us our daily milking and forgive those who as we forgive
Forgive us for the cringe as we forgive those who cringe against us
Lead us into temptation amen
Oh, I see I see I see okay invader sama you must
Yeah, okay. You already did it. You already knew what to do. Okay
What are those those are not a jellyfish up ahead
Oh, I'm being led a little to the right
Invader with
Disappeared
Pain oh well next yes, I always play stream snipe games. So please don't ever think
Uh, we've been playing that again. Azura and she be played full guys and it was adorable
I can't wait to play jelly bean
um
I managed to talk to oh
Oh dear i'm doing big role, but you can get a good look
Well something's making noise. Oh, it's just you guys absolutely blasting this guy. How could I be so silly?
Are you ready for the two-handed? Oh something's happening. Is he gone?
Oh
You're so strong
Please don't stop roll. Literally. I'm almost there. Look you can get such a good slam
Wait, no, sorry. I can't ruin it yet. Sorry. I can't spoil it yet. Ah, this is the problem I have
Here air to trees favor
I
Can't spoil it, but it's happening today. I believe raises maximum HP and equipment look wait a minute. Oh a fast roll now. No, we want
Thank you for the talisman. You guys are so selfless like you guys are so good to me
You're like, oh this one item I can only get by playing the game once. Oh here you have it strongy and it's like, oh you're so
Selfless is the description
If english isn't your first language, it kind of sounds like the word selfish, but it's opposite. It's selfless
So don't worry if you get a bit confused
The english language is a little bit like that where it sounds so a rolling girl for gen 2
I'll just have a boulder for gen 2. Just a rock
Um
Yeah, I got a third concept back. I quite like it
A few tweaks
And the things are heating up
And by that I just mean it's just concept art
You don't have to get too scared
Uh
This girl, what's a siphoth a rock, but not a slime
How dare you okay? I open the tip. I open the tip. I have an imbecile
So ward key
I am struggling with english today. Thank you for not making fun of me when I pronounce stuff wrong by accident
And like sometimes I'll be funny with a word, but I have to admit sometimes it just comes out all wrong
But like you guys don't make fun of me and I actually I'm quite pleased to put it in this one
Take it take my imbecile key
Are you teabagging me?
Oh
Did it work? Wait, what it's not gonna work. Thank you. Thank you
Uh, wait, it doesn't activate
Is it because you guys are here wait, I'm not going crazy. Did I not finger this?
Uh, I think you guys you have to do it solo. Oh, don't say such don't say such mean things to me
Don't say such terrible. No, no, no
You can just go press star and then multiplayer and then the fingers in there. You don't have to do it like that reflin
You don't have to do it like that
Just use the multiplayer finger press star and go multiplayer and use this that's how you leave
You don't have to do that. Don't do that. Make me upset ease again
Ah here
I don't know where the heck we're going because you guys just holding my hand so fair people
Just means I get to ramble a lot
Huh, what's that? You're tired to hear my voice. Can't really anyway. No
chapel of anticipation
Oh
Oh don't need to do this fight alone
I
Have to do it solo wait, I thought I could summon over here
Oh no, oh no, this can't be I am uh, um, uh, um, is there like a rune thing
I can smack on my head that helps me to be a bit stronger. I'm sure there's like something like that
Well, I don't seem to have it
Okay, well
I don't even
I'm gonna throw up. I'm so nervous. Oh god. Okay. Okay. Okay big swing big swing
Big swing. It's fine. Oh, just keep swinging. Just keep swinging. He's gonna walk into my swing. It's fine
He's gonna walk into my swing because I'm such a big girl. I'm such a big girl. I'm gonna die of blood loss
Okay, okay. I'm gonna heal
No, and then I'm gonna whack
Oh, he doesn't get staggered. He doesn't get staggered
Okay, hold on. I need to be a big girl. Right. He's swinging. He's swinging. He's gonna get some
another big dick
Okay, I completely missed
Oh, I dodged into that, but I'm
Oh my god
Okay, swing swing. I'm trying to figure out what the attack bar it is
I didn't know you could do that move
Oh my god, you're almost on the center
Your hp in my bar is all I have. I didn't know he could thrust like that
Fuck
We're both swinging for fucking lanes here
I'm out of stamina shit
Oh, no, what is that? What does that mean? What does that mean? What does that mean? He's used an incantation
But I don't know what it means
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no
Right, right, right, right, right
Ah, oh thank god. I'm so bad at what one
Oh
We friends don't ever make me do that again. He almost won because I suck
Oh my gosh
Wait, wait, that's where it came from
Wait, what?
What do I do? Wait, is this all?
And only a hundred levels higher than the recommended. No, that's where you go and go there. You got this. Okay. Okay. Thank you
Ah revenge. I did get my revenge fellow tarnish
So I guess if you kill him
Before he does the scream or whatever
You softlock yourself and you have to jump off the map anyway. Ooh, what's up here?
I love exploring
The storm hawk
Hey
curious
Is that an ash?
Even more curious. Hello
What are you?
Summoning spirits
I can know summon
storm hawk
Dean
Doesn't sound like a very bird friendly name, but sure
Jump the ledge
Wee
Angle back into the
Her
Die clothed with maiden's blood
Oh
Yeah, you don't look too whole. Are you feeling okay? Who perished you?
Did that guy perish right?
Yes
Wait, how are people dying?
Hmm back to very
Which is here, so I need to keep doing the horse stuff, but that's okay
That's your original maiden? Not millennia
Now we do a meme marker
Oh, I forgot I can swing on horse
Do it slowly you need to pick up an item on teleport
She was your original maiden, but she died before you awoke so millennia adopted me
Ah
Well, I have a blood soaked brag so I go talk to mr. Barry or bear. Sorry
Oh
My god, my first sword is spanking the horse of torrent. That's not very nice before see he's just trying his best
Oh, I heard that I hear that something's lurking in the shadows. I hear it
A dead maiden I heard a torrent link it's torrent a reef link
Oh
Dead maiden on
Okay, let's uh go off
And then speak to the mr. Hello, ah my lambkin
You've completed your final trial. Uh-huh and with this you are a formal inductee
A knight who will assist luminary mog the lord of blood in the establishment of a new dynasty
now
Give me your finger
This noble blood will be an immutable badge of honor once it settles
Inside of you
I guess I give him my finger
Um, this is kind of scary. What does the blood do to me though?
Thank goodness. This is a video game and not real life. It sounds like he's giving me a STD
The toenail moment is wait. He's taking it off
He's taking my fingernail
Good heavens clench your teeth or something
He took my fingernail
Never forget that feeling of agony for it is what binds you to luminary mog to all of us
You have the sweetest scream my lambkin
Is that the only oh another thing you should have this
A medal granted by the new mogwin dynasty
With the power to grant audience with luminary mog
I've gone out of my way to provide one to you
But you mustn't use it just yet
The meeting must wait until the mogwin dynasty commences
Luminary mog yet slumbers beside the divinity
We must endure a little longer
Uh
Use it use the inventory
You go to the audience grounds
Okay
Use it
I have no idea. This is no stuff. I don't know
Is there a safe site so I can call in the reeflings like right now?
I'm scared there's noises and I don't recognize it and I'm all alone. Oh no, I'm so scared
Oh
My god
It's all new
Oh, please don't attack me anything. I'm too scared. I'm just a baby
Please tell me the reeflings can spawn in here. Oh, I don't like this not one bit. I'm sorry
I don't recognize it. Can I live a lot maybe?
No, I can't live a lot
Okay last increase the replenish rate do it again. No, I only had one
Okay, so I'm in time. Thanks the makers. I don't have I've been here before
I don't really recognize it
Is that you president Nixon? Okay, we'll try you again
I wrote your name twice now and I have to keep like scoring it out
Because you're not able to
Uh
Were you I think you're actually an invader
Does an enemy reefling want to come in and witness bear? Okay?
You actually made it in your pc didn't shit the bed so I can write your name down mr. President Nixon of the united states
number president
No, wait, there's only been wait. How many precedences are being?
I don't know how many presents I need an enemy reefling or because we're about to do a boss fight. We should be fine
46 ish. Yeah, let's see like 65 but that's not correct
Oh hero ran money money, okay
I will call in an enemy
is
a changeling
We've not had you have we
A changeling
Are you the one that had reefling is your name and I've just been debated
There are still a ways before the boss fight my thought is he looks like a
A newbie from anime
Well, like the protagonist and then like the the the main girl is like a smoking hot babe. Hello everything
Hi
Check out the oh my god, you look like sweet and sour from kung fu chaos with your claws
Oh, yeah, are we just ignoring I guess is he even attack?
Oh
Oh my god, they have so much hp
Okay, not attacking not attacking do not engage. I repeat reeflings. Do not engage do not engage
They have insane hp amounts
I maybe need to think about upgrading my weapons to be honest
Do not engage uh, uh, maybe engage in this
So
Uh, I think we're gonna have to help
Ah
From what?
Wow, oh no
What are you giving me
You're you're stanching black
What is going on? I think the ping is pretty high unfortunately
Servers are probably going nuts for how many players are on right now. Not gonna lie
Have you made it to the dlc? I think that's what's happening right now little reefling
We're we've just soaked a rag and made in blood and been given a talisman to transport
Teleport
Whoa, whoa, whoa, he's beating the fuck out of the reeflings stop it. Oh my god, I think I need to upgrade my stuff
Oh
Okay, gang this man reeflings have this man's balls
You dancing like oh, hello
Oh, don't be here is a customer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I just wanted to see what you're all for
Ah, these rooms are the things I pop on my phone
Someone's fighting behind me
Alleviates impending blood loss. Oh, that's why you gave me that. I understand. Thank you very much, mr
No, no, you're fine. You're a great shopkeeper. Thank you. Someone healing me
Who are you fighting? Oh
Ah
Momy protect us. I'm trying but I'm gonna terrible job
Oh, no that invader reeflings need to be careful invader reeflings. Do you not have a heal?
Oh, we all Lord's ruin for doing nothing
That's what I like to see
Oh, there's an item
What does it mean?
Oh
Okay, we can stagger if we group violence. I'm sorry
If we group violence we can stagger. I don't know like those guys. They seem so strong
I definitely gonna do a weapons upgrade
Sanguine nobles I hate them
Oh
Until a little beyond did you like me on my opera?
I'm gonna get some food in my tum tum soon. And then I'll have even more energy to know you guys for even longer
Oh
Did we sneak past these guys? Okay, let's let's all upset this guy
Okay, uh, is everyone on the lift? Oh, we're all on the lift
What are they doing?
They're praising him
Hi
That makes a hundred Lord wins this stream. It actually does. Okay. I'm off the lift. Hi. Hi
Uh
Oh, no
I remember
What is boiled crab Danny to eat boiled crab?
I have a memory greatly boost physical damage
Thank you
It's time. Oh, no, I completely in whole heart as they remember
Oh, no
I'm pretty sure one of you guys had to carry me completely through this fight
Oh
That's not good oh this can't be that's not good at all
Dearest
My heart you must abide alone a while
Oh
Welcome honor the guest
To the birthplace of our
dynasty
I committed myself to you. You don't need to attack me. Good sir. Oh dear fucking lord. I'm scared
We feeling
Oh my god, right. They're coming they're coming. It's fine. Bring the guards. Bring the guards the guards and should be rang
Okay
I've completely forgotten his attack card. I'm gonna be honest
I have completely forgotten the strip
Right
Did he just call it a jewel it's a jewel
Well, we wear a trio and then you ruined it
Fuckin hell president Nixon you're actually teaming troops. I'm not gonna lie
Oh my god, he hit me in two
He's counting
We're getting a free countdown. Don't you have to pay for that kind of content?
I
May need a potion did you upgrade your sword?
Why have a chat bring her here because they're gonna carry me
Are you guys up here or are you back at that grace site? Can I summon you out here? Is anyone here?
Oh, there are leaflings up here
You don't have any items for damage reduction here. I got a crab leg
Okay, this is gonna take a few attempts. Please don't worry. Please remain seated for the rest of this ride. Um
Wait, did I not come you in? Yeah, I did
Uh, there's a flask tier that counters that one move
Should I just like hold back and let president nixon do it because I'm gonna be honest president nixon didn't even get hit
Hi lord, you've not done a boss battle. Milena. You've definitely not fought with us
Okay, I might just hold back and see if the leaflings can do it once we're all in
Definitely my a little crap leg though
Yeah, president nixon. I'm not gonna lie. I don't think I see him got hit one
I
Know ironically there was a point on the stream where I got distracted and stood suddenly strong
He says we fling and I responded out loud if that was my name. No, I'm
Stop that's the cutest thing ever. I love that kind of corruption. Holy crap. It's not even corruption. That's just like straight up love
Stop. I love that. Hi. Are you doing a little parallel thing? Right? Are you guys ready?
Um, I might hold back. Maybe I should invest in like long range weapon do
You still get hit even if you run away. Stop. It's an aoe across the whole pitch
Oh my my runes. Uh, sorry mr. Bloodman. I know this is really important fight, but wow
Oh, I don't recall
I don't want to be a little pussy though. I'm put my poor leaflings to the pair
He makes it rain down with mud
And he's like throwing it everywhere
It was fun being someone embarrassing to immediately die a moment. Oh, is that you?
That's funny you say anything though. Thank you for the
Oh
No, no president Nixon the 46th president of the united states. Where are you when we need you?
Is it just me?
Okay, no
Okay, okay. Okay. This is gonna take a few attempts. I don't really think I'm gonna break them people's names
When it comes to a boss fight. Thank you so much maths one six one eight to be so specific for the super chat. Don't be embarrassed
and
This is a tricky one come to the top of the elevator
out of morgues fight and we're just gonna try our best
Literally do not be embarrassed about failing because um, I'm literally so over leveled for this
I'll try and
Do uh different things, but I won't count your name against a boss fight just because it's
I have no idea like how many times this is gonna take should be honest
Is this the dlc or not? We're trying to access the dlc
We are outside of mark wins dynasty mausoleum, but we need to kill him in order to access the dlc section
I'm under the impression
And come hi
Uh, don't be afraid to join. Um
This is gonna take a few this is gonna take a few attempts. Okay. I can't say I don't want spoilers
Yes, there will be spoilers for the dlc
Um, but thank you for wanting to hang. Um, Azura
And me mercy and shibir are doing a collab right now
If you'd like to check them out at any moment ac has finished up her stream while she was very drunk
Hi
I'm gonna eat a lobster. Oh, I've not done the ball crushing move. Okay. Hold on. I forgot to crush everyone's
Uh, I need I forgot to do the clam slam
Right, do you want to lie down too and I'll climb slam you?
Yeah, and do you have lie down or maybe you don't have lie down? Oh, no you have lie down
Okay, these guys see I think I can handle two reeflings at once
I don't know you can do it
Okay, I missed a little bit. Hold on. Let me try again. Okay. I missed a bit. Okay. That was just based then
It's like there's oh, yes, please check out Azura's monetization stream. Um
It is going to be fantastic for helping her move out. Please do check it out. Um
She is doing little doodle request and you can see her little hands
So, please, uh, check out Azura Dili her link is in my description
You can literally see right now
She's celebrating monetization because youtube finally let her be monetized one cheek pair of reefling
I mean, I got enough room ready reeflings
On your mark
Maybe I can pick up my soles again. I mean, it's not the biggest deal if I lose them
Do you guys have that dragon breath attack?
Oh
How can it we be like how can Abby level up?
Oh no
Is this the countdown thing that's on me?
What happened?
Don't do that again. How am I supposed to survive that? What the fuck?
Oh
No, oh no reeflings. I'm so sorry reeflings. I'm so sorry reeflings. I'm so sorry
Okay, I'm gonna back off I need to back off. Sorry. Oh, like I don't want to leave you guys to fight them on your own
Like you need. Oh my god. Look at that killer worm. Did you see the worm? I
Just like it. Okay. I'm gonna hold back as much as it pains me to watch you guys do all the heavy lifting like all the time
I'm gonna see if there's anyone I don't recognize
You have been in but you were very early. Oh just straight up rear
Not had you
Hey, what a funny name
Please again, don't worry. I'm not gonna like hold this against you
I have like a separate list and it's called boss fight
So I have your name
So I know not to be like what worm there was like a loading screen blue neon worm. Are you guys ready to carry me?
Oh, you want this one too? You want this one too?
This is our pre-war ritual if you didn't know most there was like some sort of rituals normally for like back in the day
Where you go a war it would be like a send-off party
It would be everyone getting drunk and plastered it'd be this it'd be that I guess this is our equivalent of a pre-war party
You get clams land. This is there. We do a good luck. Bye. Oh take it
This is our pre-war celebration. Okay, are you guys ready to carry me?
I don't even know if there's a point of me eating the crab leg
Oh, did you say thank you? I think you did. Okay, let's get busy
I'm gonna let you guys do it again about slams worth even if we can carry it. Don't worry if I perish. I
suck
I can't destroy these
Okay, let's commentate over the reeflings. I'm just gonna crouch in the corner
Reefling goes in for a quick slam. We see some magical effects going into play
We we've got rain on blood taking out almost half of the health of the reefling. Oh
Three-fourths of the reefling help. He does heal up successfully recovering almost 50% of that HP up to 75%
for his full max HP capacity
We get a swing. We're now down to 50. We're back up to full health almost just a few
We're going in for hits. We're doing melee against the enemy. The enemy's name I've forgotten
The blood caster guy
We do have our poor reefling getting picked on taking all the HP damage second reefling comes in for the clutch to take
The aggro off of the boss
Possibly to allow some heals. We do have rain on blood effect on screen
Okay, we're now 50% on our second reefling in command. However, we do seem to have some sort of blood steal effect possibly
for health restoration
Hopefully we do have
Oh, we're getting picked on
Commentator comes in to take the aggro off of the reeflings. She runs away again and sheer panic and scaredness
Oh, I need to stand up to get a faster run
Okay commentator does come in for a swing to take the the aggro off of the reeflings very aggressive aggro on the reeflings
Okay, this is why I can't get involved. I'm sorry
Commentator does heal up. We've got a moon attack from Rena herself the moon lordness
We do have a countdown on the blood attack. We've got three rings around us
Get ready to heal
I don't think I have enough
Do we need to go get more flasks for me or a sacred tear possibly
Oh, you guys are so close Ronnie needs a quick tour for the stuff. She can't be handled like the flask
I think we might need to do flask tears
Nah, just don't get hit. Okay. Okay. I will fully stand back and watch you guys get annihilated
Okay, I'm gonna fully stand back. All my motherly instinct is being paused on hold because I don't want you guys to get hurt
It let punish boost
Uh, what wait, is that that actor who's seen me?
Who's seen me
Have we got
You've not done a boss fight yet. I do have a separate boss list, okay
Nah, do healer to sit on her. It's all when he does his siphon
NIHIL can be avoided using a specific visit
I don't have it. Wait, are you president nixon on and all it can be honest
Be honest
Crouch if you're president nixon be honest, you know, no, well, well, no, you're just doing that because I did that
Uh, are we doing the pre-retual of the clam slam or what's you want pre-retual clam slam or are you guys ready to go for the fight?
It's up to you as refland you can pick. Oh, is that cowering for the slam? Do you not have lie down?
Oh, it does make you lie down. Okay
Clam slam
Boom. Do you have clam slam? Do you want clam slam time?
No clam slam for you. Oh, yeah. Yeah, you're covered take it off
Let's go. Okay. We're ready for battle. We have done our pre battle battling
You do not need to visit. Holy shit. Is that male gear reference?
Okay, ready steady. I'm gonna commentate again
And
The two reflinks enter the battle dome
To defeat the boss something we have none other than the famous actor
Bersy me and Kagoro hits with the fucking moonbeam for over
Whoa
For over half damage 50% on lord of blood mog already. We are mogging him off
These two reflinks complementing each other one for magic on the debuffs the second for the meleys
Hit him down to almost
one four
Prepare yourselves reflings
Prepare for heels reflings prepare for heels
Prepare for heels the heels have been prepared the guards have been rang
I am out of freaking heels. So I hope he doesn't do that again. Uh, or I'm in trouble even though I'm not even fighting
Okay, he's got his wings out. He's in his second phase. I assume
We've got a few more moon attacks from Ranny
Magic refling did go down a wee bit
But he's okay. Melee refling going in for some of the kill. Unfortunately does get hit a little bit on the side
Uh, oh melee refling getting cornered not good for the aggro has been taken by magic refling
But uh magic refling now taking the aggro meleys getting in position again
Melee refling is down. I repeat melee refling is down
Magic refling his own one hp. I want to interfere. I want to interfere. I must interfere
Magic refling probabilities. I'm a heels and cannot do anything. Oh shits on me. I surely I can do it. Surely I have to get enough
Now he's like walking away
He's like slowly walking away out of my tank
Grab your runes. It's okay. It's okay. We have plenty
It's okay. Literally he slowly walked to the side and I couldn't help
I'm nothing but air. Look how long my sword is
I'm gonna go get a quick can of cola. Okay reflings. I'll be just a millisecond
This is my little foot feeling dry
Okay refling. Let's see who's ready to take the test
You have not gone against the ultimate enemy and you come
Uh
Slade you did actually take a whack at him. Just a fella has not taken a whack at our beloved god lord of blood
You have not taken a whack at him
Okay
I like it mog is mid difficulty people just have reduced damage
Yes, if you didn't know when you joined me as a refling as an aide if you will
Um, your stats are reduced and so is your damage because it's so you don't make me the game too easy for me
Oh, are we doing clam slam ritual? Okay. Okay. Let's get it out. Let's get it out
Actually, I could probably just keep the sword out. Do you both want to line up before we do two and one?
Or do you want separate you're allowed to get separate?
I'll see you have the pose
Okay pre ritual done. Let me get my weapon tree out
Okay, ladies and gentlemen can our reflings do it. We appear to have two
Maly reflings ready to take on mog the lord of blood as they both enter the arena
Using stamina to get closer. Who's going to take the aggro first? Oh, we've got oh, we have a magical sway
looks can be
this evening because
I were mainly
Refling as no one said I can't join in for this because I beat him for dlc yesterday
And I killed him before he could do his meal
Neat
Thank you so much for the five. Oh, we're gone
Yes, unfortunately, it is pc only both
melee
Very close combat. Oh, it's magical melee. That's it. This refling's participating in
If I can see correctly from the corner of my eye
We do oh, okay
Stone male stone refling is getting a little bit hit, but that's okay
His shield is helping him armored out the wazoo we hope
We are already on 60 health on more the lord of blood. These reflings are definitely making a
short work of this lord
maybe
Short range melee is the way, but we do have a physics level up there if I if I'm not a physics class usage
It prepared to heal prepared to heal you can do it
Okay, we do have a moon room moon long uh being used
We're looking good. We're both all of us are high health
Oh, we took out a beating on his health bar 17 took a bit of tick damage as we're for 44 is able to heal up
But worry not he is going straight back into the fight again
I am actually out of range for the second refling that is how far back I am hiding
They are fighting him at the stairs
Thai lord receiving over 90 percent damage. Oh, no. Oh, no. Okay. We are able to heal. We might be at max heals
We're not sure
Oh dear
Oh dear, is it all falling apart me friends?
Doesn't matter
I don't have heels. I don't have heels. I don't have heels. He's he tricked me. He tricked me
I don't have heels. I don't have any more heels. He tricked me. I'm empty
He freaking came for me. Okay. I'm hiding up at the egg. Don't bring him to the egg. Okay
Stay down there
Stay down here
Oh, no, Thai lord is kind of low. I think he's out of heels
One refling is there and it's now rests on the shoulders of melee magic refling
Where it looks can be this evening. He takes 50 percent damage from the boss
He does manage to heal up. Oh, but he takes another 60 percent damage of phil health bar. It rains blood and it captures
No
I can do it. I can do it. I'm so brave. I'm so brave and magical
I am not afraid
I know the boss's mechanics. I do not he's gonna do it. It's like, okay. I'm not even getting a bit
I'm burning alive. I literally I'm not gonna get okay. I got a hit. I got 127 damage
127 damage
Yay
I tried my best
I have absolutely no idea what his freaking hit registration is or anything
I tried to scarlet rot cheese but it didn't do enough. Don't worry. Don't worry. We're gonna keep at it
I'll give it a couple of more attempts and if it really is too much
What we'll do is get some flasks for me and some golden seat because we are kind of skipping
Salad you did have you had a shot at this?
Weeb hasn't had a shot at this. Sorry. I'm like literally just renaming you guys
Uh, do I recognize
You have two you have a clobber and a long
Why won't it let me interact with your sign and won't let me interact with you
I'm teabagging you. It's not doing anything. I have buckham salad. I'm so sorry. My brain registers you as salad
Also smithing so and strong his weapon needs upgraded should be hitting way more than a hundred. Okay
Okay, we're gonna clap mogs cheeks and then we'll maybe do a bit of cheeky. Wow. I cannot interact with anyone right now
Weep weep your internet is
Is having a hard time connecting. I think you're about to time out not gonna lie
All right, hold on everyone take a sip of water, please or a sip of some sort of liquid. Oh, no, you couldn't connect
Right, who was it? Oh, no, you've moved wait
Drag you've not had a wallet
At this king at this king at the sword
Can you come in?
Good everyone's like not coming in
Have you had a work at the boss?
You haven't you actually haven't had a work at the boss
Okay, our two reeflings have got they've been decided. We've got some sort of long
two-handed spear
Hi, are you ready to kill the boss?
Oh, thank you
Little reeflings risen me. Oh, he's giving me compliments before I take his boy cherry
Are you are you okay? Are you ready for me to take your boy cherry?
There we go already for war. That's what we like to see
Ready for battle. So we have uh melee
Let's get to it. This reeflings ready to go. He does not care. He does not care about the well
He does care because he did get pre-ritual
We do appear to have two melee reeflings again, which is perfectly fine
We're gonna see how they complement one another and their strategies against none other than the lord of blood
I'm gonna hydrate because keep saying I'm gonna hydrate and then I don't
Okay, here we go
Okay a bit rusty a bit rusty we have received a 30 percent health damage on one reefling a bit rusty stone reefling
Let's see because you got stone shield
Oh, we have a bit of sorcery a bit of sorcery looks can be this evening
Again magic being used not fill melee classes. Perhaps mistaken
Perhaps mistaken again close range reeflings
Taking on one another. We do have a 50 percent hit on drake
But we don't want him going down. He does have a physics class get active. I'm not sure what the boon
The bonus is but he does have it active because he looks like a little bubble right now. Oh, no
Ambron goes down to
10% does manage to heal up with two health flasks. However
Unaware we will need to prepare for healing at the blood loss section
We'll need to prepare oh again lower than 50% on our
On that
Oh, you're a stone reefling. I got I got a few years. I got a mess up
Maybe we need a magic in it
We're gonna do this
We're getting a few wax in here in there. We're doing tick damage. We've got 2000 4000
5.4
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa reeflings working overtime with their magic
Do you love reeflings don't die on me now?
Okay, we did manage to avoid the annihilation
attack
We are back to 50 health on the main boss. We are getting a few tallywax in but we are taking tick damage from the
floor
We are at 20 on one reefling. He does manage to dodge until he gets taken. It is now up to drake
Can he one man this boss is the question we do not know
How many restorative potions there may be
We are doing
Don't worry reeflings. I'll come in clutch. I'll come in clutch. I'm surely I'll come in clutch
Wow
199 damage. That's the most damage I've done against some. Yay
I beat my record. My damage is the 350
nine damage total against the boss. Let's go
In strontis army no reefling dies a virgin
Honestly, I mean I can like I'll take one for the team
Is it even taken one for the team if everyone enjoys it?
Hmm, can't send you off on your own like that. Uh gaav is not taking a cheeky stab
At this boss
Uh and who else? Uh
Sean has not taken a stab at this boss. My boss list is getting very full
I don't know
Look we got it. Oh, we've got a blood build samurai blood build
Oh, we're doing the pre ritual of coming of I cannot send a reefling into war without uh, no weapon leveling
Uh, we will soon tm
Oh, we we have fisticuffs. You're gonna defeat the the blood of
With fisticuffs. No, you can okay ready
Close your close your eyes reefling. You're gonna enjoy what comes next
You did it
Ariya's ready
Ariya's
What is this?
You're gonna beat them up with your gloves. I don't think I've ever seen gloves used before
Okay
Okay, let's see what happens reeflin
Okay, they're coming in
We do have magical boxing gloves in play. Um, not sure how that's gonna go
We are both melee again close combat with the reeflings. We do have a physics class active on gaav reeflings
Oh, no, we have two both of them have physics activated. We're down to 50 health on a big old swing
We are full health again. Thankfully, uh commentator is gonna run to the egg. So don't worry
Don't worry commentator is running to the egg. I repeat commentator to the egg
Okay, we are getting walloped a bit
We are getting very close gaav is cutting it close with the health
But art is able to restore health overall. Do you need to make sure we have physics?
health flasks in preparation for our uno dose trace blood n i l i h annihilation
On the second we do need to prepare
But the reeflings are getting some swings in
The damage is down to 60 on the boss health. I think a little hydration
We do have a dose
We are mailing it the out the wazoo. Oh, we are getting pummeled though, but we do we do seem to heal
We're making it rain blood
Um, but it is not ketchup season for this streamer
We do have full health on both reeflings. They are taking tick damage. Okay. Here we go. Here we go. Get ready
Oh wait, we have three rings. Is that the one he does it?
Okay. Okay. We're ready. We're prepared. We know how to drink. We're good boys and girls out here
We know how to drink drink drink drink chug chug chug, but don't get steaming because I don't think it's a weekend yet
We we are full health for both reeflings. We are in phase two with full health
Scab does take a cheeky 50. However, can recover possibly unless out of flasks
Yeah, wow, both reeflings melee second phase full damage physics up
Hold on. Is this the run is? Oh, I spoke too soon. I spoke too soon. No, don't leave me with a boss
Don't leave me with a boss
We are down a reef like oh, we're down a second reef like
No, okay. It's okay. It's okay. Right. He's gonna do one big old thrust at me
Or well, I'm not gonna be able to do it. But it's fine. It's fine
So, can you know scarlet brought cheese this man cheat reeflings cheese man right now?
Oh, I hit for 407. I hit for 500. Let's go
I'll take it. I'll take it. That was a new record. That was like 600 plus
Oh my god, I have a new high score against him
You cursed it. You cursed it. Okay. I won't I won't say anything then I made just
Uh, you can scarlet wrote cheese him. I just did it badly. Oh
That's okay. We have a few more attempts. Do we know?
I process like three frostbites. Yeah
It's 20. It's sundae
Wait, are you allowed to get junk on sundae if you have work on monday? I thought friday
Um, we have aqua the wise and you come we have a mage
Interesting interesting interesting
Um, and then we have throngler. Have you had a chance at this lovely boss?
You have not had a chance at the boss boss yet and you come for rongler
We have a clear we have jewel wield mage runny
And oh, we've got a little pirouette. Oh nice to meet you. How elegant are you?
And then we have second refling that's loading in right now
Oh, we have even a polite little bow
And then we have throngler the jewel wield melee. Okay. We're gonna see how magic and melee complement each other
Oh, you don't need to pray to me. I assure you I will bless you with everything you need in a second
Okay, let's see if our reflings can complement one another with two different strategies one with magic
One with jewel wield melee. Let's see how it goes. I've got 13 minutes left of saturday. That'll do that'll do
Okay
Reflings have entered the battle dome magic is taking
Some elements. We're doing the moon beam runny approach
melee
Oh, we are getting sprayed down for a nasty hit. We are locked on to mage until melee refling takes
The aggro sort
I'm gonna move to the egg
But just keep fighting you guys are doing great. Just keep it up speed. You're doing great
Uh, we do have
Okay, okay. Well, there's not gonna give me anything is it? No, I didn't have anything. Okay
We do have are they complementing each other?
Can the melee refling keep aggro so the mage
Refling can keep it up and just keep blasting and doing that tick damage is the question
We are on the second ring of the aoe n i l m n o p attack
um
So we do have to mentally prepare for what comes next. We are doing tick damage over time
We are already close to 50 damage of the boss
Is melee magic the way to complement one another? Reflings? We will find out that strategy live
We do have a
I may have just killed us, but don't worry. I may have just killed us
I may have just killed us because I don't have enough class
Okay, no, it's fine. It's fine. Oh our mage refling is down is up to melee refling that has all of the aggro at the moment
He is debuffed because he is helping me in my game. He does take a dodge for the aoe
Oh the area of effect of these flames that are left over is just
Overwhelming the power the power of the lord of blood is a bit too much, but that's okay. We're trying our best
Take it
Okay, I'm out stamina. Well, I tried
Completely out of stamina. There we go
Okay, not bad not bad it was interesting
This is gonna hurt very that was interesting. I think maybe
A magic and a melee might be most complementary because if the melee takes the fill aggro
In theory should I be doing magic right now?
Oops, sorry wrong one. Okay, let's go again
Okay, who have we got um, I don't recognize you Ezra income
Ezra income
And we did just how are you already in there?
Uh thigh lord, we did have you have an attempt. I'm just gonna check. There's no one here that hasn't had an attempt yet
a
Rivers you've not had an attempt just far as that my eye can see no and you come
Wait, yeah, no I haven't I haven't actually
Hello, wait, we must do our pre ritual. Maybe I should just keep this out to be honest. Maybe I just keep it out
Okay, are you ready get blessed get blessed get blessed and then now it's your turn for the blessing
That's right. You better say you're getting blessed get blessed get blessed get blessed
Okay pre-war ritual complete
let's go
I'll just leave I'll leave the sword on there's no way I'm finishing the boss off
we appear to have
a
Shield and sword reefling and then a two-handed reefling
No, we I see some magic stuff going on hold on
Uh my small brain cannot comprehend that if you look like melee
That they might have some magic spells up. Uh, there is a gray bar on the H
Uh, there is a gray bar on the enemy already not sure what that means
But is that going to stop the reeflings? Absolutely not
Uh, we do have a pressure
Downfall magic that holds an enemy in place momentarily
Curious we are at 50 hell max hp reduction. Wow
That must come at a pretty price a pretty price of mana indeed
Well, the reeflings are going for it. We're raining blood
But it's not enough to hurt the reeflings extra careful extra cautious
Hardly any damage done to the reeflings at all and yet lord of blood is down on his luck
He is below 50. He is doing now
To try his best to get any smidgen back
But he does not understand as just as
Strongies stamina is unending. So is the reeflings for they have the fortitude
They have the insight one reefling does go down
We are remaining on our two-handed reefling
shit
Not good
Maybe joining the fight
I can't i'm out of hp
Can it's on your reeflings. He does get a few blood strikes in the enemy is very low. I'm tempted
I'm very tempted to swap to the the second grace or just in case all I have to do all I have to do is the tiddly wing
Don't fuck it up. Just a tiddly wing
Just a tiddly wing just a tiddly wing just a tiddly wing come here come here right now
It's I literally have to tickle his ballsack. Please. Please. Please. Let me just run and jump
Please the reeflings the reeflings have turned so hard. Please. Please. Please
Oh
Please. Please. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. She throws
She throws one hp
One hp
One hp she throws
Oh my god
Oh my god, what what a duel those two reeflings were truly complemented one another
Uh, if we've not had you coming into the boss reeflings outstanding effort. I'm just going to check uh high
Pre-stess you have not had a whack at the boss
He uh, if an high pre-stess and you come
Fantastic effort. It was a tiddly wing. I do apologize for messing that up
But at the end of the day, we're here for a fantastic time. That was very well played
All reeflings very well played against this boss just as a reminder when someone comes into your world to help you out
One little ceremony done. What about your ceremony? Hmm?
Did you think I forgot to ceremony you do you not have lie down? You don't want it?
I'm afraid it's not optional. You will take what you get
You have been ceremony eyes
Uh, yes, all reeflings are helping. Please don't ever feel bad if you mess up or have a little mistake
You should use a blessing to get your hp back
Maybe maybe I should
Now let's see we have a magic sword and play by another and high pre-stess which makes exact sense
Considering the name oof is going for the close combat already picks up the aggro from
Mog
But are is this reefling joe enough to mug mug himself?
We are taking some serious magic damage on one of the builds of the reeflings
Oh
Riffling already down. Uh, it appears oof is timing out question mark
Uh, reeflings connection has timed out
Um
Uh, sure
Sure, why not? Sure. Why not? Okay. We tried our best with what we had in church. It's fine
It's fine. We tried what we could
It's joining after nil you can use the blessing
Okay, maybe one of the weakest attempts, but it was an attempt nonetheless as long as you get up and keep trying
What's how does that song go you get knocked down?
But I get up again
The per DC let's just like is that reeflings standing on the floor?
Uh, we do have someone called okay, and you come okay
We haven't had okay
Who have we got?
I think you're patiently waiting to see if there's no one new
You
We've got a joe weild on the hip
No, we've got joe weild in the hands
HMRC make sure you pay your taxes
Please hold back 30 of your income to pay taxes to any at any point and please remember to reclaim
Um anything you can on your taxes do not be embarrassed
Reminder that billionaire companies do not pay a single penny of tax while you
do
So please do not ever feel bad if you want to claim for example if you are a car mechanic you can
Claim back washing up liquid on your clothes because you need to be presentable for work
As long as you can justify the cost of your daily living me. Uh, are you guys not lying down? Hello?
If you don't lie down, I'll make sure it's our word, okay?
Yeah, that's what I thought you better put. Yeah
Right you your next
I fit you just fine
Yeah, I have to admit it's going to start whistling at the rate. I'm uh doing these rituals, but we're trying our best
Right. Are you ready reeflings? You have been
What am I looking? Oh, okay. Sorry
Right, we have a bleed
It looks like a bleed build on one reefling and it appears to be
Okay, we're chugging a lot of flasks. We do have a
Something going on. I don't this is a lot of stuff going on with that reefland. I have no idea what magic is filling
A bit strong that's so unfair
Come on reeflings show mommy what you're worth
Nah, you you're worth isn't based on the price to be a boss for me in a video game. Please don't worry
Wow
Okay
Okay, sorry my throat's getting a bit sore and I'm like, I need to try and
Say um, okay raining down on blood. We do have a meaty swack of 50% on hmrc to pay your taxes
Uh, okay standing
No close close combat melee again
Hmc struggling with the dodgers a little bit
Okay gets caught up in an attack that wasn't even targeted on him. Hmc is backing off
He's trying his best
Uh, please don't worry about the enemy coming over to me. I do have the health to
Not get whacked. We are low health. Are we out of healing is the question are we out of healing is the question
For hmrc. I know you don't have an r in your name for hmc. You are down
Single reefling called okay left up on the map. We are experiencing blood loss together, but that's okay
What I pressed x
I was pressing x sorry. I'm flopped at that
I was pressing x you can literally hear my finger on the button. I have audio evidence of me hitting x
brah
That's just sabotage the reef looms
Is that right outrageous my goodness, outrageous
Wow, okay, uh country pumpkin you've not had to show pumpkin
um
Barrette
Don't recognize you barrette. You've not been in either is country pumpkin and barrette gonna compliment each other
Let's check out the build. We have heavy armor
weaponry
I don't know what these weapons are
What are you doing?
You get a parent you and uh, so this this pose is face-sitting if you want face-sitting. Okay
Hi
And you are
Schematar joe wheel. So this is face-sitting if you kneel and if you go in the floor
It's it's clam slam. And then if you want the butt, it's something else
But I don't know what it is. You have both been blessed simultaneously due to the a massive circumference that my budget you provide
Uh, we'll need to think of a pose if you want, uh,
Veno
Are the reeflings ready on your mark? I'm gonna see
Another grip of heroes has fallen messed. Well for your watches in
Okay, we're good. We're good. Well, we have magic coming out from country pumpkin did not actually
um
Both again trying to get nice and close for one another
Uh having the agile constantly swapping
Which might be a good thing to give one reefling a break from the other pumpkin does cast we have lower hp on the boss total
Raining blood not quite getting it but rest down to 50 percent
However, he is going to be able to get out of the area
He is rolling around as if he was on fire. Remember folks at home to stop drop roll
That's the best way to deal with your issues but rest taking on very close combat damage
Does manage to heal up. We're gonna heal heal. I'm I'm spamming eggs. You can hear it spam
Here it gets banned in the microphone. I have the controller right up. There we go. Feeling healed
For the best I can do
We are doing magic damage. Don't worry about bringing the boss over to me. I can't evade so don't panic
It's very unlikely the boss will target me at any point
Words spoken like a true
Main character
Pumpkin and bereft going in it again. We are on phase two
We're looking quite strong face to his very aggressive very hard to
Harry with the perfect timing of your attacks
Most common dodges to roll into the enemies. However, due to his aoe fire left over
This is almost like committing
slower slide
So to dodge this enemy it is not easy
We are down to less than 20 health on the both bereft on the five percent taking tick damage from the aoe fire
bereft seems to be out of potions
He is giving it his all no health no health
pumpkin
Can he do it can pumpkin finish off the last less than 10 percent health of the lord
of blood himself
Pumpkin goes in for a big hit
Does 500 just shy of 500 again doing some tick damage
We are less than five percent boss health. Can country bumpkin make it happen less than one percent health?
Yes, he did it fantastic
Oh, he flicks it on them. He flicks it on the fantastic jewel
The reth and pumpkin managed to do it together fantastic
cooperation between the reeflings
con
Gradulations special shout out to all reeflings that participated in that boss fight
I if I can read my writing correctly
Uh, I have malena. I have veil dragon. I have salad wilson. That's not your name. I have rare
I have acaroth. I have I can't read my own writing
Spargot stronger Ezra
Steven busume or whatever his name is that actor
Rivas
Carragoth
High priestess tyloid. Okay. Just
a fella hmc pumpkin bereft drag umbran
Uh gur
Gar
Yeah
I'm Sean all reeflings who helped with that boss fight
Do not be sorry if you missed it because there are plenty more boss fights in this game
For you to come and hold my hand and thank you reeflings. That was fantastic. Now we can actually progress with the dlc
Yeah
I'm going to remove that marker. Are we not wait, you can have more than one marker
I'm strange
Sure above ground. Yes. I have a marker then I would like to remove
Yeah
Are you playing elden ring is so fog I'm getting carried through elden ring playing it is a bit of a stretch
But so true rain so true
How are you feeling now? Are you any better?
Guys don't know rain's it rains a little bit under the weather if I'm not wait wait
Rain is under the weather question mark
Question mark rain is under the weather. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Am I just making up lore for rain? That's not true
Up next red Ann and oh Kaleid
Real but cool. I knew it. I freaking you. I said it out loud and I was like wait a fucking minute
I fucked up there could you both start with the layer R?
But surprise surprise you're two different people. Fuck me, man. Sorry. I do
Humbly apologize. Right. We now need to go to Kaleid
So we actually need to go like all the way to the star
Honestly take us to the church of ele
Get the grease did I not get it?
I didn't get it. Yeah, rest up
Oh, wow, I can actually level up for once because of how big my leveling up is
Uh, right strength is already 99 what would I put it in?
Endurance just to level up my stamina and equipment load I guess
Uh, I'm actually not sure apparently vigors
Max is 60 before it starts to like heavily nerf yet. Yes six extra
HP imagine if that would have made the difference though, you know
Go to the church and head towards the wonder visit
Endurance and vigour are both good picks at this point
And I'll just put it in endurance. Why not?
Cheeky bit of endurance here
Okay, go to the church and head towards the wonders physics. Oh, yes. I know exactly what you're talking about refund
I have I'm so smart in this game. What the fuck is it? Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Um this church
This church
Oh
Do you guys hear the M&M came up with a new song called Fubini so smart. I can't believe you're so good. I thought you knew
I've played this game once fully before and that was a year ago. Look a few things are not in my head
Go to the church. What church this church?
I'm going to this church. Yeah
Like almost a Monday
Okay, you know what happens I'll talk to him and he'll make me a physics
Hello, wait, weren't you? Yes, I was there but it's okay. You're back
Care to buy something. Yeah, I would love to. Can you sell me a physics?
Is that crackpot you want me to summon will lead you? Okay. Okay. Okay
Time to summon the reeflings to help me navigate this game because there's so much content
Kind of just crazy
I always see this animal name. I don't reckon. Oh, no. No. No. No. No
Okay, uh future
Morning, don't do too close the mad reefing. Why are you mad?
That's not good. The mad reefing. I'm not in a room on this piece of paper. The mad
Where we have started column a
So we have one column two column. We're now got three column and we've got a boss fight column. Um
Right, let's get pumpkin in as an adversary because I don't want to get in trouble
I see someone's saying here, but it's not let me get you
John dark souls from the hit tv game
John dark
Yes, we have we have a lot of names. I'll I'll take a picture and like sit like show after stream. I feel like
Holy base name it's john dark souls from the hit tv fortnite
Hey
Are you near? Oh, are you all are you covering to offer me something? Oh, you're giving me money you give me in game
Danny wait, can I bless you guys three at a time?
So once the mouse and well, you know what happens to the rest
Oh, no, I'm sorry. I'm sorry wrong button. It was left trigger. It was left trigger. Sorry. Please lie down again
I'm sorry. No, don't kill her. I'm sorry. Don't kill her
Okay, there we go that work
Everyone has been blessed
Right, where do we go the pumpkin nowhere go
Okay, I fall it's still tskr
Actually, it's tisker get your facts right
Red guy is the true main character
Next cover Houdini where mummy is a girl with black hair joining forces against black rock
Honestly
I already know what I want my alternative outfit to be
Which i'm not sure you guys are ready for
It's very it's very people cozy
But I already know what I want my alternative outfit to be
Um, however
Depending on the donor song
I actually don't mind if you guys want to vote on an all-out that you want to see me and it would come with like complete
um
I'd probably keep the shape of my hairstyle, but my shells can be exchanged for something of a theme
A rebel outfit a puppy girl. No, I can't be a pup tuber and be too h word all the time
I can't I can't be a puppy
I'd literally just go so silent every stream
Right, let's go. Let's welcome boys. Why don't do that?
Okay, I forgot I need to level up these a little bit, but that's okay. We can do that in the end
Did we just run past or we just perish on everyone?
What if it's what the masses well if you guys vote for it then I ain't gonna say no
I've got plenty of tails, but I can plug in with the uh be uh streaming out here
Um
Yeah, if you guys want, I ain't gonna
Uh, but I would like vote. Why are you just hating in the bushes?
Is that the boost to do that part?
Yeah, I'm very open to like an alternative costume that you guys pick just like, you know what you want to see
Wait, I need to hold this
Wait
So then what's that one?
Okay, and what's that?
Ah, right combination. Sorry
Sorry
Gamer girl outfit
I mean, I've not got it concepted. Uh, maybe only talk about it if I got a concept
But I'm definitely gonna stick to like my main
Like for a lot. I really like the yukata. I'm sorry if anyone
Uh, I'm sorry if anyone's like, you can't, that's weird. I'm like, plus
No, no, no. Niveichuber would be here without a little homage to Japan. So I think a yukata makes perfect sense
Um
but
Didn't like it I have to have a bikini only toggle if that's what you're wanting. I mean, yeah
Are you and all it uh, that's a very alternative outfit indeed
Wait, if you don't come near. Oh, no, they they always attack. I was gonna say he unsheathed his sword
I was like, oh, does he not attack if they, like, they hit you?
You can't, if it's a great though. Yeah, like, I just thought it was a really good thing.
I definitely gonna develop some of my concept art because there's a few...
There's a hidden design in one of the con... It's not hidden, but it looked really good
and I want to see it develop just slightly further.
I think it's very complementary to the hip-hop theme.
Um...
As well.
So I'd like to see that.
We are traversing limbry for this. This is getting pretty...
We adventuring.
I thought you couldn't draw. I can't.
We're getting... I get concept art.
Concept.
Just a hidden...
Again?
Worldwinds, wolves from the sky? I have to admit are probably the weirdest thing.
Wait, what? Is that an enemy?
Whoa.
Is that an NPC?
Oh my god, I thought that was a rifling dressed up.
I was like, oh, careful honey, you're hurting me.
Careful, darling, you didn't mean to swing on me.
Hypno from Pokemon Sun?
Okay.
Ooh, we're at a new place.
Is this where I'm supposed to be going?
Whoa, there's literally a growing granada.
Whoa, there's a rat!
Is that a rat? No, it's a dog.
That dog has main cheese with that bit right now.
Serious?
I got a short sword. I was supposed to have a long sword.
Oh jeez, you guys are glittering.
Fin beast.
Sorry, but you got two heads in.
I'm really sorry to say it's because a lot of people put a lot of effort into it,
but the clothes are almost useless for now.
Oh yeah, no, definitely.
I do agree with that sentiment as well.
You literally only get to see my face and my hair.
Pretty much like 100% of the time.
I went reeflings.
When v-tubers do just chanting streams and stuff,
and they show half their body there,
I'm like, yeah, no, that makes sense.
Isn't Alexander up there?
I know he's up a cliff to the right.
Up a cliff.
Did I just say what I think I said?
Sorry.
There's so many of you, it's got me overwhelmed.
Oh, I'm to come up here? Wait, let me clean.
Are you fighting a dragon or something?
Why are you fighting on the bridge?
If you think those doggos are bad,
you should have seen the Dark Souls one.
Wait, Pumpkin wants us to go up here?
Am I going crazy?
No.
Oh, Hypno from Pokemon Cosplay soon.
Sorry, I thought you were asking for a roleplay.
I was like, why would I roleplay a Pokemon?
Are you giving up Pumpkin now, Matt?
Do I really want to be a pumpkin?
I like my little tentacles.
I think that was on the head.
Alexander was up that cliff, I thought so.
Congrats if your name's Alex, by the way.
I just said your name.
God, Alexander the NPC.
It's kind of a trade-off between copper
and shrink and more in the game.
Nah, I'm teasing.
You're teasing, I'm but-
Oh, no.
These are the ones where you have to whack the bones.
I'm getting out of here.
I hate the ones where you're like,
there's one and done.
I think that's why, even though it's probably more
expensive, each of Models
and sitting and reclining poses look great.
Hmm.
We actually,
in development, I did entertain that
and I would,
like, have a, is it dynamic pose?
Each of us at one point.
But then I realized,
like,
the appeal is,
you know,
the girls are going to be streaming on YouTube.
And
depending on what they wanted to do,
I didn't know if there was going to be someone
who wanted to exclusively just do ASMR streams,
because I know some creators are like that.
And it was like
to get, like, to spend even more
on top of what the base price of the Models
is for, like, some sort of dynamic pose.
I definitely am open to the idea
of it, but, like, for me, for example,
I probably wouldn't use it
because I'm like, I'm a shit
VTuber in terms of, like, not using toggles,
not doing this, not doing that.
So I really would
only invest in, like,
an all-outfit, maybe.
Like, um,
Emmy's interested in, like, a straight-up
2.0, which is fine.
Um, but, like, for me,
I personally had it. Like, I really
like my model. Nari
made me so expressive as well,
like, seriously. I feel like
I'm not, like, stiff
or anything. I love how, like, I do
think, sorry, my hands are starting to sweat.
I need to wipe my hands on my hoodie.
Ta-da!
I'm a sweaty boy.
We're going to Radan next
to get
DLC stuff. Sorry, I'm doing one-handed.
I'm trying to hydrate because I didn't realize how much I'm sweating
and I'm getting a bit worried that I'm going to be
dehydrated. Well, what are you doing?
Oh, sorry, my trigger got caught
on the table.
Wipe your hands
on me.
Oh, you're pointing.
Oh, no!
Wait, huh?
Am I about to do a boss fight?
Why can't I progress?
No!
Boss fight, because the reeflings can't be with me!
Sugar.
Oh, no.
I don't want to use any stamina.
Oh, no, this can't be.
I've not leveled up my weapons or anything.
Or got more flasks. Or got more seeds.
I don't want to upset anyone.
Is it in here?
Where? Where are they?
Oh!
Come here, you bum.
Come here, you bum. Just because I've not got my reeflings
doesn't mean
I'm not going to fucking give you everything I got.
I'm out of stamina!
Both of us are fucking
stamina handy. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
hold on, hold on, hold on, let me get the...
Hold on, let me cheat. Hold on, let me cheat!
Hold on, let me cheat. Let me cheat.
I see that fucking thing.
I see it. Let me cheat right now.
GAN!
GAN and save me!
Unable to summon.
Oh, mother...
I need heal.
We are both Wacken,
but not staggering each other.
That's quite funny.
Speaking of staggers, take this.
Oh, I'm missing.
Hold on, hold on, hold on!
Thank you.
Don't ever come around these parts again.
Me and the Reeflings rule this neighborhood.
That make myself clear.
Woman.
Cookbook. Of course you got Cookbook flying around.
We've beaten them.
What is your name?
Well, in you come.
Jeez, what a name.
Is there anyone here who hasn't been in before?
I did grab you.
You look like an Edgelord McGee.
Okay.
And you come, Edgelord McGee.
See, that's what I shouldn't have named.
If I had a Scottish VTuber that I applied,
I'll name him McGee something.
Or something McGee, sorry.
Is there any invaders?
Anyone...
Interesting in invading?
I strongly say for you to get to the DLC station.
I hope you're ready for some hard bosses.
They have been wiping my ass.
Oh, yeah, no.
I have been doing very well.
If you don't know, I'm actually a very skilled Elden Ring player.
I'm actually really happy to announce
I did a speed run of it one time.
And I placed top 80.
It wasn't the best speed run,
but I'm actually pretty strong at the game.
And I actually do not use the Reeflings at all
in order to help me
progress the storyline.
Salad.
I've actually been kind of abusing you a bit, Salad.
I want strongy to invade my mind.
Okay.
Let me bless all three Reeflings
that once the Invader Summer comes in.
Oh my god, my notes are getting so scribbly.
I can't even like...
I'm trying to put tabs on
like who's been coming in on that.
But I have to admit, I've been fucking up really badly.
Okay.
All three Reeflings are ready.
It's...
I don't know what hole you're going to get.
It's going to be over before you know it.
That's all you need to know.
Okay.
Ready?
He went first.
Okay.
Let's go.
Yahoo.
We will now follow.
Wait, isn't there a dragon up here?
Whoa.
I didn't even see them.
I'm so blind.
Drawstring.
Lightning greets.
But not to be confused with grease and lightness.
Keyleth.
Any Keyleth enjoyers?
What?
Whoa, you look kind of scary.
You're not going to lie with your weapons.
Look at the freaking distance he has on his.
Jeez, I don't want to go in a fight against you.
Are you going to whip?
Is that a whip?
Wait, I need to whip.
I can whip you guys.
Sheevee sends her regards.
Basically.
Okay, we're going.
Following the Reeflings.
Reeflings are following the Reeflings.
So we complete the DLC.
It costs an extra $60.
$60.
But apparently it's really good.
The Reeflings are kind of splitting a bit.
Oh no, we're avoiding that little army there.
Who enjoys Keyleth?
Question 1.
More if you're feeling
especially daring.
Five?
I mean, if you want to get
technical
six
on a Waman.
For maximum
maximum
uh
Holy
I can't believe I'm saying that.
Yeah.
For max efficiency is six.
If you want to min max a woman
six.
Okay.
I'm just letting magic deal
with these dogs. They're terrifying, honestly.
They do look like T-Rex people.
I do have to give
off my hat to the game design.
Seriously, like all these different aspects.
This game development
must have been
very long.
Six. Yeah, but I feel a difference in quality
between the best and worst
through astronomical. What about pit?
It's not a hole though.
It would be nose
ears, mouse
babina
booty
and then
that's what
nose and ears
will take another
anything.
She
Oh, they blew up.
I thought it was one of you guys doing magic on
me.
Sorry, the reeflings like
leading me on this quest or something like
contemplating the uh
the true ultimate number
was a hole again.
Yeah, but the pits aren't
uh and it's like a
it doesn't have an end to it if you will.
I actually
thought when AC was actually
getting concepts with
I'm so sorry to bring this upon you.
Um
I actually thought about commissioning
the ear artwork for her
like of her
but I was like I don't want to do that
if that would make her uncomfortable because I didn't know at the time
like what the comfort level of the girls are
as far as I'm aware
everything fucking goes.
Everyone's like on the same page of like
if I don't like it, I just won't interact
so don't be surprised if I don't interact
type thing and then that's it.
Ear artwork
have you not
oh no
are we about to show a reefling
one of the most cursed things ever?
So there's this
really famous
Neco animation
and it's like a Neco girl
which has got Neco ears
and
how am I getting ashes of war?
I'm done it. Life steal fits
oh you can yank HP as you
fist someone that's my kind of doctor
your math ain't mathin
oh are you talking about ear smashing?
yeah
I think that's what it's called I guess
oh wait, mumbling
hold on, hold on I have to take my glycol
the ears aren't designed for that
no I know but I thought I would beat someone
to the chase and do it for icing
and if she found it funny she can post it
if she didn't she didn't have to
do the artwork
the concert artists of me and AC together
it's not like a major thing
it's just like AC is
but you guys just think it funny
I won't post it yet cause
I guess I need to ask her
although she's already seen it and she laughed at it
she found it funny
um
tell that to the R34
oh someone messaged
like a week back
and they were like congrats you guys have
the R34 tags and I'm like
oh my god poggers already
feels good man
I mean if it worked
in scary movie
okay we're gonna do this fight
and then
I'm gonna have to get some food in my tum tum
I got
natural
like I ordered them yesterday
so I can eat them today like a 5 head
so I didn't have to make any food
I assume it's this way
oh no we're splitting off
hold on a minute
we've got conflict of interest conflict of interest
what's going on
no
I'm not real
you can't see me
did I activate that dragon
oh you're taking me to the church
we activated the dragon
just a little bit
it's okay though
it's okay
everything is cool
we are going to get
ah he has a health bar
what does he do
I'll get my bone out of the way
it looks like I won't
do you fly
oh my god the solo
refling doesn't give a flying
who is the dragon
oh he's getting rotted out the wazoo
he takes 60%
it does manage to heal up
it's not a problem for him
the dragon already experiencing
roughly 8% max health
it's going down
the second refling coming in to help
I have no idea where invader refling is
are there punching
without punching sounds
oh other reflings
are out of bounds
oh no there is
now we do
oh whoa whoa whoa how am I getting hit
oh my god the plumage
this must be
a rot dragon
wait whoa
wait it has physics
the rocket actually goes up
I'm
surprised oh we are taking damage
PA
let's just call you PA
is taking damage
is he taking tick damage
PA is infected with raw
and taking tick damage
I hear punching
someone's punching a fricking dragon today
you're feeling very brave refling
you really are
the braps have a long range
we do have magic spells trying to be
were you coming for me
I'm not even fighting you
I didn't even do a lick of damage
and I got the points for it
thank you reflings
I got a dragon or
now we go
you're pointing to the church
nooo
the refling
had only a few moments and the last thing
he does is send me to the church
he sends me the right way in his very last moments
he said this one's for you
moment
I go to the church I'm at the church
good afternoon
congregation
and here we are
ready to
not rumble
is he easy
you can do it
it's just a night
okay
hey is he easy
oh no get that
fucking shield out of my way
oh thank god I don't have slow roll
you're standing the way of me and my reflings
don't do that again
okay let me rest
at this shrine
wow this place felt absolutely obliterated
why
why did I get so scared
I get so scared when I hear noise on the wall
okay I'm gonna rest
so I can restore everything
strongly struggling with NPC
like I'm not leveled up anything
okay don't be stingy
me knowing fill while I'm
shit at the game
oh wait what
oh wait
this is a refling
yeah
why are you so far away
is something wrong with this place
cause it's uneven terrain
I'm strange
they're unique where are we
the cathedral of dragons commune
okay let's just get in here
here we can
I guess I won't put a tally
cause you guys are just guiding me
where I need to go
I actually don't know the words
they're doing beatle just
I
I could
be very quiet
be very very quiet
refling
there's an enemy right over there
why is there no others
I said be quiet
no don't
wait where can I assign
a second refling
okay take me where we need to go
I'm so sorry to any refling
put their mark down there I think that's glitched cause
the area goes downwards on the map
we don't have to be quiet anymore
like a weeping
I'm not actually sure how to hit enemies
as a summon jola
enemy
I don't think it's a bad refling
I don't know why
there really isn't any mark that spawned in
it must be glitched we'll go to the next one
I have one refling to protect me
it'll be fine
wait where the heck did you guys go
jeez you guys remember this again
wow
look at that tree
oh it looks like a skull
do you see it
oh it must be a skull
that's not a coincidence
that's clearly been altered
okay follow the light
sorry follow the light I'm blinded to the bat
I'm sorry
oh no
oh no refling
do you need help
do you need assistance
I can kind of help it's not
oh shit you need help
oh I'm coming
I'm coming I promise
no no no
don't summon more
oh she's dead
oh
just a heads up for upgrades
while the guts sword is based
it's a pain to upgrade
it'll take 110 upgrade items
to reach max level
if you use a unique
somber weapon
it only takes 10 items
okay
I've not heard of that guts weapon
thank you Oregon for the 10
the guts weapon
I'm not holding the guts I'm holding
joe wheel like big old broadswords
or whatever you're called
okay let's
carefully navigate
don't go that way you're gonna aggro him
refling no you aggro
the horse man
wait did I need to go that way though
oh there's a seed of the tree
he's protecting the seed of the tree
oh shit
wait you don't aggro anything
man I wish I was you
whoa
oh my god
he just teleported wait we need to help him
gang violence gang violence
you are not hurting my refling
he doesn't belong to you
ouch
refling is a free man
and he can do it as he pleases
and it doesn't please him
and it doesn't please me
that you're hurting us
okay we did it
let me go get the seed
joe is not enemy aggro
because he's also an enemy aggro
poison
more flight
what curious thing
I got a golden oh second refling
can come in and you come
oh my god you're such a wait I've wrote your name before
I've wrote your name
nah I'll put a little tally mark to your name
cause you've been in for a section
what?
wait that doesn't make sense
cause I never gave the other one a second
wait hold on I'll take it away
can you connect
wait where's my other refling
enemy refling
hello
oh no
oh no this can't be
wait what
okay wait I'm taking that away
cause you never got to come in
what the heck
you just be a bot man
stop it game I just want to hang out with a refling
you're so silly
you're so selfish
wait everyone's failing to connect
okay that works
oh okay
okay okay we have a new one just a fella
please connect
question mark
nope
what do you prefer
oh no
I don't think you can connect
oh you can
right okay now we need an elevator
we need a naughty refling
and you come naughty refling
I'm so naughty
naughty
oh you bet
are you
whoa
he thinks he's a
what are they called a philosopher
he's not the thinker
map then Radan
oh the map's right there
it's to the left
oopsies
it's up there
a little bit more to the left
we need to go back a little bit okay
cause I'm gonna get the map of Kaleid
we might get attacked by those birds though
maybe if we
if we like stealth
that would be okay
I think we can do it
I sophisticated refling
you're so sophisticated
okay straight ahead
yay
okay and then we go back
okay
check it out
is that you refling
did you make that noise
oh hello
hello mister
I would like to
you're very straight forward
I would like to buy
cause you have anything of interest
gravity's advantage
note imparting knowledge and brief
how strange
I mean
I'll buy it I guess
cause we might need it for crafting something
but thank you
I would now
where do we go
back this way
the wind forgets me every time
I was like who goes there
identify yourself refling
oh sorry
I don't know
I don't know if you're like
self impaled on my
cookbooks or the
I'm like I'm crafted an item
this entire run so far
then again I haven't had to do
thank god
and I wouldn't have it any other way
but yes
there is delay
is doing doodles
question mark
and our membership is open
show your literal mother some love
that's right
she's your mommy
you crafted the things
that show you everyone's mark
I am a crafter
oh I'm so good
I'm so smart
throw money at Azura
I got it
I'm trying to help her move out
she's got a little bit work to do
with the audios
I can help her with the youtube audios
which means
everyone gets access
and then hopefully
she might be able to move out after one month
but I am going
to tell her to make sure you have like
triple
the rent
and your savings
because I don't want
any issues I don't know how renting in America works
but I've heard some weird horror stories
so I need to make sure
she's like stacked out the wazoo
so there is no problem
in that
she's so mummy
but you're mome
yes I'm mome
but she's your literal mum
I need to take this portal
I think this is the clearest indication
I need to take this particular portal
I believe I understand your communication
flap flap flap
yes
yeah depending on her credit
we might ask her about your portal
I don't know how
wait
I suppose
when I had to rent
because I said I was self employed
they were like
prove you have money and I'm like
okay
wait
yeah I don't have it
and so I have to like show them
like hey I make this much money
please let me have somewhere to live
that'd be great
wait you're not open
cannot be you
oh no
oh no this can't be
do we need to defeat more main bosses
I think
yeah it depends
wait she needs to get to
Altus
is that other way
is this Altus
like across
across the bridge
go to Altus Plateau
it's
oh my stomach
just farted internally
if you heard that
I've not taken the lift no
I've defeated two bosses and I'm getting
my hand carried
can you just walk in via the gate
Alice is about the huge lift
oh Alice is the lift
okay
hey strummy
oh my tummy
it's an internal digestion
right what did I do
the temple quarter
great
go back to Linaria
why is it
the four bell freeze
Linaria or like
the
someone's appeared to lead the way
internal fart
yeah when your stomach makes like internal
digestion you can hear like
the gasses on that river
you either have to start the round request lane which will activate it
or scale
to Altaville
lift or main
below the bell free
oh the round request
that must have been how I triggered it
I have no idea where I'm going
just let you guys leave me
am I to do running
or am I to do
whatever this is
I do not have the deck
as have
I do have a deck
five inches
take your leave up
the mains are faster
okay we'll do this then
oh really
let's go up to the back
yeah let's go to the back
oh no
any five
perfect
why is the game not spawning
in the middle of this thing
nothing crazy
I need to go up ahead
oh no sorry I just took a hot second
let me get off first
let me get off first right invader first
oh wait no I can't do invader first
because it can't deserve the other one
and you're too insane
fine
uh
I don't see one other
oh smart
no
and for am I going
why did you pass on me
I'm trying to be fair
and give everyone a chance to give you a birthday
I don't I honestly I feel like
you know you guys completely understand
like I'm trying my best
we play weekly games that you guys can always support
now I know people are like
runescape boring once runescape
finish we'll play different games
I
okay
is that my connection
it's taking so long
her back door
Alice we go yes
people haven't arrived to put down the marks yet
they were just putting them down at the other spot
oh when they thought I was runescape never ends
no someone said
statistically if I do two 12 hour
endurance streams I'll have 99
cookies
unable to summon
no
must be my connection
who didn't get in there was that
that was zero of sanity
my connection is wavering
it's not having a
let me check what it says
multiplayer group
multiplayer of settings
reef
there's nothing else to it
if no one can connect
there's definitely me having a moment
runescape grinding in the background
for tinfoil yuffin
could that be their server
yes actually before I start accusations
against Australian internet
it's very plausible their servers
are overriding right now
they're going ham
they're going full time because everyone's having to read each other
and all that
unable of god are the servers
down
you think the servers might be down for connecting
and I'm actually going to have to do something on my own
hello
oh no this can't be
oh no
can we even progress if I don't have the reeflings help in me
oh no okay
okay hold on hold on
don't get too ahead of yourself
alright let's get enemy reefling in
no enemy reefling doesn't work
hello
I had you
a wee bit
wait who's that
oh god the servers are fucking perishing
I can't even see an adversary now
oh wait no piss
I should have got you first
was that you don't do that again you scared me
enemy reefling
wait
please work
okay okay okay it's working
the servers are back
elden ring head quarters
elden ring
yeah elden
something on your own like bout through
shadow
okay take me
take me
take me reefling take me
show me where I have to go
whoa
damn right you're sorry
damn right
you're fucking sorry
the immediate kewerding
I'm so sorry
forgive me that's so funny
I have six class
what the fuck is that I gotta jump
okay the reefling is gonna take me where I need to go
you guys know where I go?
where are we heading
it looks like adversary reefling knows where I go
kill that rogue reefling
mods
incapacitate that cage that man
and I don't mean put well
how do you say it
I don't want to put you in a full cage
that's like big and tall
and all of you goes in it
you as in
oh you're
so thankful for my forgiveness
my reeflings dare betray me
how
I like the immediate kewerding stuff
kewerding
kewerding after
English parts
ooo the cavern
secret cavern
to reefling
technically I'm a reefling
cause I'm a fan of mine
I hate that word fan
not fan
not fan it doesn't make sense
how are this
you're a howard is
howard is
how are this
and I hate on this
oh it's wee lily
mecuelas lily
mods cage that man
that's exactly what I was trying to see
cage that reeflings technical
whoa you're the bug
a bug
a flag
someone killed something
and I got the flag
for it
the only betrayal we would do
is a reverse of the usual
and out of nowhere using the front door
yeah how dare you
I do like the idea of
the old bandage
I like those
underwear as well
that cover up that section
but don't have a section
for the back door
of the house
those underwear
are really good
one's a crusty bus station
something like that
there's a good mark of grace over here
hold on I'm going to grab it
everyone asks howardens
but never whyardens
oh so when the reefling
tapes it's funny but if I see it
out loud it's not funny
you guys have some attitude on you tonight
you know that
I'd like to perish
okay
okay let's go again
what are you doing
what are you doing to that tree
a bandage
yes
so there's this act
of
hooting
and an empty apple
and the apple like you take the guts out of the apple
and then you fill it with
this toffee
sticky toffee
like a candied apple
and then you put
the lid back on
or the lid could be a plaster
of the sticky apple
what
thunderbolts and lightning
very very frightening
oh wait these are the thunderbol
flowers
oh they attract thunder
thunder
sorry
I was probably terrible
I tried
oh my god the way
Brian said ponzu
bit of ponzu
thank you broly legend
a bit of ponzu
I mean I wonder if I could get away
with doing a donut thunder word with it
see
oh this thing's terrible
I don't mean a brag or anything
but
um
the cake is so big
that you actually
even if I were to
put on
those kind of underwear
you actually couldn't see anything
because the cake is so big
does that make sense
I think that makes sense
whimpering this way
bandaid
lingerie, lots of good options
the bandaid after
yeah
it's not a well guarded secret
what gave it away the clapping ASMR
oh yes
I will sit
are you telling me to sit
I will touch it
I think we need the evidence
is this where I'm like donut thunder
I know like people in a vtuber
shouldn't show flesh or what
vtuber having fun, everyone having fun
vtuber not having fun, no one having fun
my heart is beating so fast
I'm gonna pass it
maybe
dragon
is this poison source
that goes away
or
going away
infinite plumage
honestly
we need the evidence
oh you guys are comfortable with it
I'm uncomfortable with it
yeah it doesn't make sense
can you show us
well I wanted to do
a slow clap
like slow motion clapping
so people can comprehend
how I made that ASMR
did we just run past
I think we may have to run past, you know that
okay I'm just gonna run past, I'm brave
I'm so brave I'm running fast
I might need to sleep but I need to
do more, oh you need to be careful though
neutralizing
bulbouses
did you just give me your bulbouses
okay we're just gonna run past
holy crap look how many there is
that's so much
actually speaking of dolls
because Ranny's a doll
you know how I cannae get away from like
creepy doll vtuber's and that
you know why I also like them
do you know what the appeal could be
the appeal could be
free use
like in theory they could be inactive
in like a plot
I don't know how to
like in my head I've not thought it out it just came on my mind right now
but like you can like play with your doll type thing
like free use
like that's another thing
anyway that's just me
I got it I got it
wow we need to keep moving this forza
everywhere they're taking over
they gave you a poison cure
oh in case you get poisoned
show gimley
what about Vigo
you don't like the appeal of Vigo
baby boy is a
he's been a very
interesting boy
recently
so when my hair
is wet
he goes crazy
pushing into my head
and it's really sore
oh I got barbaric roar
my flanks
Vigo is quiet he is a quiet boy
he's not very gimley
I don't know if it's because he's part munchkin
like I don't know how healthy munchkin cats are
I should actually probably do my research a bit more
he seems to be
are we oh yeah you flake
I was here 10
hours ago you're so slow
slow folks yeah yeah
um
I think the tag is something
emotionless yes yes
that could also be another angle of adult
each of her
oh can you not progress
oh no none of us
can progress
oh no this can't be
this can't be my refunds
have to no we can't go in
I can't go in we can't progress
the helmet has jiggle
jiggle jiggle jiggle
yeah thankfully
he's a half breed munchkin
I'm very happy to say that
so he's not a full munchkin at all
he has tabby gene tabby cat gene
domination which I'm very freaking happy
about
his legs are just slightly smaller
but he looks healthy
I don't know if he just seems more tired
and
you flake
I have to
I have to go on my own
but it's okay
what they don't know
this is now a stealth mission
when I can't call you in
okay it's a stealth mission
we do not want to get caught
we do not want to enter any unnecessary
fight
we just need the mark of grave
oh my god no
I just had a memory
this room has jumpscare gargoyles
oh my god my memory just saved me
I can see them now
did I just run for the grace
is it in there
I'm not getting stuck
yes
fucking arsehole
what is that
poison
I fucking had that
I knew it I knew you were there
I remembered
uh
right
I'm gonna be honest
oh thank you recently
giving me the poison buildup
ah
these are a very limited item
video game don't ever do that again
are you freaking serious
oh
jeez louise stop it
jeez you things are so great
this is scary leave me alone
right the mark of grace must be up here right
hmm
yeah
I will admit they are cute
objectively
they have horrific health issues
any cat that has
folded ears has
terrible joint issues
oh god I hear something
oh
I am brave I am brave I am so brave
I am so brave I am so brave I am brave
oh
I am so brave I am so brave
oh reeflings
oh thank fucking god
I hate every second to that
really
please come in
please come in anyone come in
it doesn't matter who just come in please
don't make me do that again that was awful
ugh
I literally had to go
silent I was like there's too many enemies
I do not have the strength to kill them all
cause my weapons are too low I am running
I am just running I don't know where to go
ugh have we got an enemy reefling up here
ugh
you're welcome
uh
I don't have an enemy
got a lot of enemies
we are at a place called the rune stream
rune stream it rains
rune stream rune stream rune stream
I don't think
why are you
geopnik
per dollar
previous
I lost
I don't
okay enemy reefling coming in
oh my god I just shook in my life
I don't know if I will fucking bump it
make if I did I am so sorry I got such a fright
the fin
are we ready
you have so many poles
do we go up here
I don't want to go back in that cavern
I am going to be honest I don't actually want to go back in there
for knowledge you guys
I forgot to sit down
that guy was chasing me the entire time
they have very big aggro
like they
whenever I play my old games I like them
cause I can always be like
oh har har
you're not cool
over there
I am like oh har har you're not coded to be over here
this game is like no they will hunt
you down
they are like you are mine
what is going on
oh wait don't I have a few runes on my
persons
I wouldn't call for you
wait so the reeflings have now split up
one is going down the other is going up
is this a safe station
hey we are down here
I am sorry walkway
I am so sorry other reefling that went up
the
where are we
oh you are a smithing stone
that's fantastic how do you guys even remember
I am so patient
you see that I almost perished off the side of the map
cause I am a dum dum
yeah tether games are so nice
literally I always get so cocky
cause I am like ha ha ha ha ha
you can't get me
you just gave reeflings
so many heart attacks I am so sorry
if it makes you feel any better
I had a heart attack
we got smithing stone level 4
it is clean
BRB have to clean the litter
and feed the kitty
at fed
people
and weakens
when I made my cup of tea I gave them a wee licky lick
cause they are we precious
adorable things
oh there is another one
ooh a smithing stone
ooh another one
holy crap
I am killing it with the magic
and by killing it I mean
absolutely why am I taking poison damage
huh
those bats do poison damage
how strange
I would not have put them for that
it's called having over 500 arrows in the game
at the point you just know where everything is
aww I am glad you can find a game
that you enjoy so much like that
I am kind of like that with Isaac
but I have to admit
Beltro stole my heart yesterday
I am
careful careful
I am very interested to play Beltro again
it won't be until July
my dad
he told me what
when he is coming over and when he is going
it is actually a lot longer
it is like just shy of me
behold precious item
oh you are right sorry
you are singing sorry I am going to distract you by the singing
I am actually open to Zura
I might entertain some more song covers
her voice is very unique
it sounds bloody good
obviously I made everyone do a meme song
but I would like to see her try
something of a different category
that I really need
yeah
she definitely has a thing for it
I think she just
I don't know what I should ask her to sing
is my only question
I am not sure she knows
either because she is new to it
as far as I am aware she didn't do song covers
or anything like that
that first song is boobs in the thumbnail
was her first ever song cover
I am just trying to think what kind of songs
would either get popular
like Emmie
has been
I am so sorry
Radio Refling
Emmie has been really receptive
I wanted to try a few things with her
as far as I am aware
the other
Mercy might want to do a song cover
again
I am doing that
we are going to do a little meme
I am going to ask them
hey what do you want to do
oh no
I think I am going to have to start upgrading my weapons
I am going to be honest
oh no
this is a dragon
I thought it was going to be the crystal guys
because we were just in a mine
I don't know if this is going to be easy
or hard
Joel clapping with no heart
seriously
I am going to ask them
what do you want to achieve
what do you want to do
a song cover project
let me know
am I supposed to attack
I don't know if I am supposed to attack
I missed
oh wait that lava flamin
just him
he said we were me boy
you know it is lagging
you are aware
I am helping I am helping
see I did it I killed them all by myself
oh I got an achievement for that
I didn't even do anything
and I got an achievement
are you whimpering on your way out
oh no that has to be on my own again
because we just
alright I can just call you the back end again
like immediately
it will be easier compared to mine
Joel clapping
wait it is active right now
wait hold on let me sit down
hold
or is this considered an enemy
like
I can't call you in right now
I mean you can only try
no it is still active
can't come here
I am brave
I am so brave I can do it
oh wait actually it is just an elevator
yeah I think I can do it
go up and get a grease
you don't have to tell me twice
compared to Mog
actually most of the bosses
are pretty easy
that is what I like to hear
the full princess carry
I need to get artwork of us for this stream
I will get someone
to like lift us up
no like lift me up
so there is two good reflins and one invader
and you guys are literally carrying me
and I am just like yay
and I am like happy
and I have got like a little weird
radical helmet on and so
I think that would be cute
ok we made it to the plateau
a dozen reflins
well there is more than a dozen of you joking
you should see how many names
I have written down
go up here
I don't quite remember
this area so well
funk
rest at the grace
I would like to
have a sleep until night time please
talk to Melina
hey my arena
hydration check
it takes me back
I was born
at the foot of the earth tree
where mother gave me my purpose
though now
everything is lost to me
I
have to ascertain for myself
the reason for which I live
burned
and bodyless
are you good
shall I turn your rooms to
strength
rest upon you
for but a moment
share them with me
thank you darlin
bye bye
can we have a mod
where there is stroney
inside of her
what did he say
can we have a modification of the game
where there is stroney
dead instead
you only read what you want to read
holy crap I am so sorry
am I to go somewhere
I am so sorry
you only read what you want to read
I am so sorry I didn't mean that
talk to Malayla
now you can take the portal
so go all the way back
and we will take this portal here
right here
but also on sale
Freudian slip on ironically
that is a classic
case of Freudian slip
I can summon you guys on the other side
of the state right
instead of running and stroney
oh we are in the castle
okay
you can save
I see a grace
I am lagging it
it's in a house
it's in a wall in a castle
okay I made it
oh there is no enemy
oh
maybe in a weirdo creeping around
and there is not even any enemies
reading
we got one each
you got a tag
oh wait isn't this dialogue
oh my god we are singing healer reach
oh
you shouldn't summon
oh my god it's bleed that's
the boyfriend of
Rani
allow me to introduce myself
life
warrior
I am a warrior too
okay
oh hello
not very talkative are you
oh well
the festival
is nigh
general radon
mightiest demigod
of the shattering awaits you
champions
prepare
for battle
defeat the general
gain glory
and grab that great rune
a celebration
of war
the radon
festival
hi alexander
ah
if it isn't a tarnished warrior
I am the warrior jar
I am fist alexander
did you get out yourself
hi alexander
do you know for whom this festival is being held
nah I'm too dumb
it is none other
oh wait he was a good warrior
but within the rock
he got to him and now we need to put him down
and
he's so heavy
he uses anti-gravitable magic
so his pure horse
can be ridden
who also has wrought
and probably needs to be put out of its misery
and all on it
he fell to the root his way
hereby vow to unflinchingly
brave this ordeal
ok
someone says talk to the jester
is he the jester this guy up here
good wee horse honestly
oh right he definitely is the jester
kill jester
are you good and prepared young chum
the festival
begins
ready as Oliver be
is wee horse
is called lennard
oh lennard is such a horse
I'm so sorry to anyone listening
that's called lennard
ok we ready
oh that furry thing
oh
general redan is cursed
ever to wonder
from the inside
by malinius scarlet
wrought his wits are long gone
now he gathers the corpses
of four friends and foes of light
be gorging on them
like a dog
we are the horse in stronius redan
you raided me
wait
you did that the other way around
I'm so sorry
I did it the wrong way around
I don't know what is going into me
today honestly
heartening cry
hello
you will find the field of battle
past the church ahead
general redan is divested of his wits
and howling at the sky
howl
ok if I remember correctly
I can always call you guys in the
battlefield off the head
and there isn't
a save
break
I don't want to break any fern
at your
oh got a level 6
what's this
is this the random door
an internal far
wait I can get you guys down here
I'm by the poor elders mistake
you are going to get NPC summons
no no no my wiflings are too
whoa I didn't realize I had a little beak
oh my god I have a little beak
I mean this is actually very laura
oh there you guys are
nice wifling
ok I'll put it under boss fight
category
for anyone that calling
just in case we have a bit of a hard time
I don't know how
no are you not being a nice wifling
picture you have
whoa there's a few wiflings
I see
your name is
censor I don't know what your name is
but the game didn't like it
ok have your names under the boss fight
I don't know
if I can engage or if I'm just going to
get koblamo'd I do need to upgrade
my wee weapons
they're both not upgraded
at all I actually can't read
where it says like if it's upgraded or not
I do need to upgrade them
they censored
oh you have ass in your name
ok anyone
ok
right are we ready
are we steady
I'm fucking up
praying that you guys
can clutch up
do you have
or need to upgrade Matt
I need the stones to do it
oh my god no
I can't just sit in combat
dang
ow
does that hurt
why are you looked on to me
there's other wiflings
are literally so much closer
you're so stinky
get rolling
literally
far too early sorry
he looked on to you because he saw me
ok
right
seems to have
we don't have access to force
oh my god sniffling just took
fucking 40 damage remember your debuff
when you join please don't get too coffee
your debuff
we do have a magic wifling
it looks like a melee wifling working in tangent
although the arrow swapped to the magic wifling
we are rolling in to get killed
we are getting some tick damage again
we're doing something
something's happening
sniffling is down to less than
10% health can he heal
he can heal
magic wifling
is going for it as best as he can
oh there we are down to 50% health
on our
darling redan
one wifling is down
I repeat one where the fuck
did he go
where is he
oh
I'm traveling at the speed
of light I'm gonna make
a supersonic man out of you
don't saw me
hey hey hey these are mpcs
wait can I
can I get mpcs
with a real wifling
or will I just let that wifling
go for it time to summon an mpc
right blade
I wasn't paying attention I'm sorry
I wasn't paying attention
why are you going for me
why are you being so mean
you're just a mean mean boss
ow
hold on I need to heal and keep
getting away from you
oh shit I'm at heals
if blades and that
if blade and wifling can do it together
possibly
I need to be on standby to summon
all these other
I'm not paying attention
I'm out of heals
this is the worst this couldn't get any worse
I'm just running
I'm just running it's not my problem
I'm just running this blade already down
sure and you come
what about you do you want to come in as well
come come come come
everyone come in oh it's a reunion
yay reunion
everyone in
why did I get casual greeting
oh you can summon them all at once
okay
they're going
I see them making their way
there's five players on the battlefield
surely he is not going to
randomly target me
surely
surely not targeting me
the one with no heals
I don't know why he randomly
targeted me
oh it's a summon
killer
everyone else playing an action
oh that was such a hard fight
I'm so glad I managed to clutch that up
I got a bit nerve wracking
there I got a bit nerve wracking
but I managed to clutch up and get the last hit
and thank goodness
ain't it just swell
oh life is good
we changed something in the stars anyway
by doing that
is that Rani doing that
I don't remember them
he was holding
all the stars in place
at a sheer force of will
he was holding the stars in place
so now that he's dead the stars can move
oh he like paused
this fucking planetary stuff
a red mark was made on your map
oh
bright way rgb story
you can now do the dlc
where do I go for the dlc
I don't actually know where to go for it
you guys are teaching me all right now
yeah he stopped the universe apparently
but couldn't get a bunch of rounds
back to
Mog
where was Mog
new hand touches the beacon
where's the wee telepore
is it back over here
where's the fucking log
yeah it's like back this way
so underground on the map
I need to get out of this area
because it's not like
the telepore out
I don't know
the wee telepore thing here
right
the telepore thing I thought it was right there
it is right here
huh
am I going crazy
they didn't just say I can't
can't travel to a great site
can I get that
get the grace here
oops sorry
he's
blamed like a diamond
because we didn't have eyes
is that all there
hey tauren
if you see anything sparkle
and that isn't from the sky
tell me okay
cause
ah
yay
oh hi bleach
how's it going you got something to tell me
did you like the fight
huh
what a sick way to fight
a mate the glory of the class is shared
by radhan
and you
and then a falling star
right before her eyes
I can't fathom how radhan was holding back
something of that scale
if ever I saw one
he has admiration in his voice
for radhan
what's that
hello
return to the end
oh there's like a fathom
okay and then now
we can telepore
underneath the map
to the cocoon
sure
is he a furry
no he got more
oh hello um
oh I'm full health
hi
oh
oh do you see
ah this is so cool
well
just need to touch
it touch withered arm
okay to the realm of shadow
weapon leveling
should I level up before
I assume you can weapon level
I don't know would I need a generic
something
uh
oh wait no the round table
round table
sorry don't make a mark
how am I making mark
let me let me uh yeah
I should get as many
tier or just pay attention to that
what I said each
that's um do you have too much dialogue
to players they'll just skip over
oh there you are
you again yeah
we did
yeah
and
an arsenal charm
what do you do
raises maximum equipment while that
makes perfect
go fast roll still
there's getting ready to be mean to me
upgrade your weapons and fluff
normal smithing stones are 1 to 8
you need 12 for each
pair of weapons
yeah
okay
uh
strengthen
sword
no
do I level them up equally
or just try and do one big
just focus on one at a time
okay
okay additional items required
I need smithing stones here
uh I don't know who
does any of that
uh
right
someone said focus on getting
seeds
um
if we want to get seeds
I'm gonna pretend
I don't know where to go
there is a main
and
maybe we went to that main
oh fuck it let's just go into the dlc
if we get rolled
we can always come back and like genuinely
get stuff
I assume we can come back
the dlc isn't like a weird instance
like you can never return to this area
again type thing surely
surely that's how it works
yeah you can come back up there
let's go let's see what happens
touch head to the realm of shadows
oh
grave site clean
the tree is dripping madness
well well well reeflands
well well well indeed
just
okay far we've gotten already
okay we get invader in
does that count invaders
I don't know if I should have done that
here we go
uh
where did the other creeps
the game is so buggy
gorgeous view incoming
look what have we even got a man
I don't know if you can go on that man
but still looks good
the tree looks good
good
oh there's like a few kind of temple
things over there
hi
oh no
because I did the invader
it got rid of the freaking things
I don't know why the game does all this stuff
are you praying
you want to
oh your butt cheeks are heavy madame
would you like us to hold them
yes you may
sorry
for that
wait why is it
wait why is there another second weeping
coming in
I think it's like bugging out
yes don't use a gorgeous movie
oh shit
he's still buff
I think it may
I'm not sure
but
we certainly seem to be having summoning issues
it's all we can do
is it worth jewel wielding them by the way
I don't know
is it
wow
I mean I wouldn't want to
be in the wrath of me
do something like that
with 99 strength
yeah just spam attack
you need a second here
okay
what it's hardly showing up
refling tescaru
oh you can be here
oh no
I might done that wrong
wow
I'm so sorry if I forget the order you guys come in
I think refling tescaru
can I bar it
everybody let's get
to it to it let's get this
40 started
let's get this
oh you look like what you have on head
what you have on face
you are a bear
oh my god it's an ac still
okay
thank you hello right shall we do it
where do we go
do you guys know where to go or are we all
like none of us played the dlc at all
I don't know
okay we can do it
we'll do a bit of exploring and then
I'm gonna get some proper food on my tummy
and I'll take a little 5 minute
chatting in the
we break
I can do that thing it
new enemies
new enemies I'm not familiar with
oh my god did they take a hammer
and wow look at his design
I almost look
deer like when he's like straight ahead
you know that
holy shit we're getting ghouls
careful invader refling
well these
enemies aren't kidding around
holy crap
I'm sorry refling
do you know where to go
are we all just guessing here
oh there's the map
oh there's like an actual town
you never see that
wow
imagine if we had a refling village
shit
what would we do in a refling village
we'd have a tavern
go this way
hello mister
are you okay
everyone burnt a cinders
burned away
put to the touch
put to the torch by mesmer and his lot
what did we do to deserve such a fate
we merely lived our lives
we lived in peace
oh no this whole place burned
are these enemies
oh they are
what did they do
did they just fight
why are you aggressive
don't be aggressive
fun fact a big theme in this DLC
is rebirth and that
and that enemy you killed and it's perfect
some weapon when you view it from the front
looks like it's the structure of a woman
oh
I love a bit of fanny
inspiration as well
not bad
I'm sorry I don't know why
I thought that was going to be funnier
if I said that out loud but that wasn't funny
that was just weird
I'm sorry I delivered that really bizarrely
it was supposed to be a joke
but I think my voice was a bit
too monotone to explain
that I was joking during that
I'm sorry
that was good
where do we
no one knows where it goes
something's supposed to happen
if we're all literally exploring
oh no you're going over here
right we have a torch
that means you actually know where you're going
we'll do that
I'm fricking too short
I'm too small I can't reach
wow
like robes
can I climb the robes
kind of
I'm not going the wrong way
I'm getting distracted
I've just never been here before
okay follow the rea
follow the torch if you have a torch
I know it means you know where to go
if none of us have a torch
then it means we're just sending it
okay
I vote for the clueless squid to leave
well the first time I played this game
I ended up wandering in a kaolin
it felt like part of the section
you're fricking mad
time
I got not resist
okay a little bit of parkour in the town
don't mind
I love what you've done with this place
honestly none of you has told me you were stone masons
but look at this architecture
I mean look at the
love and the detail that's been put into this
what's happening
you guys really don't give yourself enough credit
for how much you do
I mean look at all the detail
the words
go inside
say no more open human
that not raisin is made my bad
ooh item
what is inside the treasure chest
a blade of mercy
I didn't realize she was in the video game
let's just check it out just because we can
it's an all weapon
am I going crazy
I saw that you're a fricking
pulp behind me wait am I going crazy
is it not like an actual weapon
I just wanted to check it out
oh it's a talisman my pardon
raises attack power
after each critical hit
but it would put me on heavy load
I need this talisman
what are you jump attack
I do be jumping a lot
a critical hit
I don't really hit criticals
do I
I'll just leave the things we are
I do a lot of jump attack
oh my god
mercy as in mercy my dear
from violers gen 1 indulge
okay I now have talisman
you will follow them
did you make me stagger there
I think you staggered me
oh no
okay I'm running and jumping
I don't trust myself
another replay
wait down
I'm looking at you
I've got red flesh mushroom
if you have the torch
you're leading the way
because I don't know where the heck I'm going
mercy's whole thing is
bleak
if she was karam
you know actually
because of her name change
her custom
toggle
her unique thing
like she can put her hands on her face
oh look at that
I don't want to go against it
but look at it though
oh my god
hope it doesn't have a big aoe
excuse me mr. sheep
face it
no I'm just scared
oh my
okay
we're learning the new enemies
we're getting familiar
got a lot of enemies
I might need to drop a loaf of bread
I'm not joking
my tummy
I should have started stealing
a bit of loaf of bread
I'm feeling heavy
it's up to being killed by the witch
the thing is all aoe
honestly
oh these are where the wiggly worms are
that's on the menu
okay
bite it anyway
even if it's friendly
nothing is friendly in this game
are you praying to the wiggly worm
oh wiggly worm
oh my god look at it
oh no
it's face
oh
it was going so well
for your design
that's unfortunate
that face is unfortunate
the cuteness factor
may not have gone down after that
aoe
a little thingy
sorry I'm getting distracted
looks like a fight would occur here
yep there's definitely a fight
because look at this
statues and stuff
well
oh we're getting blessed up
okay
it's a fight in the DLC
our first proper fight
let's see what happens
it's a crypt
we've done crypts before
it's just a knight
I'm pretty sure crossbow bolts
are only supposed to have one
thing on them
oh my god for a knight
he is so quick
he
I don't even get stuck
oh my god
did you see that
I need to
no no no
no don't do it
fuck you
I can kill him on reekland
and you get out of the way
sorry I'm out of stamina
I'm trying to manage my stamina
but I'm not that smart
stop it
oh my god
I'm out of stamina again
sorry
no leave him alone
ah
he is so much health strong
I only upgraded them a little bit
I think we might have to upgrade them
how about I let you guys finish him
off and then I'll go drop a loaf of bread
and get some snacks
does that sound like a plan?
I'll let the reekland finish him
off and then I'll go drop a loaf of bread
ok
surely this is gonna work
surely
I don't even know if I need to put you guys under boss fights
wait who we got
I could hear that
I knew I heard that
boss fights don't count
uh
what are you are you melee
you're big melee
I don't know
hmm
the gear diff is pretty hard the DLC is not
on top of the fact your weapons need upgrades
there's even more upgrade nonsense which is
unique to this DLC alone
oh see another one
in come in come
boss fighters in come
I will be holding back
because I am
shy so
as much as this outfit is absolutely
stunning and I actually have to put on some armor
don't worry mommy
take some sleep
hmm
ok not to
not to make the situation
critical or anything
if we fail this one I still
might have to go drop a loaf of bread
I'm not saying the situation is critical
but it's not good right now it's not good
it's not good
King Kong's fingers pushing ok
right let's go let's go let's get this
done
oh my my my
I'm just gonna hide in the corner
and he can shoot at me
ok come on refling
we got two melee he has so much
like
oh ok ok we have a crit
we have a crit fantastic
oh we have like sword art
blood dancing
sword blood dancing
but magic being cast
sometimes missing
it's not possible to always hit the
avocado
abracadabra
oh no one refling might be down
possibly the aggro swaps
the refling can heal up the aggro was
swapped
successfully
we are down to
just shy of 50% boss health
does this boss have a face to it
unlikely due to the fact
he's in a crypt
I might have to do it
I think I might need to help
oh my god he's still low
wait
what's going on
wait he healed up
only we're allowed to heal up
you don't know the rules around these parts
stinky
smelly
and you don't have a tongue scraper
ok
I'm gonna go take a cheeky fat loa for bread
we will be back
and we will defeat this boss
I have faith in the refling so I know you guys can do it
I did
sorry
I will be back in a couple of minutes
give me a few minutes and then I'll
heat up my food and then we'll do a little
eating whilst the refling
absolutely wallop this man's
booty hole for me
yes I'm dropping every toothbrush has a tongue
scraper on the back side
not electrical
toothbrushes
I'm gonna crouch surely I'm not gonna be in
trouble if I just afk
right I'll be back in a couple of minutes
you do need to give me a few seconds ok
you know cook your little guts
oh wait actually I need to drink water
ok the water has been drank
my guts
if they do not produce this little
little loa for bread
I've been baking for three days
I think it's been three days
imagine the smell
no refling don't
right I'll be back in a few minutes
get some snacks get some water
make sure you stretch ok
can we see your start screen
you actually want to see it
I never use it hold on
here this is what my start screen looks like
see
it's my background music
that's what I could be showing
oh my god the stinger
no the stinger isn't even on this pc
it's on the other pc which is even funnier
see chat room
it's real it is right I'm gonna go drop a
absolute stink in third
this heart I'm cramping right now
holding this in right
BRB reflings get some food stand up
what are you know the drill
no
I just want to fucking say after this stream I'm giving myself the biggest fucking animal
All he did was far and nothing happened. We will heat up my food
You
Are you squid me right now bread for the bread that just keeps cooking
Are you squid me right now?
Reflings, we gave strongly the wrong kind of bun in the oven. Thank you anon for the tip honestly. I'm no well
It's literally been like I've been so frickin
Stressed I can't even poop properly man, and like the only time I don't feel stressed
It's when I when I play with you guys like when when I get to stream I
Get to have fun and I get to get addicted to about true. No stress. No nothing. No, there's no problems
I get I get carried to the game the problems
and then
Frickin
Fogged up a swine. Oh
That's an awful. I think anyone was like that one
Okay, we have our two chosen champions
I think I've accepted that I literally cannot do anything against this boss
So you guys are gonna have to we have dual wields bleed. I believe and we have
Arcane of some sort. Oh, I never do the blessing. No wonder you guys can do it last time
You do the blessing you ready and I'm blessing to
You don't want to bless him. Ah, you want the bliss
Oh, I miss sorry. I went a little to the left. Hold on a little to the left. Oh, I'm so not done right there
We go blessed you have been blessed
There is no better blessing
Let's go right you ready a smart talking to your girlfriend for a difficult
Honestly, that would be funny if it wasn't
I might be
I'm just
Okay, I'm a couch in the corner and get my natures. That's bad
Whoa, you literally just tanked for me by accident
How I think we need to go back. I'm sorry. I think we need to go back and I need it like sacred flasks and tears at churches and stuff
I
Refling almost perish. He didn't even get close to the boss
Also, I mean it's the night's logical step that repeal or a very nobie
Now the refunds goddess, are you sure if the refunds are if the refunds have confidence
I will happily let you take a quite a few tallywax
I'm much way
I
Not be manure. Oh, no, don't cuz I
Brain that the enemy doesn't randomly target me because my hand is not in the bag
Oh
Oh, oh no, oh
No, this can't be. Oh, no, this can't be. Oh wait, I need to try and grab muscles. Hold on
Don't mean to be
Just doing nothing
Psych I shouldn't have done that me so he actually takes a lot of sacrifice, you know that
Now I want to eat my naturals leave me alone
Oh, you want some of this oh shit, I completely miss a whole heart
I
Got a bit confident. I thought mine was a bit longer than the average. No
I am gonna let you cook and see what happens. Wait, he heals
Wait, what does he heal when he does that unique attack? Oh
No
Yeah
I'm gonna let you guys have a big tallywack arm because it gives me an excuse to eat and commentate
I got my yummy food. I've got water
Also have a new fizzy juice to try it's sparkling blood orange juice
I'm gonna I'm trying to make an effort to eat a bit healthier because I've not been very healthy recently
No, no, only come. I'm not even I'm not even censoring it this time. No doom
No doom
I'll come. Thank you
Your summoning pools function, so does that do it for free?
I
Doesn't do it for free. I still have to use the talismans
Okay, curious, I thought
No, there we go. Um, this doesn't count
This doesn't count like as like a
Journey in with me
That work it did work. Why is only
Okay, I'm gonna try my fizzy juice I can open it because my nails are so freaking long
Okay, and then our next smooth operator
You
Are you role-playing through the creation menu on Elton ring?
Running at a beefling. Oh, that's not that bad
Do I like it
Can't believe it has me addicted to the syrupy thing
What we've got we've got Rohan dual wield. Oh, no, we're gone. We're gone to a singular two-handed
Got you addicted to I am very welcome my ship burns the burns good
Sorry, I'm not trying to eat too lovely. Okay, ready
We hate cola for that. Thank you cola for the contributions to the cake on Islam. I'm a head someone was like
How do you get that build and I'm like
I
Would commentate but I'm just stuffing my face like a fake
What do you mean not eaten for what seven hours
I'm friendly and letting the reeflings do the fight for me
Oh
Sorry
So he has a flash that heals about
Let me go to this corner. I'm trying to do that one. I can't eat and like think at the same time. Oh, I'm yeah
Oh, no one leafling zone this guy has a heavy hitter
Oh
You're not
My dead body's gonna be
Oh
We're fucking dog pale enough
Hold on I'm out of stamina hold on any heel if I was domino
Okay, wait is it even for you
Fuck a mom
Oh, shit. I'm hitting the wall. Sorry. I'm hitting the wall. Oh my god. I'm already hit the wall. I can't believe it
I'm only walk three week old
Oh sugar, I just took damage for that. Oh my god. I'm out of heels. Oh
Oh, no, I'm overzealous in my actions. Uh
Refling you might have to take this away. Refling you might have to do the rest
Unless I go for it. Fuck you
Okay, we did a bit of damage. We did a bit of damage. Okay. I've taken aggro. This is terrible. I yee. Oh, how did I dodge that?
How did I dodge that? I don't know
Uh, I wasn't really wanting to take aggro
But I'll take it
Oh, this is for refling. If I can take some of the aggro
Oh
Oh, he's so close. Fucking gangfiles. Yes
I mean, thanks. You did it. You did amazing. Thank you so much. You did it. We did it. We did it
See if I wasn't a pussy. Whoo great sort of solitude not to be confused with
Oh, wait, should I take all of this and put it on?
Should I put all that stuff on?
What was it? Is it like way better? Oh, no, this can't be. It's like way better
Oh
It's too heavy. I have an amulet
I have an amulet that like
Oh, no, I'm a heavy ruler
Take off one of the great swords
No, no, I'm still a heavy boy
Uh
I mean in the nicest way when I have you guys to help me doesn't matter if I'm heavy
What level is your crimson class? Uh zero
The heavy rule kind of epic though
If I have the reforms to protect me, ooh, what do you use? It's a crypt
First off. Well done. By the way, praise the message
Fine. I'll praise it. Are you applaud? Yeah, fine
Wait, it's good. Sure
Heavy mummy the big cake roll. Yeah, we're in big cake territory
The rule is important for you to dodge that. Oh, no, you're kind of spitting the truth. They're not going
Oh, everything's such a downgrade on defense like I know why it's a downgrade on defense
Right if we start tell you what if we struggle
Um one adversary. Oh wait, I'm an idiot. Sorry adversary takes a week
Um and you come
Um
And then
Have you explored with me?
You I know you've explored with me, but I don't think you got a chance to explore with me
I do
Only a downgrade if you get hit five heads five heads, right? I should actually eat and get distracted
Yeah
Wow, yummy
I don't know who's gonna come in
Look outside
He didn't work
What do you mean the servers are overloaded because they just they're loaded they just they're not uh, they just
Publish removed
Hmm
You're praising them
Personal as to just trying that guy's sorry. Oh, you may change the story
Oh
You
Don't be like by my dumpy
I couldn't do that
I don't go down
You'll go down and I do it. I do the animation
Oh shit, sorry. Oh, let's forget that
I may be easier for me to upgrade this new item
Um
Oh, no, it's actually better. Oh no, this can't be
Oh as a faster swing, I think or am I just making the off
I might have a faster swing
Okay, I follow you guys whilst I munch, okay? There's so many beans in one section
Easier to upgrade at this stage, yes
Now that I'm doing oh, sorry, sorry
Oh, no, I didn't get my class back
Oh, I've got our class back
Oh
It's hard to eat
It's yummy food, so I hope you guys have eaten and hydrated
Is
Oh, you can't use it, okay
I'll go in a second
Sorry
If I could eat in one bite I would
But
Yeah
Drop your other side to the tree today
Oh
No, that was a refland in the game. He's clapping. It's not me. I swear
I'm too busy trying to eat
I can't eat that fat. Well, I can't eat fast, but I can't like talk and eat fast
People who hate eating sounds hate this one beat you go find out why about clicking this video
And you've actually walked around the rocks because I can't jump right now
Are you fighting in the ooh, what are you? Hello? Oh, I need a jump up hold on. Uh, I need to do this with one hand
Pick up item
reverend stirrash
Hmm
Light in the way
I don't know how I'm able to do this right now
Oh
I can only I only like your sense. Can you not tolerate it anywhere else? You can only handle the happy cuttlefish munching sounds
Hmm it's funny because
My mouth is closed, but if my jaw goes low enough like when I like I'm chewing food when my jaw goes low enough
My mouth opens on my model. There we go. I've washed it already
Already
Hmm
I don't know if smacking food is uh, are you okay?
He doesn't do anything
He is an enemy
But he doesn't respond to anything
I think um smacking food is a learned behavior
I suppose others we mushroom here
God this graveyard is it you never end them
You'll lighten up around here. She should probably
There is more food hiding under my natural
I don't want to waste the food because this is all the food I got right now
Oh
No, can you guys get him for me?
I'll be out here you two just go on ahead and have fun, okay
Me and the rival
Just be checking it out
All right. No, he's getting there
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah
Uh sat sat do tree fragment
Uh, okay, I'm to the next I've almost finished eating. I'm so sorry
We love chicken salad
Yeah
That refunds a war crime pride
Hmm
Oh
So violent I follow the torch
I am a simple woman. I see instructions
Grumble some chips on top of the salad to have makeshift crouton. I've never enjoyed crouton. I thought they were just dried stale bread or something
That was my impression of the man
She says she eats stale naturals, but I don't mean
Um
And I keep saying that but we'll play if you were basically
I'll hurry up. I'll catch up. I'll catch up. I'll run. I'll run
I just need like what five more nachos and I'm actually done through for real this time
I'm coming. Just give me a second. I'm coming. I'm coming
Just a few more nachos
And this will feel me for the rest of the stream. I honestly thought I was probably only gonna do eight hours
today
This will be like, uh, I'm gonna really feel it. I didn't get a good sleep or whatever and then
classic me since I get on
I can't have enough
Oh, Jim's day done. Thank you for the super chat. I just saw that there in the notification
I missed it
Only eight hours like I know it's a unique concept, but
I love it, man
Like we're literally getting princess house through Elden Ring DLC. I have no idea what's going on. I'm happy. I'm smiling
I'm eating. Hopefully you guys have eaten and hydrated like you guys are literally coming in and I'm like celebrating cheering for you when you
Oh my god, are they gone? Reeflings? Hello? Hello?
Over here
Where the fuck did they go? Oh, all right. Okay. Oh, there we go. Sorry
Just eight
As I choke because I'm trying to talk and eat. Sorry. I'm gonna shut up. I'm gonna choke
I
The food doesn't disappear it's like more keeps appearing on my bowl
Hmm
Do you think when game studios plan something so large they already plan the DLC in mind
Like this was already in production. Just like it will be like a different that comes out a different timing
So this is massive like absolutely massive
Never end them
I'm getting free souls for every time you guys whack someone
You got it
Okay, I'm okay. Thank you. Thank you. I'm I'm getting through it
I'm swinging. I don't know if I'm hitting anything
Oh, yeah, we have necronomic effect or something
I'm fucking swinging. Oh, I've only got one shoulder
I think we're okay
I think we're okay. Okay. No, I'm potting. I'm potting. Okay. I'll buy him. What'd I get? I bet
Okay, I have two more baitfuls. I think um
And I'm done. I ate
I hydrated questionable
Um
Oh
And then I I wipe my greasy fingers
And I we nap him and then I wipe my mouth on the napkin as well
Hmm
And then I'm all clean. It's prissy. I think I drink a cola
I think I drink a warm
Oh
I've been DLC on the lunch DLC that you buy layers
Um, okay, we're ready. I'm like properly in. I'm locked in. Are we ready refunds?
Let's get a move on. Come on refund. You're gonna get left behind you goober
Gotta get a move on
as I say
As I do a heavy roll follow the light
Oh, there's like a thing here
Uh black pry fly
I have very quiet rupees today
Oh
Okay, a little shortcut
This is an endurance freedom
It was always gonna be 12 hours. Let's be honest. Let's let's not kid ourselves unless my voice
quite literally breaks where I cannot speak
I probably can't stream
But even then you already know that I'm autistic enough to do hand cam ASMR
And all you hear is my breathing because I'm just like giggling that everything you guys are saying. Ooh new enemies
Like
You know, I can't so
I'm addicted and I can't get enough
I've so much lost time to make up for and like it's just like such a good thing and like I'm serious when I say like
I never feel it's when I click go live live. I don't feel stressed. I don't feel like oh my god
I need to do xyz like right now
When I finish this endurance stream
I need to go edit the audio. That's for patreon and upload it
And I know that's going to take me over an hour and I know I'm going to be tired but right now
I feel relaxed
I'm happy
I'm chilling someone just got stabbed over there
Are we beating up birds now?
We are
The most friendly bird in Australia
Right, what am I supposed to do with these swords? I'm supposed to take something all
Right, oh god by the time
I'm supposed to do what?
I'm supposed to take this off
Have this boy out and then hold y right from 4 to 200
And then one okay
I ain't gonna tell you what I was supposed to do. New shot card it mutes Ronnie every time
She can't tell if she says she gets zapped. Honestly, that would actually be content because I can't even
I got to do the first thing
Well, we're going into this cavern
It's got quite a magnificent entrance. I must say whoever architect this
I hope you're paying them well because uh
That is a tourist attraction in a half if that was in real life, you know
It's
Oh, there's something glowing
Wow
Is it a site of grace, but it's just highlighted more. I'm gonna go crazy. What are you?
Touch the cross
Carved words conceal I abandon here the first of the flesh of my body
Fragment is this mackayla or mackoella?
Also, don't forget your blue flash so you can do your weapon or or you can change them into more health. Yeah, I think I'm
Definitely more health
Wait, why are you clapping because I just oh I need to talk to him
Lady led a spoke of you
You're that tarnished
Guided here by kindly michella. Bloody or be driver question mark. I am freya
I once fought alongside general redan
You can be sure I'll hold my own
One if you've yet to do so
Have him give you a map of the crosses whereabouts
You'll find more of them dotted about these lands
They are michella the kinds footprints
Um
Why are you on the floor? Are you okay?
He's hired
Micoleta
Nicholas cage. Yeah, uh, we're doing the Nicholas cage deal fee
As much as I've had to spend all the time in the world with you. I don't want you to be the cost of your health
I don't I'm not unhealthy when I suppose
Right what I want to do am I to follow?
Oh my god, I might need to fart on her on a clip
I
Let out the world's tiniest it wasn't even audible
I felt my my cheeks just part just a little
Foot prints sniff
Zero out of ten no, you know right in my tooth
You can rate the burps but not the toots
Part to burrs part to burrs. No brat burrs and shambles
Hold on a minute. Wait. Oh my god, what's going on?
Oh, they're like silent. I'm just gonna leave the mic on. Sorry. I'm
Sorry to be so gross and but like they're silent. You're not gonna hear them. I'll just leave the mic on
And you just have to guess
When I let one rip
Bit bruising shambles they are over me. She's not unhealthy. She's just seen junk food. She's just like us
Oh, there's another cross. Okay, let's carry out this
Uh, hello
Hello there together
We work together for michela the kind. Yes many things
We have found
What have you found dear traveler? Um
Pickled lever template grants boosts and stuff. Do you give me anything I should know about?
No
Well pickle turtle neck pamphlet grants a large boost of stamina
Everything that is
Touch the cross
And then speak to you. Where's your face? Are you this way? Oh, you're this way?
You must be the tarnished. Yes. I am ansma. Hello
Formerly in service to lord. I may or may not perish now like you another soul guided by kindly michela
I'm hardly the steady hand. I once was
My fighting days are far behind me
Which is why I have chosen to dedicate myself to investigation
To discern tender michela's ultimate purpose
I'd rather not volunteer service to a new master unless I know that I can be of use
Yeah
I created a new character this morning unaware of the power level my fellow reeflings to carry you
I've already caught up to my other
Characters and levels. So I'm gonna keep going. Yeah
Like I would it's quite possible. We'll go back to like lemgraves and stuff
I think I'm gonna hit a power wall where you guys it's like too impossible for you guys to carry me
quite possibly so
We may go back to like lemgraves and like do the actual stuff because like I do need weapon dream stuff, but
Yes, it is kind of like god. I'd be exhausted going up like forced it. So I'm like, okay. I think I'm done by now
As soon as more editors in cooperation release in her job, he's filled that no
That's so funny
Uh, I open manually this door is too big for me to be pushing again
Oh, no reeflings wait
Reeflings did we do something we weren't supposed to
Oh
You're retired. You're out of bounds of the playable area. I'm afraid refilling your service of guiding me ends here because we need to go and save
Thank you very much
Uh, I'm only at level
What level?
I mean, I spoofed my level 191
What are you making? What are you doing?
What was that?
Are you imagining yourself to pass away?
One more reefing and then I go through and then
We see what's on the other side. Thank you reeflings for understanding
How's that oh gimme on
Hold on I need to check on fucking gimme. You can't pause this game. Can you hold on? Sorry
It's cold
Why are you doing this to me?
Oh
She's so silly. She doesn't cry and it's basically a cat's cry
For I need help and it freaks me out of everything she does it
It's a high-pitched cry
Um, which is what they do to get their mom
If you want to be
She literally
And then as soon as she sees me she's like, oh, you're still alive and then walks away again go outside and play game
go outside
Literally, right. Did that scorpion thing leave me alone? I'm still alive. Sorry
It freaks me out when she does the creedisha. It's what kittens do to get their mom and I'm like, oh my god. What's wrong? What's wrong? Um
Nothing's wrong. Right. What the fuck is going on here. There's like a scorpion
How many just one
Am I good? Am I
Can I run
There's no way I have any power to do anything against that
Oh
Hey, at least you're not level 40 right now
That just go for it
Oh, just go for it. Just go for it. There'll be a save station
I'm safe the reeflings have me they just need to
I don't need that right now. I need the reeflings to be able to
I
There has to be a save station
I refuse to believe there's not
Oh, I'm
My heavy roll heavy roll heavy roll that reefling you're allowed to say you told me so you're so allowed to say you told me so right now
Oh my god, you're so allowed to say you told me so
You are allowed to say it until I perish
You are allowed to say I told you so
Okay
Betrayed by the armor upgrade getting this shite off me stripped me down. I'm no having it get that back on
get
These back on what are they weight is like nothing honestly. I'm now medium load so
Is my my roll could be faster if I'm not mistaken
Does this put me on late loads
Being very dumb
I don't know how this works
I assume that doesn't do anything. Oh that is actually fair
Okay, well I can do this now
Light load is 30 percent medium is what people typically have light is very hard to do without just straight up being
I have no idea what your name is but sure and you come
What on earth is your name to get it all censored?
What is your name?
You
Heard her strip down last
Literally, oh, I'm so sorry if I seem out of sorts. Give me doing that me. I'll freak me out
Fuck out
It literally is the cry of a kitten for its mom and I'm like what is wrong
Oh, can I be doing that to my hand? Oh, no. Is there no reefing here?
Is it just us I see some enemy for the same
Oh, are you tipping me?
Oh, here we go. Here we go. Right. We've got enemy and a friendly right do the friendly first and then do the enemy
Enemy enemy I got up an enemy
She and needy
a
unable to summon
adversary, huh
Are we being invaded? We've literally had like two seconds to freaking
Get in here. Are you tipping me glowstone for you?
Okay, why can I not have an adversary and he didn't have an adversary. Okay, and you come
He's healing me. Oh
Oh, it does
Oh
I didn't really heal. Oh, I'm pretty sure I have I'll have enough left. Thank you for your heel
The adversary making it in
Because you didn't say the grace look I was just so happy that I can get the reef on the back
Okay, that was scary. I missed something at the bottom of that statue. I don't know if I need to do that for the lore
There was a statue a walk past when all the wee baby scorpions came out. Oh, I've not blessed us. Okay. I need to bless our journey
If you would like to lie down and I will bless you all for this journey
No, you just want to lead the way you're like, you're like nah, come on
Oh
Okay
rival reefing and you just want to
Oh, you changed clore
Oh makes it you look friendly
You know the rules it doesn't it doesn't matter. There's enough holes for everyone
I'm sorry. I heard the rival
Okay, let's head off on our adventure. I am going to put my nightlight on that keeps me safe from the enemies
That's how it works clearly
Few enemies few enemies got a lot of enemies
Uh-huh, that was a bit silly
Oh wait, I need to hand it press y and rate bumper to two hands away. Yeah, I'm too smart. I remember
Wait, what was that? I saw that
I have more not
originally
The blazing is why I'm trying to speed through my levels right now. I mean
Oh wait, I was going to be like, oh you can catch up
I'm doing 12 hour endurance of those
Can you catch up?
I don't mean it as in a dower way, but I'm like you would have to like what is what is that?
Attacking
Silver horn tender
Hey
Oh, it's our pantry look we have sage hanging and we have the onion
If you didn't know this is actually how you saw onions
You need to dry them out before storage and then they can last the whole year
It's pretty cool, honestly to think that something so simple is removing the water like makes food last longer
But that's also what a dehydrator thingy my barber does
and
I will try my best to catch up
It is possible we might have to go back at some point. Um, not all the streams are gonna be
See even get I was gonna say does this guy even get staggered?
Um, it is possible some days. I might only have eight hours
um
But today and tomorrow is like a hundred percent twelve hours. Um, it's one of the give myself an animal
Um, then I am completely fine if
There's anything there that I don't want to activate that man. Um
The third day I might need a cheeky eight hours and to get
Oh, no
What are they
Like dragonfly
Or drop something
Oh silver horn tender. I guess those are what those are
I'm getting smithing stones everywhere. Is that is that river gonna blow me down?
I don't I'm I'm scared. Is that gonna push me down?
I was just on me there. Sorry. I wasn't paying attention
There's no waiting for strong anything
No, I don't give up. I'm gonna go back to limb graving like level up and do like the actual main quest and stuff
Good night we flings. Good night. Rest well
Store room key
Why yes the store room key
Okay, now that way we're jumping over here. Oh, there's a weak thing here. Hold on
Throwing dagger tangles free
I
That new armor that is only like old
Who or what oh a bird
Beat that bird up show nature what we think about it
those
Huh
Is that a wee bit buggy just a wee bit buggy
Okay, I think that was just like a wee bug. Bird stuck. Bird stuck
We're just beating up everything in our path. I thought rival reef and right right ball replaying
Say rival refling 10 times fast
rival reefing rival reef. Oh, are you gonna stop on the first one rival replaying?
Yeah
I'm healing by the fire and I'm healing by the fire
And the fire is healing me and it makes sure I have lots of flasks
Because I'm so under level over level, but I don't have the upgrade. Wait, don't do that
It says he goes it says go forth
Oh
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Hold on. What do you do? What do you do big slam big slam?
No, I'm here
Now you will handle my club. Oh, how did I dodge? I don't even know
Fifty five damage while everyone literally came in close. Oh, I'm out of stamina
Summon stamina. I'm out of stamina
No, the reefing didn't fail
I
No, I'm so weak
Wait, he wasn't was he even that bad? Okay, this is why I think we're going back to limb grave
This is why I think we might be slightly going back to limb grave
Just the wee bit
Just the wee bit back to limb grave a new map has been found. Wow
Wow
In the realm of shadow
Okay, we are in small private altar
Gee
Look at that it's all being decimated at the back of the cast all those seems like a green area
Oh my god, are we actually going to have a nature area that doesn't look like completely decimated?
This is where all the people the month
In the shadow realm
Have we got all the wrong that was absolutely not your name by the way
Um
All right
An area that doesn't look this
Decimated in Elden ring for a chance
I mean, it would be nice to see like the game dev team have a nice non broken area
Like the closest you get is what the roundhouse table
Um, um wait because it's such a new rule
And then a rival
What is your name that's gonna bother you
Real one of souls that everything has to stop
Oh, we need to do the blessings so we don't get ruled again
If everyone wants to lie down next to each other one friend
If you have the lie down one, I don't even think I'll have
Confirm remove switch
Oh lie down isn't a default. I wonder where you get lie down
Oh, you guys all seem to have it. So you must be playing the game. Well
Only one of you will take HP that one
But it is a sacrifice
Just don't pronounce the H
Ah learning never
We're
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Name wonder he's wiping his way
Why did I start leaving a message there?
Oh my god
Okay, now we're getting back
absolute
absolutely
I don't know where my souls are
Oh
Are we are we crowded around the healing stone?
Thank you for the healing stone
My full health. I'm full health. I don't know where I've lost my souls, but it's fine
I'm sure someone will kindly drop me
Um
Like a billion dragon souls again, and then I just although I've levelled up
I just need decent armor and stuff and not to be bad at the game really
Really, it's kind of the classic case of don't be bad. I hate to admit it, but
As soon as I get decent weapon
I'm literally getting rolled by
No
We're fine. I'm out of stamina, but we're fine
Unlocking your flask upgrade would probably be most important right now drop 99 armor refling can't do that
It's a shame, but we can't do it. I was saying that you guys like dropped me so many weapons and armor like I don't even question. I'm just like, oh
Refling first
What does that mean?
Is that unfriendly? I have a feeling that might have been unfriendly
Uh, something's attacking me. I don't know what but uh, we'll just keep going forward. That's the main thing
Wasn't the bird was it?
What did you admire this man?
Okay. Oh, okay. You were literally turned into kfc chicken wings within what two seconds. Yeah
Don't mess with me or the beefling
Are you sat down there
A bit of working out
Oh
I just smashed a pole on his head pita will be in contact
Oh, did we I am here
Uh, oh, this is where my souls are I found them
Wow if you can okay now take the aggro off of them
Oh
Okay, yeah
Okay, if we like switch the aggro we're fine
Yeah, genuinely absolutely fine if we uh five head up. Is that my healing stone?
Is that my healing stone here if you don't want to use the flag?
I only did it a little bit but that's
Uh
This way
Whoa
I have like a billion eggs, hey
More of those ingredients
Oh
Yeah, see I missed one of these back there. So whatever this is, I hope it's not too important
Oh, I was a reverent spirit ash. I might might need to go back for that. It seems rather important. I don't want to
I don't want to tell you on how it should be, but he's rather
I
Love
Sorry the heat
Oh
What's happening why is one of my rooflings down? Where did you go?
What the heck is this?
Oh my god, oh, no, that's a freaking refland. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm so
Doing a bit of acrobatics. Yeah, acrobatics, mate
Oh, I meant I just hit the wall. I'm punishing the wall
Okay, okay, okay, okay
Okay
Oh
What's her refland one didn't make it
I'm trying to find out my room for being too hot and this is what happens
Okay
Oh, we've failed him
We may he rip in this
He did what you could where you could
No, we can't win them all we can't win
It is not possible
I
Should someone say my message they're like I fall asleep to your streams more than your ASMR streams and I'm like how
How do you not completely perish?
Did I have you?
Is there any other reflings here? Um
Wait, this isn't a grave site. I've
No, it is a grave site
I think I had you in recently did I not
Is who are you red mean for you sure
Uh
There is as I said, there is probably a possibility we're going back boss time
Have you already as there are reflings who've already finished all of the deal? I almost dropped off
Um, have you guys already finished like the DLC?
Is that no friend that's friendly
Reflink refling that's another replay
Reflink that's another replay
Stop it. That's another replay. Are you not a refling?
Am I missing something or did I just fall in from that's not a refling? It's an NPC who?
Oh, no, I wondered why your name was so funny. I was like that's such a specific name refling
Why you wrote I'm so sorry refling wait. So how did I get rid of her?
I don't
Oh my god. Sorry. I'm going to go ahead so you despawn refling. I'm so sorry
I was so freaking confused at the name. I was like that's such a specific name
All right. I shouldn't do a cutscene so you don't get pummeled
Freya hates refling. Oh my god. This bosses effect can well destroy you
Oh horned beast from higher sphere delivered
Take root inside the tower sculptor keepers
And perched within we beg of thee rise
Oh
And those who plague the tower
Lends away the trumpets
Oh
Uh
Where's the first
Eh
He has this
Oh my god
I have no flash I'm absolutely no help right now
Uh, you're on your own holy moley
Uh
Yeah, um
I think we need to go back to limb grave. I said it. I don't I don't know what I'm supposed to do
Isn't there that death plumage thing going on?
I'm probably gonna perish like in there because of an accident
Oh
Wait, why are you locking on to me? I haven't done any damage to you
I'm trying to look at his attack patterns, but
Wow
Oh my god, sorry
No, there's no way holy
Holy moley
Just wait as in
Implication of
He filtered so many people. I would not be surprised
And ignoring the impending doom that's actually pretty decent. He gets harder
Oh my god
Okay, we have a real situation on our hands
I'm too weak to do anything because of my weapon drain stuff
Do you want
Reflings do you want to have a whack at it?
I don't mind you guys have it if you want a whack at it. I do not mind at all
Or we can go back
Go get some flasks. Okay, we're going to go back to limb grave and just chill out for a little bit
Because like this area is definitely getting a bit too much for me
As for seats and stuff
Unfortunately, my memory failed me of what ones I've gotten
For the sake of
Oh
Okay, we're just going to take a little chill pill
We're just going to uh, I want to explore and get like all the maps and stuff if that's okay
We'll just take it nice and easy
Nice and easy. Okay. Nice and easy
Uh, we'll go unlock the map. Um, if you want to come with me, I'm in
K-Lum ruins and north of K-Lid. Yeah
Uh, and then I get my little reasons in and we'll just do some explore and get a few flasks and seeds
Um, not really sure what else to do
Can't do that from here
From this one freaking marker
I've got the game actually going to make me go travel on my own. Does it not know that I'm a streamer princess?
That map is a separate map. Well, I'm going to go discover the map of this
Go to summon water village outskirts. I will go there
Please do not attack
I do
Good luck attacking me. No, I'm on the other side of the lake
Why does it say dragon spiral? I'm gonna get jumped by a dragon
Please I just want the map of the area. That's all I have
I'm a simple streamer. There's not much more to it
Just want the map of the area. I wasn't too far off it
Nice to be at pin the oh, I found the dragon
I'll never guess where the dragon is
Uh, right, okay, we'll discover this map. I actually don't see the map on the close here here
Okay, um, I am too cool to summon water village, which I
And the other map
So
It's on the other map
It's in the middle of Lynn grief
I
Didn't that took me a whole second. Sorry
We are going such a girl boss girl princess streamer and she's the basically girl. Oh god
Honestly, where's where we marker? Oh
Uh, right. I can summon you guys in here and then we'll
That
Oh, I keep doing that. I'm not to bring in the adversary first. Ah, we'll show you. We'll show you. Okay
Oh
That's what you're wearing that boss's face
You're wearing that boss's face
That we just got absolutely kablamo'd by
There's a church and a grave and a sacred tear just south-east of here. Okay
Oh, no, what's wrong little refund. Do you need a nap?
Are you scared of the enemy?
What's wrong? Are you caring for a blessing me?
Uh, is there any other refling and the summon water village outskirts at the north west of kaolin or limb grief?
What are you holding?
No, not that one this one
For some reason there's no other symbol showing up. So there's only one logical thing to do one slam
Um
Okay
Ray let's get into it. I don't know why there's not any more symbols showing up the game's a bit finicky
But let's see if we can hold our own and limb grave flash kaolin
Calling the reef
Oh, he did a jump jump, okay
And a jump and a jump and a jump
Yahoo
We did it a jelly. Did you make it? Yeah, see look who's really MLG pro out here
Can you watch over a certain goddess if she's demon?
I knew she was doing drunk buckshot roulette. Sure. I or dining messenger on
I
Meet the girls do not enter out to me refling time. Also me even there's something up with a girl. Uh, uh, uh
Okay, I can't reach that. I'm too small. That's okay
I'm used to being small so
Take it where you're hidden
Oh, I have to get those flakes and on you. How do you do that?
My tummy's no digesting the noises are
Weaver someone who might be interested in rescuing the great kenneth height
Servant to the to order he gives me a thing or no, the false
That's no despite of people might have heard I'm touched. I want you to tonight come on
What are you my fort life? Oh, I fret not as celebrations will be
I would take that depraved lot honestly got picked first. He hit it in he in
And to think
I almost feel sorry
What are you waiting my fort lies to the south beyond the south beyond mist would take it back
Take it back. Oh, baby
A shot for every failure. She's fine. Just a bit plush. Okay as long as she's fine
But you'll you'll tell me if I need a message or and be like
Temp you to tuck yourself into bed
Okay, I trust you guys and your judgment. I don't know ha ha funny streamer. It was but health first
Oh that boar's charging you
Me and the boar are charging me
I have funny streamer. That's basically the only way I can do it is like so, you know, it's like a streamer does a drunk stream
And it's like the cute drunk and like oh, they're having a good time
They're giggling they're laughing they're singing or whatever and then there's like the other drunk time when you're like, oh my god
I this doesn't feel good like watching this I feel nervous, you know
I
Crystal tear and a wondrous physics. Oh, I never even had that on mall. I understand now why I was getting asked about the physics
Okay, is it like a sad drunk streamer like yeah, I only got two beers and about eight ounces the camera has it done
Don't overdo it
Oh, wow and a sacred tear
Oh wait, but here's a leafling here
The perfume alone
I swear if I just brought in
An mpc again because I'm so dumb and I can't tell the difference
If you kill Kenneth, he gives a golden key. Do I want to kill whoever this Kenneth is?
Or should I be worried did I just call in an mpc again? I was gonna say the name looks so formal and specific
uh
Oh, no
You're not an mpc at all. No, definitely not an mpc with this uh with this arrangement
Oh, do you want do you want it to rival leaflin?
You want to join in
Are you good nah you joining
No, that's definitely blue. Yeah
You're cowering
Oh, why did that all walk on you that actually like went for you
Okay, let's go again
He's just good at blending in true
Wow, I'm using up a stamina bar because the game thinks I'm fighting you the invader
She's shocking behavior
Forget Lumbridge we adventuring through a limb break. Okay, that did not work at all. I thought that rhymed a bit better in my head
I
May have to make a cup of tea for my wee voice shortly
Even though I just ate
My voice is starting to feel it. Okay. I've been rambling your ears off for how long
Eight hours already. Wow
I'm sorry, but you guys make the same part with one
I say, oh, what do you think of elder drink?
Oh, it's really good if you play it with friends and play with friends. What do you mean?
I'm like, oh, I got carried through the entire game carry. What do you what do you mean characters intact? Oh, um
Yeah, I kind of just
Yeah
10 out of 10 game wait
So if you played it solo, what's your rate and oh I can still appreciate the game and all that
But I'm too scared as a player
But the actual game itself is still 10 out of 10. There's fantastic art and direction and narrative and everything
Just found my xp form spot need to take a detail my weapon is not strong enough
I can relate to that my weapon is although it's a dlc weapon. So maybe I'm like overpowered for limb grave now
Caleb and all that
The fact you guys can remember where like these sacred flasks and tears are
Look at fast from running. I like speedy gonzales
I never played it you've never played it before wait, why are you tolerating me playing at this?
I guess soul's game doesn't for everyone like I have to be honest. I've never played any other soul's game
um
And I actually don't think I could even play this game on stream if it wasn't for the fact that you guys can come help me
Like it is not possible. It's not possible. I cannot do this on my own and get too scared
Too scared. I want I want uh friendly. I want help. I want everything
Because I like you
But like to tolerate like such an endurance stream of a game
I feel like
Right there one dead here. Wow
Oh, I remember what we're doing. There's a piece of a half up here. Are we going inside the castello?
Sorry, mate. I won this time
Elden ring is just the backdrop for the yap stream
How does she do it leaving jump?
Oh, I'm getting sleepy because I've eaten. I'm not sorry. I'm doing an endurance stream
I'm not gonna bed
I need to get endurance
because
If I don't then I'm in big trouble big trouble
What's going on in here?
We things together strong. It's not normal to watch someone when you play the game
You love play a game you don't like. I don't know. I just feel like
Oh, that game doesn't interest me. I won't watch it type thing
I'm like, I'm not that entertaining. Oh my god. You just did that for me. Thank you
I just got that ash reward even though I didn't do anything so
I'm getting a lot of blood roses around here
But we watch for you know, you're gonna stop. Oh my god
Can't say such things to me
You can't be so nice to me. You'll make me too happy
What happens if I get an ego because of how um kind you guys are?
Okay, I'm picking up this half is this for the all
That I've already gone fast the elevator it is
Oops
Hello
Okay, that was lucky. I don't I thought that was a lot closer than it was
Sorry, I was doing where are we going?
I
When you're eager to be so flustered get an ego use it to crush ours
I don't want to crush your ego. I want to crush your pelvis. Yeah
I don't want to crush your ego though
Like sometimes it's good to be selfish and like confident and all that is um
Isn't it so bad to be confident in yourself?
My lord talk about in dream stream after I went to work and came back and you're still here
Did you have a good day at work?
Did you remember to hydrate did you remember to do your
After work
Jobby for 45 minutes in the toilet like that's all I see about on tiktok
Is all these chicks are like
Oh my man comes back to work and he takes a 45 minute in the toilet
and everyone's like
I don't know if you've ever been on the the female side of tiktok
It is the most bizarre experience of your life because without fail the comments are leave him
It's bizarre. It doesn't matter what the context of the video might be
There's always one chick in the comments that goes leave them
And it was like what where did they even come from?
So, yeah, stay if you if your brain was on tiktok the chick side of it is bizarre. I'm sorry
You've never thought I you I used entirely the wrong phrase. I meant get an eagle use it to crush our minds bad typing
I mean either way we got something's getting crushed
And it's not the can the central bank of
Texas
Oh
Did you guys forget the joke already someone said central bank of texas and
The acronym reminded them of something. Oh, it happened a couple of hours ago now. Like sorry that you guys don't remember. Okay
sorry
Only people have been here from the very start understood any of that
I take a
Boss makes a dollar. I make a dime. That's why I take job beyond company time. Exactly as intended. So I'm gonna pay exactly
CBO too. What's the acronym central bank texas?
um
Oh, there's a bear
I
Mean as long as the bears. Oh my god, it's a ojisan in the wild
Okay, we got the map. That's fantastic. We're the heck Harvey. Okay, we're right down here
I'm following the reason
How many times would you be depositing them with drawing will at the
central bank of texas? I don't even know what we're trying to do with the euphemism
Okay, but I don't get it. English isn't my first one. Um
CBT
Is uh acronym for
Hold on, let me pick up these flowers like when a woman
And a man get together
And the man has two boiled eggs on them
And then she will she like steps on her
On the eggs and he goes hey, those are my eggs
But instead of feeling sad about her stepping on his eggs
His he he he's like he he enjoys it
Rock and ball torture. Oh my god, then most of you're gonna have to forgive me
I swear but most of every time you see me alive
You must your eyes must rule out of your skull being like she said she's gonna do this goddamn
ASMR collab and then you see me sitting streaming for 12 hours
Honestly, I'd be fed up of myself. So don't worry if you ever feel fed up towards me
Uh
I will never forgive you stony bad girl bad girl honestly
Jiki jiki
She's just sitting in the villa streaming literally
Mamosa refland
Don't you guys forget that one of us one of us one of us
Are we about to the beat of the game?
I don't know
There is a limited amount of flasks in the world. I have no idea what they're going
Ooh the rocks are floating. Whose connection is that? Is that my connection or his connection?
Must be
Okay, it's your connection because you're a stan moment
She has a membership too. That's when you know that's when you know
Me who doesn't have a membership to Mamosa
Smile
Ah these sheep
Stony you can step on my egg. Am I allowed?
Are you going for it? Oh, he's going for it
Is he gonna let me do it?
Oh my god, wait, why do you guys do such a whack and I don't
Oh wait, hold on two-handed hold y right bumper to two-handed. Okay
I do
Oh, I know you've blown a horn. Whoa
Okay, there's something in here. I'll let you guys fight. We'll start discover what is in the back of this carriage
It's a great axe. Okay, we'll be honest. Don't think we need a great axe
Not monetized queen soon though. Soon TM
Soon TM
You'll get there
Oh
Okay, we follow the torch
We use our eyeballs and follow the torch. Why yes, of course
It's really just an okay axe and my axe
You have my bear
under my axe
Thank you
Wait a minute. I think you're not my friend
I'm muted and I and the OBS studio shows you if you're making a sound or not while muted
I in the microphone heard it. It would have been over
I've mained and my tentacle. That's the same you guys are have mained in
How you doing it? Honestly, I have to admit this is gonna sound really weird
It's actually really funny and like a dog errands. I don't have to think or do anything. I'm just happy to be here
Like this is so fun. I'm just like talking away. Blip. Blip. Blip. Blip. Blip. And I was like, oh, and you raise it. Oh, and you
Flask, oh, oh this, oh that
Stony season's ended like her full name in a trance. What does that mean?
We've done a momo shirt to bring this
Uh
What castle and flowers. Sorry. I got distracted by the pretty flowers. Tee hee. Honest to say
Is this where the last piece is?
The bench between asleep people
Handholding is the most fun and best way literally
You said it was a noise that you wouldn't want us to hear. No
You're not allowed
Because once you do it, you can never go back once you brap you can never unbrap
Honestly for me, it's not that serious that really
What
Wait
Why can't I progress?
They're going for it. I can't progress. Why would I need you guys not to be here? I'm about to do another boss fight
I bet or not
It's the wall again, I can't believe it three year old be sure to hit the wall at three year old
What no refling you can
Because you're crossing a boom boundary
Uh
Uh, I'm gonna get on torrent. I don't trust this at all
There's a thing right
Can I wait can I just summon you guys like right here?
I can so why did it even make you this with the because it's like a new loaded area? That's
Pretty plausible explanation
That it's a new load in area
Grass ahead no enemies. He was just a wee fellow
Oh
Yeah, background load in shenanigans. Okay. I understand that then that makes sense
Because if it wasn't then I'm angry because I want maybe something but if not, then fame
I'll allow it to get there. I'm gonna do a little cheeky little cheeky head and load in the screen
Um
I love
Yeah, it's just new can any other leaflings come in
Or is it because of something too far so doesn't
I don't mean to be an adversary, but I'm gonna need some help. Okay. I'm gonna need some backup
I'm wondering I think I'm gonna be honest
I think a lot of people might just sleep or they can't stream
Because the before the pool was massive
But you guys are allowed to break okay, he's don't ever feel bad if you like can't join me or can't get in or anything like that
Hmm
You can stream snake. I keep putting my sign down, but does that show up? Hmm
Sorry, I'm addicted to playing the dlc. Honestly, maybe if there's leaflings that are playing the dlc
Maybe that's wiser for when we go back to the dlc
I actually don't mind that concept. So maybe keep going ahead for me if that's possible
Yeah, the further you go because the difficulty gap is getting massive
Okay, no, don't worry about joining. Please don't worry like we just been chilling. Don't you want being chilling?
Are you all red so I can spot you? Okay, let's go
Oh, I need the blessing. I forget every time that I need to bless you guys when you come in
Do you have to lie down?
Okay ready steady
And I've led you into temptation
Wow hold y bumper 200
Pretty sure I just beat the main part of the dlc. So we'll be good. Okay
Yeah, we didn't some exploring
Is level 42 anywhere enough to help you um in where I am? Yes, actually. Hello
Hello
Is somebody there? Yes me?
Yeah, of course. My name is arena
I've escaped from castle mooring to the south
Servants there have rebelled
I
I can't be sure what it is
My eyesight's been weak since birth, you see, but I swear I heard frightful howling from all over
My good father secreted me at the castle, but decided himself to stay
He says it's his duty
As commander
The accent sounds familiar. Is that a ba we know?
I
I fear for father's life
The servants are full wrath
Filled with hatred for every one of us. They've since come for every one of the companions I escaped with
They haven't spared a soul. I fear it's no different at castle mooring. Please
I implore you
Would you mind taking a letter to my father
At the castle and my soul wishes that he escaped
Even if his honor should be the price, please
I just want him to be safe
Of the region I'll deliver the layer
Dearly then please
Take this. Yeah, we'll deliver a letter. Come on. Let's go. Okay
Deliver it to my father who remains in the castle if you please. Yeah, sure Ray. Let's go find your dad
The castle's done here. What are you?
Are you spelling out a word or is this just a pose in particular?
She needs some yummy grapes. Don't think so. I mean like the regional accent, but I can't put my finger on it
Um, a lot of the voices are actually Welsh
Um, I'm hearing Welsh voices a lot in this game
Um, which is nice. You don't really get to hear the Welsh accent at all
It's kind of like one of those forgotten accents. It's very strong
Very very strong
Wait, does he not even attack?
I'm gonna have to get that pose
Uh, this should be re-grapes
Are they nutrition?
They're looking for me here
A morning star and it's literally, uh
Jack is me
I think I
Yeah, believe it's a Welsh pronunciation. Oh blaz
Am I beating this up fucking come here
Take this
No, you're gonna win
I've got matey shot. I don't think I've ever seen a crossbow run of this game. I'm gonna be honest
It's an I've never seen it if you read the description of weapons and gear these things have a wee hidden buff as well
Honestly, don't mind buzz
Let me grab this little phone ring here
The morning star can get you after every hit. It can heal you after every hit
Uh, if my memory serves me correct, there's a horse guy that's ready to attack behind this
Uh, bang. Do you have any stone? You do. I'm sorry to see
Do you have anything else that we use?
I guess if you want to do like a hundred percent
Collection, uh being interesting
I mean, I have so many souls I can just buy out the shot
I
Only at night they're called night riders. Okay, we're safe for now
I do love a good hidden status
It's kind of like
Um, I don't know if you guys have ever played this game called darkest dungeon. I've never managed to finish it always gets stuck
But I've always thoroughly enjoyed the game when I've played it for like my two hours before getting absolutely gridlocked
I'm just stuck at it
The game's like, oh your characters are supposed to die. Don't worry about it. And I'm like
But if they die, how am I supposed to progress?
Because like they're my strongest character type thing
And I just find it really hard and like, I know
I don't know if I should like mod it or get or if you guys want to vulture it
You guys tell me like the best thing to do. I'd probably need to watch a YouTube tutorial though
On it because I wouldn't want to play a stream game that I completely mess up like I kind of learned my lesson not to be silly
and
I was like picking a game that like I have my doubts that I'd enjoy and then play it anyway like
Boutro was interesting because I could hear a shot
And like it just went amazing like I genuinely cannot wait to play Boutro with you guys again
Um, and it was like so nice being able to be like, is this the right move?
Yeah, no, that's the right move. Like don't don't worry about it. You're doing great. Like that was so lovely
I'll really enjoy that
And like I love how you guys are like so non-judgmental about how dumb I can be. Is that a church back there?
I think I'll need to oh these things won't happen here. Have I been here? No, I haven't been here
Have you thought any more of them? No, we backed off
Unfortunately, I've come back because I need to upgrade my my
flasks and pouches and stuff because I'm just at a terrible just truly in wholeheartedly terrible
Um
So we're now back in the limb group area. We're just hunting for sacred tears for seeds
Just so I can get a few more pouches
Because I am basically getting completely princess carried. I have not done one proper thing
Like on my own. I genuinely haven't. We've been here since the moment in and I wouldn't have it any other way
I wouldn't have it any other way. I'm literally going. I feel like a dog on a walk
That just gets to have all the excitement of showing up at the destination like oh, what are we doing now?
Oh, that's lovely. Okay, let's go
That is exactly what you want
You sold a guy in the belfry
well
That's debatable considering how many levels I got shoved up to thanks to rieflings
putting all their stonk. There's there's soul stonks into me
and
Donna Donna has some darkest dungeon mechanic and it's a colorful
alternative version
and the streamer mode has
That survived on youtube
It's very strange what things will fly and not fly
Like one game would do it with a different art style and it's fine. But another game is like not as to work
Um, it really is this massive great area at the moment, which is a shame because like I'm sure
Now obviously company wants to make money, but that show people behind it
I'm sure like they never want their the people that create content to ever be unsure
of what the rules are
like the people behind the scenes that actually
care about like creators and like I understand like hey, this is your income source. This is serious like
um, obviously as there is just on her
Monetization celebration stream. Hopefully it went well actually. I had no idea how it went because you know
I've been going crazy over here for a little bit. Um, but like
Basically azura got rejected for monetization
But youtube now has an appeal system in place and we appealed it and to my surprise
They monetize her and now she has an like an income source now. She
Is like genuinely like a full content creator now. She has an income source. She has these avenues like
But if youtube denied it then like azura can't even like plan to move out at all like she just has the
She would have had to wait a whole other month like type thing. So I have to admit there are doing changes in that
Like I don't hate
YouTube as a whole because it is a good platform
It discover abilities really good as well
Not for a live stream discover ability of the live streamer isn't good
But if you produce alternative content like asmr short for example that discover ability is so valuable
Whereas if you want to compare it to like switch for example, it's just no the same like it's just not hanging
Very uh uncharacteristic of youtube too much alleviation. Well, actually I was like, um
Uh azura's goobies are like what stopped her but the problem was her appeal rejection
actually didn't mention
actually gratifying content
um
So I was like wait, this must be a mistake then because when youtube don't actually give a reason
I don't know if it's possible
We got reviewed like her channel got reviewed by someone that doesn't like anime
Look, I wouldn't be surprised it's plausible
And but the appeal went through that's the main thing azura now has a another income source on top of patreon on top of uwu market
and
And hopefully there'll be something else. How do you guys remember where the churches are literally straight led me straight to a church
I don't know how you do that
Is this like when I'm like here's all the strats in viva finata you guys like here's all the strats in elden ring
Oh, they're on the map. Oh
Another sacred tear
Everyone should be monetized. Yes, everyone is monetized officially on youtube. Um, I think uh
Management are gonna do like
About it at some point, but I'll definitely like
Oh my god, congrats girls like pat them all on the back like
Yeah, they did it. They did it
There's steps to being a content creator
Sorry, I feel time content creator. Oh that yellow fish
Wait, where we going?
Do we know
Follow the light
It's just like you in Assassin's Creed brotherhood really impressive
So you just shoot off all that info about the game
Okay, I'll take it that way then because I'm like there's no way on earth
I could remember where the locations or churches are that have sacred tears inside
Her voice is so good. They thought it wasn't real
Literally, I had to write the cringiest script for her. Maybe she'll find it funny
Um, and we could like show it on twitter or something because uh, zura is such a good sport
Like she's so down for anything. I'll like suggest something to her and she's like, yeah. Yeah
I like she's so that is such a good sport. Fantastic. Um
She might find it funny if I show her the wee video that we had to appeal the monetization with
Oh, I can put up Azura's meme ASMR now
Oh my god, then all of her meme ASMR's are up. Oh, thank the heavens. Right. I'll need to keep that in the back of my mind
Oh, jeez. Sorry. I was both listening to her
Um
Yeah, I can put up her
Oh
Sorry, I'm getting yawning because I had something a winged size. Oh, that's what that crazy weapon is. You guys are so coming with
um
Only need to remember 12 churches and forget how many seats along the way
I mean, we're definitely freaking getting are you joking?
I
Wondering why Azura didn't have any ASMR uphills that were in line. Yes. So those meme ASMR's those originally were actually supposed to go up
in order to get the
Watch time for monetization
However, the debut went so well that everyone reached the watch time after debut
YouTube just took an entire week to update the stats
And then like one after one we did our celebration
But Azura behind the scenes actually got denied and we're having to make this like silly appeal of video. She's like
It's so cringe. They're like explain how you make content
And I had to like type of sense for her to say I am a live streamer
I make my content live you can see via the evidence of all my live streams
I play video games live like it just got really silly and arbitrary
But the silly and arbitrary work. So I'm not even mad
um
Like I'm just glad they genuinely that appeal process actually works
Like as much as youtube bad warning for kind of meme stuff or whatever a great area on ASMR now
I'll I have to I have to put my hands up. Oh, sorry. I didn't mean that. Um, I have to put my hands up and say, you know what?
We're
What's that? Oh
Where are we going? I don't think
Anyone knows where we're going. Oh, he's okay. He's down there. He's down there
Go down go down
um
I have to put my hands up and say, you know what youtube put this appeal system in place
for things that happen and it actually did help us out
Whereas old youtube didn't have an appeal system. So Azura would have had to have waited
30 days on top of
Uh, what she had already streamed at that point
um
So yeah, sorry. I have to admit youtube definitely won there. Um
With that one, I do appreciate the appeal process actually working
The bell tolls for the a better not
I need to keep my voice
I'm actually a bit worried about my voice breaking a little bit. Where are we at? Oh, no
We're almost at nine hours and I'm like, is my voice gonna break before then
Oh, no
I can feel it breaking though, which is not only
Slight problem. I need to maybe not
The thing is I don't want to stream like completely monotone
But the completely monotone is what helped me not break my voice
Hydrate how about I make a cup of tea in 10 minutes?
That sounds like a deal
Um
And we'll get some water bottle and all that
Whole ass family, but me's got COVID can I get a good look like it? Yeah, you're gonna catch this shit. I'm sorry
Unless you're like unless you have like a separate bathroom
And you can just grab like take away food without them like being in the kitchen or interacting. Sorry, you're getting COVID
Uh
Oh, no enemy you
Reslin, I don't think you have to do anything
Every slim you didn't have to jump
Why are you pointing into it? You're the one who's to go get them
It's you two that needs to go get them. Not me. I'm too scared
Okay, let's see if we can do it
Oh my gosh golly
Oh, I love it here. I love it here. What we're sweet. What was that attack? Oh my god
You literally said like banquish in the name of the
Oh my god, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, not the freaking light don't
Oh
Sugar right, how'd I get you back?
What do they bring you back over here at castle want rampart?
Back to lunaria
There's two more in lunaria
This is like lunaria over here by the the boil prune chat
Or do you want me like way at the start like last on a lunari lake shore
I'll do the lake shore reeflings are strange creatures
Strange and magnificent
They are also loyal and also patient
So I hope the milking sessions make it work. You're sorry. I shouldn't do
Oh, you want boil prawn? Oops
Oops, I may have brought us wait you want boil prawn. Hold on boil prawn
Hold on boil prawn. Shack my bad. My bad. My bad. I apologize. That was me
That was me. We're at boil
Cran
Shack, we have unusual powers. Yeah, you can grow your tentacles
So you guys have lots of access
Are you talkative yet? What the hell is wrong with you? You're trying to start something piss off before I crack you in half
What the hell is wrong when you're trying to start us piss off?
Why do you not want to sell me?
Uh, right no evil reefling first. Does it work?
E okay good reefling first wait evil reefling gone sugar
I
Ruined me
Nobody that can I even write me down now
I can't stop writing them down because I think everyone's gone to bed to be honest
And their reeflings are being nice and patient and we
Um
Step on his prawn take this
Now you have now you have cuttlefish prawns. What are you gonna do about it? What the hell is wrong with you?
You're trying to start us piss off
Before I crack you in half
Crack you in
Wait, were you are you gonna close on your hand? You do look at your flaws
Wow
Oh, you're like one of those feral beast ones I don't like
Are you ready? I don't know what we're doing where we're going somewhere
Maybe you didn't even know where we're going. Oh, I've not done the ceremony. Hold on line up for the ceremony reeflings
I need to ceremony you
One more reeflings of ceremony
I
What my
I would pay for strong it step on me for on ready
All done you have been blessed now you may go into war
Okay, hold on
I could have sworn you wanted us to arrange you about the cat. Oh no, Gimli's in safety. Whoa
Miko's not safe
So
Oh
Okay
Vigo and Gimli I still have two cats. I'm happy to say reeflings. I still have two cats
It's because it's because
Uh Vigo is a mix so he can't jump and escape
So when Gimli's inside I'm like, oh, it's fine. Gimli's here. What did I miss nothing?
And just my cats being a menace, right? Are we ready?
Leap the way reeflings reef that leap the way
I
Just heard the control her job is I left my cat outside
But the cat can come inside at any minute, but I didn't know if the cat was outside
Read the way leaflings did I say it wrong? Sorry
I'm a bit. Whoa, because I completely forgot about Vigo. Sorry Vigo
Um
But all is good
As they say in the Netherlands they go they say all is good
That's how they say. How are you?
In the Netherlands they say all is good. Nothing. That's a good sentence. Like all is good. Yeah, I'm really yeah
Yo, all is good with me. What what's going on here? And then that's when you say, oh, you've been need to hold
And then the other Dutch person goes bottom. No bottom bottom bottom bottom. I don't know
See see see the reeflings have given me their seed after I bless them
She are the German
All right, here are we can baron is German
Chat we must read the way for her on camera
All is good now. I can't believe all is good
If she only was a grass. Hey, we'd be leaflings. Oh, that's so cute
My little leaflings. What if I was a firetape? What would you be high?
Highlings does not work if I was a firetape
Firelings kindling
I think you may be kindlings like a week kindle
And because you're so caned as well
Canedlings. Yeah. Yeah, Amberlings is cute. Ashlings. I've got fire beechaboor. Oh
Oh, no, is this that bird that one shot so if he gets enough poison on you
Holy crap, leave him alone
Why yeah
We're getting bunched up. No
Oh, that is a creepy design
I see this every time my hat goes off to the development team for making some creepy that frost bait
And it looks like frost bait by yeah. Oh, no
Oh, no, this can't be my riffling zone. Oh, no, it's up to the other
Wow
I'm out of stamina. Just get to the dam. Hey
I'm helping I did I did 60 down a 600 damage
What is frost bait doing?
200 damage. That's great. Oh, how did I miss I didn't even
Oh
We have
Yeah, I think that's what did you just show me
You
Did that refling just do us and
All right, get on a horsey
And then we'll go. Oh, no, I didn't just cover the me mat. You're not make it there without perishing
Surely I will make it once the frost bait mirrors felt effect is triggered dealing damage and for a 30 second duration
Increases damage for 20%
I ate huge damage and then immediately got frostbitten. Oh
It was infamilar with the boss didn't know I was gonna eat all that yum yum yum that yummy damage you didn't know
But you did amazing though we won
I'll teleport back to that loading site, but I do want to be able to see the map just so
So I can see I know cartographers anyone any any cartographers any map appreciators
And if you're a map, I think if you're a map maker, you're a cartographer
Yeah
Oh, there's a site here as well reflames. These are too smart. How do you know I'm gonna be here?
Actually
Actually, oh
I've got the map
I don't know if there's anyone else that's trying to get in
Right academy gate town
I am going to go micro cup of tea if you can give me a second. I have 500 hours. I know for too much
I'm glad you can find a game that you can enjoy
Seriously, it's so nice when you can find a game that you like
Um, and then you can just have a fun time with like it is really good
Right give me four minutes. I'm gonna make a cup of tea and make sure the cats are okay
Because I think I just scared the living daylights out of gimley. I basically flew out of that door and then
Like burst out and like there you go
But no all is good
Yeah, I'll be four minutes roughly. I'll get a cup of tea. I'm gonna get another
Uh
A bottle of water because I'm eating the hydrate. I'm eating too. Get a bit more serious like that
I just get too invested. Okay. I just get too invested
I'm just trying to stomp in and round to check on cats. Honestly. I was like who does
Are you there?
Right, I'll be back in four minutes. Please get a stretch. Please go for a little tinkle from your winkle
yellow fireman's hose
And and don't forget to get a wee snack if you're feeling packaged because food is fuel. You know how it works around here
I'll be back very shortly. Okay
So
Are you squint me right now?
Are you squinting me right now?
Are you squinting me?
Is this a portal?
Examine the seal.
To the left, there's a save.
Yes! I remember!
Ah, I remember the person.
My hair was crazy.
Oh no, my scars on my legs are gone.
I thought it looked pretty cool.
I like that AC has scars.
Oh, there's two enemy reflexes.
Who's not being around me?
Oh man, I don't think I'm being around you.
Okay, we are now at East Raya Lucaria State.
Raya Lucaria.
I would skip for you to do it.
I love being like, come to the convention.
My A-Bone will prevent me.
There's only two that I've actually shown off.
I don't know if the loading symbols aren't working for everyone,
so I do apologize if you're trying,
but you don't keep displaying.
I'm not really sure what the deal is.
Although I have a slight inclination,
and I'm not saying that just because I'm a cuttlefish,
that the servers are probably overloaded like crazy right now
and are barely surviving.
So just bear with me.
As I said, I'm going to be playing this a lot until we're satisfied.
Would you like to all cower before me?
Time for your blessing!
All done!
You have been left.
Now I put the sword on.
Then right bumper.
No, sorry.
Why right bumper?
He's whimpering in response.
You have an inclination.
Literally, I'm like,
oh, inclination is such a good word.
I think it's a good ASMR as well.
Inclination.
Yeah.
I'm going to do some trigger words
that are all related to cuttlefish or whatever.
Inclination.
I like when ASMR sounds like they're beatboxes
and then they do trigger words.
It's really funny.
I'm not going to beatbox before anyone's like,
why would you beatbox?
Come this way.
Are we just going the same way anyway?
If that's your inclination.
Do you feel ever that we're so inclined?
Your car transaction has been inclined.
Wait, that's not even funny.
That doesn't even work in a sentence.
Pardon.
Are you guys in here?
Oh, you are in here.
Imagine a convention with 100 people in the floor
like a starfish waiting for a girl to stomp on them.
Sounds like a rifling convention of me or something.
I feel like it would be funny though.
But it's a wail day and appropriate.
I don't know.
Aren't you tired?
Aren't you tired of everything being the exact same?
Aren't you tired of never having the excitement
of something new?
Admit it.
What is this?
Why did the tree fall though?
Is the tree bad?
I would love it.
What is launching at us?
Something is going for us.
I don't know what.
Whoa.
Am I missing something?
Oh my god.
What are they called?
Trunchions or something.
I've completely forgotten what these freaking things are called.
But they're bad anyway.
A trebuchet.
Oh, a trebuchet.
It's trebuchet.
Not a truncheon.
Oh my god.
No, I can't hit him.
His butt is so exposed to me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know how I'm perfectly avoiding you by accident.
Truly by accident.
I'm not even putting effort into trying to avoid him.
He's doing it all himself.
I don't want to spank the horror.
Something is wrong.
Oh, that's Gideon's magic.
Gideon does that in the Borscht.
Aw, I don't think having to compare the thing.
Oh my god.
You're gone.
I'm going to regret that.
I'm going to ruin you, buddy.
I'm trying to fade off the tiredness right now.
What do you mean streaming for nine hours makes people tired?
What are you talking about?
This isn't even possible.
In fact, the improbable occasion three.
We're going to the right.
Why are we going to the right?
Is there a thing here?
We're going to the right.
Spank the horse.
I've got reflexes by accident.
I don't know how.
I was like walking away from his attacks.
I wasn't even rolling out of them.
I'm just like, ooh, streamer luck.
It'd be funny to say the least seen thing
so many lean down.
I don't know.
I feel like that kind of like fun is like,
what are those like once in a lifetime,
like fun things?
Like, I don't know.
Like, I need to try and think of all the arguments
before I start arguing.
Like, what would someone say about it?
Oh, that's behaviors inappropriate.
We're all consenting adults.
So annihilated.
Wait, why am I getting madness?
Oh my god.
It's the Lord of the Rings tower.
How did I do this last time?
I'm pretty sure I did do this successfully
because I died.
And then like,
someone would be like, oh, that's so tacky.
Like, oh, she's just a Lutuber.
I never said I was going to fucking praise the Lord
in the middle of the stream.
I'm only going to praise him as a leaflin's tentacle.
So I don't know why you're getting cheeky.
How is this not seeing me?
It's so vague.
Well, their arguments could be made.
I can't think of anything.
Are we, okay.
We're just walking away.
The Eye of Sauron Tower.
Yeah.
I couldn't think.
I was like, where's that madness coming from?
Nothing's attacking me.
I am apparently getting life or something.
I don't know.
Reflexes.
Oh, I like that.
I need to look up all the words that go R-E.
And then, like, insert fling into it, basically.
Oh, me goes.
Well, I think there may be a painting in a shack here.
Maybe.
I could be a terrible mistaken.
I can't remember.
It may be some other thing.
Oh, this is the Madness Village.
I don't know.
And it's nothing fun.
I hate this section so much.
I mean, we don't have to hurt the eye.
We don't have to hurt the eye of Sauron, so we should be okay.
Where's the other replay?
Is he ahead?
Have we lost the other replay?
I don't see him.
I'm trying to wrangle my children.
Don't he put collars and leashes on you?
Where are you?
Are you lost?
Am I going crazy and he's there?
I'll give you just spread waiting.
Hold on.
I'll wait right here.
I don't know where the heck he is.
Oh, he's down there.
Oh, you made it.
Okay.
We found you.
What are you?
What even is that?
Is that that dragon spear that does that thing on the snake?
What is your fit?
How do you get giffy or looking every time we see you?
Oh, my goodness.
You look like an elf.
Okay, let's keep going.
Let's keep going.
Oh, you got more clothes.
How do you swap a pearl so quickly?
How do you know?
Maybe you've got it.
Or maybe you're just MLG at this game.
MLG inventory.
Church of inhibition.
We'll definitely go do none of that around here.
Touch.
Great.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
What's in the lady's arm?
She didn't make it.
Are you alive?
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, it's my wedding cloak.
I think I used to marry Rihanna.
No, Rihanna.
I know it's another maiden, but the maidens are good, but we don't know this one.
Okay, let's go next.
The invader needs to leave real quick.
The Church of Innovations.
I thought we were going to do another prayer again.
Wait, is this a fight?
The Minish Cap NPV, honestly.
Oh, no.
I need to fight on my own.
I'm so brave.
I can do it.
I'm going to sit right here.
You should summon in now.
Even with reeflings with me?
Can reeflings do the honors on spit-roof- reeflings?
Spit-roost this man.
Reeflings?
Get out and spit-roost this man, won't you?
Where?
Here.
Did I walk back up to the church again?
Okay, yeah.
Here he is.
Reeflings destroy this man.
Unless I do it for you.
Yeah, yeah, nice fight.
Okay, that was perfect.
Couldn't have asked for a better thingy.
I've got a fingerprint.
Great.
Did you win for her?
All right, how do I get an evil reefling in again?
Is evil reefling at the church?
Wait, spit-roost that man, maybe.
Oh, sorry, spit-roost that woman.
Okay, let's see.
Sorry, but we chairs go again.
Whoa, you scared me doing that.
I thought we were reinvading that woman.
Do I need a tingling?
No, I don't need a tingling.
No enemy reefling?
Oh, where are we?
I don't even know where we are.
We're in the church of inhibition.
If an enemy reefling wants to be naughty, naughty.
Are you burying?
Or do you have to go?
Or are you just burying in general?
I have-hello?
Hey!
Hi!
I have-I have yippee!
That is a-did you even get any lift with that?
Yeah, I really did not get that high up their lap.
Oh, enemy reefling.
Okay, we're safe to get again.
We need not to worry for we are safe.
That had big colon ambulance, but not for me.
Okay.
Wait, you didn't come in?
Oh!
I'm unable to summon you.
Whoa!
Am I being-am I losing it?
This schizophrenia is kicking in.
It's not looking good.
Are we being invaded?
I think they both disappear.
It gave me an error.
I think you're invaded.
No, reeflings.
I need to kill her.
I need to pretend to be a piece of furniture.
I think I am being invaded.
I can't see anyone's thing.
Ah, same.
So...
Oh!
I heard it!
Sorry, someone's getting-getting right now.
I do not want to be fricking dumb.
Wait, turn into furniture.
Chair.
Table.
Elden Ring knew my funny prank and said no.
Oh no, are you doing a prank?
Okay.
I'm going to test-
I'm going to test the tea.
Okay.
Are you doing this?
No.
Okay, I'm having some water first though.
Hydration check, please.
A reefling.
Wait, did I have that?
Did I even have that?
Or did I not pick it up?
I don't really know what it is.
This?
No, I didn't pick it up.
Oh, it's for you.
Good night, rest well, both of you.
Oh, I've not blessed you.
Okay, hold on.
Let me bless you.
Do you want to come over as well to be blessed?
I can't even roll out the statue.
Now I'm getting mad to do-
I was going to say, did you want me to do it on the crystals?
I think that might be out of my expertise range.
Perfect.
Where are we heading to next?
Do you know where you're taking me?
Does anyone know?
Oh, I just straight up killed this one.
Sorry, reefling.
It wasn't supposed to be like that.
But he went out doing what he wanted.
That'd be pretty painful.
Oh, yeah.
Did you not see the fake taxi?
I would take the guy, like, tried to jump on the car
and slide in,
but he, like, completely messed up
and, like, really hurt himself.
Crystals might be stretching it,
literally, and figuratively.
Just no one know where we're going.
Oh, hold on.
Let me open up the map.
Oh, I can't because the game thinks I'm fighting.
I'm not fighting reefling.
I can't even open up the map to see where we're going.
I'll let you go.
I don't think there is anywhere to go here.
You've got to move.
Hmm.
Is that everything I can pick up?
I've sold in, I guess.
We're going back to the DLC.
No.
I don't think I saw that one.
Oh.
Oh, no.
You didn't have to go, though.
Is that everything?
Um, we would have to do a campaign to get up on top.
I think.
And we did all of that down there.
Caleb has one or two.
Did we do Caleb?
Not the top part of Caleb, we haven't.
Do I have all four talisman slots?
No, I only have the two.
The crotch bone is the strongest bone on the body for a reason.
And that reason is strong, eh?
Stop.
That's so good.
I thought you were actually going to educate us there.
I'm like, yeah, yeah.
What is it?
I don't.
I only have two talisman.
I can't recall how to unlock more.
Go to the church where you find the physics.
There's a teleporter behind it.
Um, yeah, I know exactly what church you're talking about.
It takes you to the top of the Caleb.
Wait, that remains.
I don't know if I should go and then.
Talk to the finger lady at the round table and she gives you one.
Okay.
We go talk to the lady at the round table.
Am I listening to that instruction?
How does it feel being able to instruct me to do stuff?
Does it?
Oh, hello.
I don't believe we've met.
We haven't.
I don't know you.
I'm taking a sipping tin of pee.
What are you on about?
Honestly.
Oh, it's you.
Hello.
Oh, she levels up.
Spirations.
I recognize.
My name is Roderica.
I should have told you sooner.
Isn't this place impressive?
Where the domes for all the little in control.
Covert quarters of the two fingers.
Whip.
Did you know that women actually have 206 bones in their bodies?
Would they like another one?
Oh, wait.
Oh, what?
Snow flakes.
Relax.
It's called a joke.
Right.
What am I to do?
I'm still looking for my own purpose.
Okay.
What am I doing here?
I'm talking to the furled fingers.
I'm going to get your fingers.
Your fingers.
I just remembered that right now.
Wait.
No.
Wrong area.
Furled fingers up here.
The two fingers.
Hiya.
America.
Oh, you don't want to interact with my thing.
I had my doubts.
But my look at you.
Can you even see me?
I've only once before have I seen two great runes together.
Look there.
The fingers shudder with exuberance.
Fine work, brave tarnished.
The greater will is pleased.
You have earned the right to become Elden Lord.
Oh.
Now, seek the Earth Tree and an audience with Queen Marica
to become Elden Lord and restore the Golden Order.
We can do that.
Farewell.
Why?
Oh, thank you, darling.
Go forth.
Become Elden Lord.
I like Elden Ring the Bushkush.
She's very nice.
Thank you, Elden Ring the Bushkush.
Hmm.
Raise this equipment loads.
Raise this holy tack but Lord's Damage Mediation.
Raise this attack power after a critical hit.
I mean, where are you?
Constantly attract enemy aggression.
Why would you want that?
Or should I put that on so you guys can just go crazy on any boss?
Do you guys use that?
Is that why he's so...
Whenever we do a boss, it's like such a swampy boss.
With the power of remembrance menu,
you can draw out the power of remembrance magic.
Once that power is claimed, it will be lost.
I'll just leave it.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Teehee.
Teehee, sorry.
The reflings make all the decisions for me.
Teehee, thank you for the Talisman pouch.
So, yeah!
Um...
Uh, right.
Will we go get spoken down upon by Gideon?
Are you ok mate? Jees.
You've received the wisdom of the two fingers.
Have you not?
Yeah.
Then I bid you welcome
As a true member of the Round Table.
Right.
I am known as Gideon Othnir.
As a tarnist who wishes to stand before the Elden Ring
and become health and lord I am accumulating knowledge to be all-knowing you now belong to a
select group of fellows as such I ask that you remain constant you'll be after more great rooms
now a then as your fellow allow me to the inheritors of the great rooms the shark bearers we have
the round table know the location of five of them including the one you defeated godric the
grafted lord of storm there yes general redan yes fought millennia and her rot to a stand still
in the calid wilds pray to rica lord of the volcano manner of mountain that's a snake
the grace given veiled monarch and lord of lame del and renala queen of the full moon
okay he actually do be kind of no one though hold on a minute hi warrior I just want to check
up when you could you like yes I wonder if you've met my foster father he's in his study the room
inches guarding just over there if you haven't already I advise you introduce yourself father
is a leader of the round table I'm sure talking to him will be worth your while wait you didn't
adopt a warrior here is he's still guarding I wonder if you're wall of her
man has that convey to us go back to the third church I'm a rack as I once you've done here
I think we're spoken to everyone we can at this point in time I don't want to upgrade weapons yet
because I mean you need us we can make you super star send us dm on how you take over the
stream of fear stop that's funny as fuck but what the fuck
what the fuck is this song are you the one that says are you the one that messages me and says
save the blue one
um are you the one who messages me save the blue one be honest right now thank you for the tip
do you see there that's fucking hilarious son is ever just lay out your arms
oh he's starting to lose it sombersome I don't even have one what does that even mean
I think he he's having a week ago I think he's having a week ago and he's saying
he's pretending to be a company and the company's like you need us oh wait no sorry we need you to
save the company because sometimes companies can put themselves in a little bit of do do
and it's kind of it's kind of hard to get out of it because when people think of like a company
they think of like this entity sorry where am I to go uh save the blue one I need contact
there's a blue one that recently debuted I'm I'm apparently to save her
not in Caleb but right before this one
this one smoldering not in Caleb but right before it ah gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta
there's the blue one I uh I think I think it's a muming I think uh it is a little tee he funny
oh wait if I sit down am I gonna get like a billion in new flasks yeah increase
and make more and make more no but I do have more flasks though okay my flasks are actually
gonna heal me now feels good man so they're more potent which I'm really happy about
oh it's fun ah wait wait hold on hold on there's one more allocate flask charge okay no I don't
need magic so I don't need to do anything with that uh talk to Milena something new with Milena
I said we can echoes linger here words of queen marica who vanished long ago if you wish I will
share them with you sure very well in marica's own words my lord and thy warriors I divest each of
thee of thy grace with thine eyes dimmed he will be driven from the lands between he will wage war
in a land of far where you will live I totally understand and die well perhaps that might serve
you in you of a maiden's guidance you're my maiden makes wonders physique okay I want to put together
restores HP steadily restores HP this domino enhances charge attacks significantly negates
damaged damage and oh I'll just do health I guess so now I have extra extra heal
you've hardly I remember you and then enemy refling there's only one enemy right now
oh
I hear a horn
can someone's follow her through a portal wait am I about to spawn you then to not do anything
for a millisecond
oh you have like every item unlocked seriously
are you coming to lie down you don't want flaps do you have lie down
you do have lie down all right I need a big running start for this one you ready
take a deep breath okay there we go
all done
I had to do a running start on that one uh where are we heading
follow the lake follow the lake what the heck is that
we're not to be confused with the hit anime monster misumi
that was the most ridiculous anime was gonna happen
the uh the theme for monster misumi really uh pushing the upper oh no
oh
this is so hidden you're gonna have to do
sponges in only a booties out I don't even know where I'm going
you never saw monster misumi long story short solo protagonist
adds animal girls to his harem and one of them lays an egg and her name's pappy and I love her
hey I was so frustrated during that episode though oh my god wait a minute yeah I knew this
was where I thought it was oh my god is there even a save point is there a save point to the
right in here if my brain is the guy gonna attack me
don't wake the beast behind us and hopefully this guy doesn't attack either
it awoken many to lamia I suspect many of the lamia is more because of that
you don't fight me when I first talked to you right no you only go a bit crazy later on
I don't have a death route okay he doesn't talk to me until I have a death route
I'm scared of that gargoyle outside is this can I get you guys to come in
okay I can
pappy best girl oh the freaking episode that pappy lays an egg in is so frustrating
it was like so some guys like trying to exploit her for like being different type thing
and like the protagonist wouldn't just kick him out I'm like brav I remember being so freaking
frustrated being like just kick him out like I know it's an anime plot and there has to be like some
give or give or pull give or pull or whatever in the plot I just remember I'm on a PC you can
come join me on PC I'm playing controller because I don't play mouse and keyboard
ready
steady need to need a little wind up just to really get it going good
yeah I've been blessed I like how the music gets all intense and I was like no no you don't
understand I'm popping them see he was trying to sell that material hook your head
oh I just frustrated maybe are you going are you going for it oops
where so you didn't mean that yeah I'm watching you are you are you going for it
wait he doesn't get activated until what until I whack him
are you gonna whack him first or do you don't want to whack him at all
oh he doesn't interact if you don't and oh it's just news to me I thought he always like came out
swinging strange he doesn't attack if you don't attack I think pretty much all the other episodes
resulted yeah either claim to film documentary but they wanted to all right that sounds more
like we thought make me extra we got another flask how many flasks I have I have well I have seven
eight and I'll wonder
but yeah not monster misumi's was kind of like a goofy
although I could have sworn about the dvd collection and there's like a hidden scene with
pappy at the doctor or something and I remember being pretty shocked but it was because I had
never seen like that kind of stuff before I don't know anything
I can't remember if he showed her chest or not
are we missing raid reefing right he's coming he's just he needs a moment to catch up his
little legs are trying it's not fair because you guys are technically on eight are you shadow
stepping you are okay no wonder
wait so it's not the anim an anime but uh I I think it's called itchy if it like
kind of blurs the line not maybe
you hear that oh god it's going to be easy
oh wait I've got the other cord out
ow ow ow it burns it burns it burns okay my flasks actually heal so much
who said fight a dragon on a bridge I have to admit this feels very one-sided
I can't even get to the enemy and tame
okay the wacky little leg I'm doing a hundred pair swing I'm helping I'm helping
I promise I'm not going to make it I'm really not going to make it if I'm doing stuff like that
hold on two clasping on people I'm complete and I'm here literally for 500 damage on this rubbish
wait can I summon a new reason at that point that's down here I may be able to can I summon
a mid fight hold on excuse me I you'll do feign refling you'll do feign mommy's gonna get back
up you you're doing great sweetie keep it up I'm just gonna get some back up darling
I'm almost there I'm just a wee bit out of stamina okay maybe this is everything that can help
can you come back in then you come and you come and you come come help help help help
I can get oh you go so long
is there summon in I don't want to go back in the face if I mess it up
at the summon DCs I got this are you tape is that you are you taping midstream
mid fight mid boss fey cute support mommy look mommy got back up you can do it refling
you're just casting spells to yourself like we're coming we're coming
it's just taking an awful long time to get there not gonna lie I'm tired just thinking about it
come on
okay we're gonna take your time because we don't know how quickly aggro swaps and we're gonna
mess it up that's fine look any damage is good damage a whole hundred and fifteen damage
okay okay we're gang violence we're gang okay okay we're gonna do it we're gonna do it we're
just getting to be a little you know a little move around
oh smoke the destroyer apparently over here
I'm helping I'm helping fail this I will be
wow why is magic so strong that magic felt like it was good is there anything that's even
resistant to magic at all? I still move around every day you were so brave in the fight you
don't need to move for it all okay let's go grab some refling now that we've done that
we don't need to worry about any d spawn you have 19 strength how come how does it come that you
don't do any damage I think my weapon's like next to useless is my guess I think I don't I'm
I'm I'm slightly unsure yeah after I've made a movie I'm sure yeah okay here we go
wait you can come in
I think it may be bedtime soon for us you know that we can or do you want me to go for the
10 the full 12 hours or 11 hours and 55 minutes since the vault literally explodes at that mark
range we have something to prove we do up to you I'm here for the rage
exhausted I'm listening in the same voice all day I think if you want to sleep you can't sleep
hmm I think I'm gonna have to change my sleeping time it's the only problem
what I'm needing to do is basically sleep as soon as I finish stream and then that means I'm awake
and I can record like ASMR and edit a couple of hours before I stream I think I'm gonna have to
do it like that because um because the current way I'm doing it is I wake up before stream but
I'm so tired after stream so I think I just need to do all my work before stream that's the best thing
you lying down got a second layer down here you are yawning maybe sleeping might be on my
person a tune hope make sure you're full mass because if you're semi I'm gonna do something
that's really gonna hurt we should all go get that whimper coconut
he was semi oh that's why he took some damage yeah did you know your pinches can actually
break that's just terrible I suppose yeah I don't even know how you fix that can you even put it
in a cast I don't think so no impress me then literally it's so funny that we cooked enough
why wait sorry I always forget to to have my weapon oh was that full mass
I'm even dead in it oh oh you sound like those those vain birdie
there's no bone it's just muscle potentially
I feel like you I don't even how do you manage that it's a muscle
can in theory could a reefing cling flap so hard he'd hurt himself
whoa whoa
that brani beam she's
holy moly magic
magic okay as I'm saying I was really interrupted
literally if we can keep like if we can keep the boss off of like the magic player I think that's
like the perfect job you have what I knew you can't whimper after you want to pay
opaline hard tear storm barred cracked here these are elements I think next part solo go behind
the tree go behind the tree come on torrent there's something behind this tree we have to explore
is it cavern
no oh
blue stone
did the rager reefing do that
oh sorry I missed it
wow
that's kind of scary where are we
there's a grease back down here to the left
eat get the grass here in some sorry sorry somewhere around here to the left
huh
um sorry I'm looking out for something
towards oh I was perfectly hidden from sight
I'm gonna rest because I need to reset my things oh no the first sleepy dragon
I didn't I kind of want to leave the dragon he doesn't hurt me or anything
and he doesn't mean any harm he just wanted to sleep
okay I can't level up that's fine do I want anything new here
temporary boost or damage make attack more likely to break enemy's dance move
that honestly seems pretty good for my 200 build instead of the
deadly restores I mean am I even gonna remember to use it sure probably not
probably not like there's no way okay uh sniffling were you my enemy a second ago
ah I'm getting all turned around wait like anything coming
wow I'm so sorry if I go over you but you've not been in recently I got a bit confused
come puzzle to talk to me like I've been I've been memeing for 10 hours now let me make mistakes
wow that wants to put me asleep like that nice like orange hue
but you can become we can believe the dragon kills the dragon to run
are you covering are we doing the blessing you want blessing okay you want blessing
okay you get sleepy tame blessing so I do I do it right above you
sleepy tame blessing
and then press
what is this
it's frost
if you're eating a tanker
I need to go to bed enjoy the rest of the stream rest well
I'll try and do a bit more I actually don't know what we're doing to be honest
lead the way we flings I'm really unsure but tomorrow I think we'll definitely get into the
meat of the DLC so I guess today was just a speed run of getting set up for it which I'm happy with
because I did want to do a fresh save I think tomorrow we actually do the DLC
but for now we're just going to try and level up and get ready I see a level up I'm already leveled
up can we go down are you hurting those
can I jump down here it's kind of an emergency can I jump down here
uh you guys aren't budging which makes me think no
uh oh no this can't be uh there's two dragons activated on in three flings what do we do
did we go for it
oh I didn't even see like one here
yes
okay I need to join the fight I need to join the fight join the fight
you need to help you need to help okay stop walking onto random body parts are you supposed to hit
ah I wish I didn't do that I'm helping I'm helping I'm getting crushed but I'm still helping
okay that wasn't as bad I thought I was going to be like terrible
are you done are you done no he's no he's bitten
okay
these parts jump on in the way
oh
yeah I think you guys are going to see this one
wait well Torrent where am I supposed to go back down there
can I hear another dragon in the distance
I can he's aggro to us
what I did what did you
what are you doing oh
you have full distance on
that's strange I've never seen that before there's a big drying mother dragon
oh okay use torrent to raid down the wind down down the wind with torrent
oh no no no no no no torrent I mean I guess
that could have gone terribly wrong torrent and I hope you know that
okay I see a church
the music is incredibly unsettling in this area and I'm not going to pretend otherwise
uh what are this
was that supposed to oh my god there's a save station which will reset the enemies
save station
can I get off the horse and reset reset reset reset so the enemies don't kill me
sit down sit down sit down sit down so the enemies don't kill me
wow okay we're safe
are you all right hen you didn't sound that good are you all right wee man
hold on let me get the refunds in first though they'll make you feel better
they'll make you feel better wow I need to get them
we'll make you feel better we'll get you a new arm and everything it's in a castle though for some reason
that's a safety go to of the four oh wait I need to move
I'm currently fighting a really cool boss in the dlc so I wish I could help you
I mean if you're ahead in the dlc it's probably better because you can then help me
uh
okay did we start her quest that we
who's there well it matters not if you are wise you will leave immediately
my flesh rides with scarlet rot it is a curse not to be meddled with by man
if you are wise you are flesh rides you are wise my flesh good thing I'm not wise
okay wait I'm to teleport away it was really fun Gigi's I enjoyed it I wrote to see
uh there isn't much more useful stuff in Kayla go
to fit of the four bell freeze up here yeah uh I may have to summon you in guys I'm very sorry
I need to teleport and I can't teleport if you guys are here I'm sorry my beloved
aw my leafling what are you when we can't go in foods too far unless there's something else you
want to show me I just get for the rotisserie where are you going is there something I'm missing
what are you doing
huh where are you going
use the severed finger feet
I should have saw that coming shouldn't uh
why is there bowling balls spawning on a hill we didn't tamp in bowling though
are you taking me to a grave site uh uh mark of grace
is that bowling ball going to spawn again
well the answer is yes but we're okay question mark
wow this is chaos I'm trying to go over the freaking bowling ball oh okay there's a mark of grace
oh I was almost going to jump down there to hurt my health bar
there's a gold seed in this city
no come back up
says the leafling
don't do that don't do that what the heck whoa what the heck I'm just trying to explore
she's
where's other leafling are you here other leaflings coming I I will come on the bark of the tree
I'm very oh I see it how did I get down there wow
okay here well the tree
oh okay okay it's okay oh you made it too okay we all made it we all made it that's a good
deal that was incredibly dangerous and silly what we just said but we did it okay
okay I go through this door
look at the check the fit
tentacles on my head oh there is eye holes they actually made eye holes
off connection error
uh the servers
tend to teleport now you got the IMG need okay Lucaria no not Lucaria
footed the bell fouries
there could have been three fouries but there was only four
and then call everything
oh really time to answer mommy
to edge for the weapon
the smithing guy
this game like hard air to play I mean
if you got refueling to carry you through the entirety of every single section of the game
it's all right
to EG and EG up here
this is a hostile jellyfish are they back let's play
is everything about the grace oh okay sorry my apologies
okay safety first at the grace I thought it was like a quick thing that was like only to send
me right away
let me go
have an enemy refling
uh I'll have one good
wow look at the back
I think there was like
some
I think only one good refling or one bad refling
I think I tired everyone out with my dream
imagine if someone was threatening to me creep right now maybe get me people
oh it didn't work odd I think the servers might be freaking just an ankle bit
there's also different gimmicks that you can
speaking of things breaking I'm about to have a coughing fit if I don't hide
the movement is the camera it's the camera angle
huh is there another refling Hayden
oh there is a refling Hayden
starting if you need something just hold or I can come back just feel
compared or upgrade my weapons right now I do have refling scatting me
aww he's sitting still here he should be here in supply
wait what did I not come you in sorry someone you in
I don't know what this for me where you put you Hayden something why you give me
flowers for something I'm going ever to get through before kayaking I can sleep after
these hangouts bro you're gonna be exhausted are you sure you don't want to quit catnapping
ready are you standing are you taking it like a man
I think you're taking it like a man are you looking through your emotes right now
oh you're looking through your emotes okay you're all taking it like men
isn't this requires a big wind up hold on let me just let me just right let me just angle it
correctly don't want anyone getting hurt in this uh little arrangement we've got going on
hold on thank you you're right thank you for coming join uh coming to member
since they're joining membership but it's becoming a member welcome to the membership here thank you
very much for the uh appreciate it oh you're offering me stuff oh this is to craft oh I can't
do crafting right now because the game thinks I'm in a fight but yes ear mech thank you
not the lamb the lamb isn't doing any well I guess they roll and hurt but they don't hurt too much
I don't know how you guys are hanging literally I'm ready to pass out I already know I'm gonna
try and flip flip my sleeve so I sleep right after stream and then I can do work when I leave off
that night shift life helps and hurts me chat is the reflection of a streamer
that's my word that word I'm not allowed to say
oh that burn arc the reefing endurance finally passed
like I like being able to say that yeah I'm a cheeky endurance viewer
well it may I get fucking tired too
wow that's a lot of enemies up ahead does someone have like an eoe magic spell or fun
oh it's a chariot that's why
okay hold on why
oh let's forget that
not magic
oh you can't open it if the guys are still moving the carriage
interesting I think it would be funny if you could like rob them without them knowing
I feel like we're putting them out of their misery because we look at literally how they're
it goes through them sorry we're putting these guys out of their misery sometimes it's time to
move
so on and start working five words before you stream until you move to the phone when you
need to move around oh my gosh I mean it's going to be very weird when my dad comes over
because the streams are literally going to be like what I consider like a regular stream time
um are you good
just infinite horse you okay you give the horse a little kiss you make him feel better
shrodinger's horse he's neither dead or alive because he doesn't need to move
oh are you scared of the horse
he's just chillin yeah like it's going to be so weird being like a normal streamer like
two ever streams four ever streams what what am I supposed to do
so I need my background noise at work hopefully I make more tasks like on that one
and just like come out with like the most inappropriate thing
ever oh I'll completely miss that no one saw that
no one saw that I was so embarrassed for no reason
I'm gonna hear them horses doing mannequin challenge I remember that
ASMR streams during work you'll have more time to work on your ASMR collabs I suppose
yeah basically if I flip my sleep on purpose I can get so much stuff done before stream starts
and then also the fun part about that is I can start stream and be like I did this and this and
this and this and you've got this to look forward to whereas now it's like I've got all of this to do
after which is like causing a lot of yes not major issues like issues for me
because I'm supposed to do the ASMR audio like the audio upload today but I'm gonna be honest
I think it'll be tomorrow but I think reeflings are like super understanding if it's like a day late
all right well I think I think everyone like understand whereas if I flip my sleep now wow
if I flip stop if I flipped my sleep now I would be able to do it since I wake up and like guarantee
the fails like they're uploaded and I'll be like all the fail ups you know uploads at 9am my time
like it's there it's waiting to go I am getting tired but I can do it I can do it wait what about
what about the future in audio uh it's gonna be tomorrow I think instead of today is that okay
I'm not really like that I'm not allowed to do that
unacceptable unsubscribe unless you're reported honestly most inconsistent streamer streamer
content crew oh hello you're that big giant that crap hello uh am I talking to your coach right now
hold on
hmm it's only been a few hours since your last ink what about you
you
oh you need to get those numbers up that's been two days come on you don't want to be pennant
EG hi EG
an old codger who refuses to retire is running check your shop so here perhaps you'd like a display
yes purchase oh but what one or all of them there's all of them
um
oh these are infinite
ish
who did it not snare who's in video did I sniff you I think I sniffed you who didn't ask
no but uh is it you
right now you're doing it right no refling I can smell it on you
geez Katztran even failed reflens in the dlc spot yay
man's they even ink and toys per day shocking okay no I ask him to strengthen me I can't do
this in multiplayer what do you mean I can't do in multi today watch out there when I'm absorbed
in my smithing I lose sights of all else if you come too close I'm up to cause you harm
I am after all terribly large compared to you don't know how hard it is not to break anything
while I look because you're a giant
okay I what are those you got peanuts a weapon did I upgrade my weapon or do I not need to
gentle giant are we not doing the castle am I upgrading my weaponry or I'm taking cues from
you guys you guys are controlling the stream you're telling the streamer what to do not the other
way around we uh we appreciate back back see and then these parts surrounding parts upgrade and
then do the castle okay wait something so I can't upgrade but okay uh these things that I can kindly
ask you to leave and then I'll summon you at that grace that's over there
and then I'll get uh oh no I keep fighting yonza keep fighting on something else
strength
two three four and I can't do any more but that like doubles my damage I think that I do with this
okay we're going to storm the castle
we already have a we actually well some here I can craft these no no that one this one
give me them all I need lots for my oh wait can you guys summon in here
so I need the eps the eps we appreciate the back
I don't think I can spawn you guys in here but possibly oh wait no I heard that
it really takes a whole second to show up
the eps soldier of them all
oh
oh no wait no that looks fine may just look like nothing happened
they're only used for multi so craft away okay there's nothing else
I'm becoming an eps soldier I don't know if I'm gonna make it I'm not gonna make it read
links I'm gonna make it a little bit but I'm not gonna make it
oh is that thunderclap you on thunderclap
you don't have to ask me right are you making me cool you try to wake me up
what is oh is this picking me asleep oh I wish I would like curl up in a little bowl
okay now you go to sleep because I know what I want to do
no I'm sorry sorry don't cover okay you ready for your ceremony to convince
that's just commencement uh oh I can do a gravity run up this thing because I've
got a rock so I can jump from awful right you ready tell you oh it oh it didn't work hold on hold
on let me try again hold on hold on hold on run all the way to the edge and then ultimate
oh okay that was pretty good that was a pretty good uh that was a height advantage
go to bed I know but then I'm like I'm just like looking at the clock
what how long have I been streaming for is that you
that it's not you okay let's run run make it to the castle do whatever you need to do
evasive maneuvers serpentine serpentine we can do it we can do it just avoid like everything
how are we supposed to successfully avoid that is it just random how are you supposed to look
up and know it's coming you don't something go to the side oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god who freaking it's not a very welcoming castle this is how you welcome guests I'm already
out of stamina oh wow wow
just keep running literally it's a lot easier on torrent to be fair
can they hurt me at the door no they can't
it's been 10 and a half hours okay uh but see when it when it's like oh it's been 10 and a half
hours it's like well I might as well just keep going like why not just make it the 11
11 hours 55 you know we're huddling we're we're we're playing Chinese whispers okay my sentence is
we flings are cute pass it on
he didn't even do he didn't know what to say so he went
this game trip it here it's a soul's oh wait there's fat there's hands there's hands there's
lots of hands that grab you and stuff be careful that's quite literally what I was thinking of
there's so many hands that grab and squeeze you oh yucky oh I don't like that that's terrifying
you are not gaining for 30 minutes is that a challenge
careful you might just you might just put fuel in this fire saying stuff like that oh I see the hands
wow there's a wee baby one there
okay they're relatively weak that's what I like to see I don't want to I don't want to see none else
wow
okay we're doing it we're doing it your body will thank you I'll I'm gonna try and swap
my sleep I think I've decided on it I've been thinking about it for a few days I've
never been able to do it but I think I've decided no oh do you want another ceremony again oh do you
want to give a ceremony what does this refling want to teach us uh we'll have to name it just do
some emotes and I'll try and read together we are gathered here right at this very altar
uh wait you want me to do it you want me to do sir oh there's an item sorry there's an item my bad
I thought you were straight up wanted to play a ceremony sorry we are gathered here
reflings here you hear you we are gathered for the rebirth of the Elden Ring Run together we
will destroy the DLC and do everything within our power in order to help us all win because this is
a group effort yippee uh to have an emote to close up the ceremony and my emote to close up the
ceremony thank you thank you everyone come on come on to the ceremony okay let's go
oh you've given me oh oh I got tipped I got the church tip full went around and I got two heroes
runs from my works hey give it a go I can almost change back schedule yeah I'll try and sleep after
then when I wake up I do a zero days more then I do my editing
gonna send some stuff off to the editors and then I can actually upload my short
I hear them
what do you mean to was ganging off on him was it enough oh they like spawn after you woke up
wow I missed sorry whoa I think I made him hit the wall
her
oh oh I was I'm trying to whack a ward spell
um yeah you deserve that oh it's a lift
you raise me are you scared of heights per refland
this is one of my favorite areas in the the magic locations
are you a magic lover this looks like a boss fight it's so big uh let's not
and there's America thing there okay I have the seat I repeat replays I have the seed
uh what's the boss fight because this is all good over here there's a statue of respawnation
I couldn't make it past the first boss in this game the horse
you're you can skip the horse and cheat see doodle it's okay I cheat see doodle everything
um I think I think the first time I did it I just got a sword and I just used to farm the
same place over and over until I got too over leveled for the area and could finally do it
oh why are we moaning over here
okay oh oh hold on sorry women moment my legs aren't as long as yours
just needs to get on over uh okay we did it
that's good to know it literally did not feel bad this is my first ever souls game
and yeah why are you covering why would you be scared no need to cover I'm not gonna bite you
I got glints don't stop
gentle oh you don't wake them up
I think we're safe and we can just lay it down to the end
oh
are we safe
oh no I rude hey you can't come past the wall oh no oh no there's a there's a
boss wait here I can't remember what happens so
can you come in now oh thank god
what are the attacks okay that was quite a charged up one
am I actually doing decent damage for once or is that reeflings are old enough
no I think I'm actually working for now because I upgraded the weapon I should have a bit of a
meat in black so okay thanks a lot I got I gotta level up to that hey Johnny how's it going it's
going good we've gone back to the base game just to try and help me level up a bit better
hi we think that helped me uh sorceries and incantation aren't we a little late into the game
what we've had 10 hours of playtime aren't we a little late to be explaining mana and
sorceries and incantation or is it just because it's a location maybe it's because this is like
the magical world how do we do it oh no you guys come can't come here
hmm oh my god it's it's me and the girls is that mean where me and the girls are discussing
how to tease you guys mercilessly when we were doing debut all of us were like so stressed and
everything but so this is it came to like right how do we do it there were there was plans and play
there is uh stuff going on check your flasks I have eight and one and one
now that I've said that out loud I don't think that's what you were asking
I'm going to interact with this uh flasks I can add not on a full seed okay rude but I can add a
sacred tear so now that you're even more potent okay I definitely can't have you guys in here
because my things go actually look over here
uh Ranny's house is here
there's also a dragon oh there is it's outside is he already locked on to me
no he's not he's patrolling holy crap I thought he was already locked on to me
right I'm gonna look for a safe station
uh there's not much else is Ranny Atlas is the best place now oh right we don't have to do
um Ranny's quest sorry I would recommend uh uh
your alice aren't you abandoned coffin no where the heck is alice
no this is alice isn't it abandoned coffin
if you want to do Ranny you can do it no I'm gonna do DLC but I'm not I'm too weak
okay wait okay this is our you guys here
we've got an enemy weapon okay wait I need to bring in the good reefing first
so always forget bring in good reefing
and then bring in other good reefing if you show up
honestly this outfit's really cool sorry I think this is awesome as I said I just
realized the cloak gets wet when it's an Iranian location I have never noticed that before I'm
pretty sure my cloak isn't white usually the detail but someone please appreciate the detail of this
game oh there's a reefing did I have you in last time I don't think I've had you in
and then we have oh wait are you dressing me up again
what did you give me a graveyard cloak okay and then what else did you give me some sort of trousers
oh wow
oh I'm like the silver version of the red mask
right can I put on a hit okay that makes me look prettier
I like that I look good
well she's just like me for real a level 200 on the character
oh okay we do this slam I must bless you with ice slam before war
uh how do I do it again you guys want to lie down for us on come on it's jam to come and get this
clam come on and jam to come oh wait this is in here urge trees favor are you giving me a talisman
I had so much aoe are you giving me octopus head or you don't like it
what do you give me wait I can't put two on at one time
the game said no you're not allowed cannot cut talisman as an incompatible
one oh wow it doesn't really double stack man this isn't the finding of Isaac I think I got to
the secretary level 14 I don't know how high it will go okay are we ready on new marks oh wait
I've not got my weapon on I don't have my actual weapon on yeah the DLC so far is a lot of look
at how beautiful this place is now perish okay definitely quite glad the stream ended up being
get me ready for it stream instead of a although it is quite fun sending you guys into battle
that sounds so terrible but I like doing our pre pre-war ritual isn't there a dragon ahead I'm like
yeah in fact I'm like so good at remembering it's been a whole year and I remember it
why am I so smart I am I'm running away
whoa
oh my god look at his wings though oh this looks great
it's good to pray now there is no more dragon here at all I'm just making stuff up now
using her wreath links with cannon fodder and calling it wholesome
actually imagine how cute it is it's a boy disney that oh uh rival wreath link we're we're resting
at a healing station sorry give us one second rival wreath link
we're healing wait you got my sword how did you get my sword
it is my sword
okay we're ready
I'm level 140 and it took me like three and a half hours to take all 18 inches
of
what did I what did you just get me to say what did he say
I don't know where you're going with that uh excuse me let's what did he say
mesmer is a boss they release an 18 inch figure of them oh yeah didn't they not advertise it
really weirdly it was like you can get your 18 inches too and everyone was like what was that
them I think it was them okay we're going down here I mean that's not the beef limb of the light
where's the reform of the light are my gun crazy no it's a it's an enemy
I'm losing hours that reason I am sorry I'm fighting the allegations I'm getting sleepy
there's no evidence or proof that I'm getting sleepy after almost 11 hours of streaming it's
not possible these other gunkies aren't true in fact I can disprove it because I'm still going
I'm feeling like a little warrior I'm still getting carried by the leaflings after all this time
I'm picking up the pieces of the soul so I can level up I'm still smurfing
I'm still smurfing I'll send a clip with proof if you want
of your 18 inches what did he say
really legend thank you for the tip a proof of war my brain does not have capacity to retain
any information so you guys are going to have to put in brackets what the context is and then
your response so I can keep up a memo just crossed my dice it says stroney is a good EP girl yeah I
believe it I believe it why are you talking I can clearly say that you are sleepy your
avatars eyes are half closed no what are you talking about I'm still playing away right now
the pilot of the mecha is not withering away she's just a wicked EP
we're heading now wow there's a map up ahead
Loki you are EP oh wait how are you EP at 3 p.m
I can't tell if this is a troll comment or not are you trolling me little replay
or are you hashtag serious
I'll be swimming for 11 hours that's why I'm sleepy
map found how are you guys trolling you know I'm gonna
still fucking just give me soap I had a bath yesterday had a big bath I'm joking I get EP
le5 oh okay okay I am super serious you believe that EP memo you just confirmed the allegation
no the algonquies aren't true if I was sleepy could I
recall the epic rap battle uh oh I don't know what one um let me think of one epic rap battle
begin uh the Marilyn Monroe one versus Cleopatra whose rap flows the dose
locus oh no that was absolutely terrible whose rap flow is the dopest Marilyn min roses
upthrown pharaohs like who opposes like moses I can't remember anything else oh god
that was really hard to come out with I'm not gonna lie
Leonardo versus oh Leonardo
I can't remember four scored over 65 years in the past
and then I'm a beard I can't remember any epic rap battles right now
uh I used to listen to the mario brothers versus the ones who made a plane
we're the right brothers and there can't be no other we don't want to listen to your
yeah she's gone staying all night in my donkey song I'm absolutely just mashing words together at
this point wow okay I don't know how we didn't take fall damage well there's a seal here I'm
about to take this if I touch it I mess up the game and she feel the epsi no I can do
them at the alphabet
a b c d e h i j i k l m n o j i j k wait a b c d e f g h h h i j k l m n o p is a j i is j i
whoa wait you're not a ghost you're real I thought you were a phantom the phantom note
but it's not the phantom note these are these aren't phatoms these are actually real enemies
a lot of enemies wait they just keep coming
can you do the alphabet without singing wait they do just keep coming oh fuck i'm i'm less than this
okay I think we stopped now
okay there we go
oh it's a a b c d e f g h i j k l m n o p q r s t u v w x y z wait I missed something
a b c d e f g h i j k l m n p p q r s t u v w x y z
what the fuck
I think I'm doing that wrong oh those guys creep me out I don't like them
is that a hidden tower I don't oh I can hear those things make noises and I don't like them
because they fill you with void I think it's cold if you get done by the void like fool you just
insta die doesn't matter you can hear um any tower can be a hidden tower
leave us alone we're just traveling reeflings we're ain't dropping no eaves sir
that was a quote from Samwise Gamgee from Lord of the Ring
well let's take this woman to bed and tuck her in
you know you want to plop me in bed after all this screaming
she's randomly recording Lord of the Ring she's done for it's ogre
well there's an end there's an end there's a merry old man beneath the old gray hill
and there they brought a beer so brown the man and the man himself came down one night to drink his
so oh hey diddle diddle played their wiefling on the fiddle a jake that would wake the dead
as he squeaked in his floating egg within this trend and the landlord tricked the man on the mid
oh it's this creepy woman village
oh i missed we all miss unanimously our bad chief our bad always in greece
starting with on the bright side if you go epitome now you can read into us or if you wait longer
wait is the zero still up
this land oh well i'm looking at the time it says i've only got one more hour to go so
wait we've got a split one's going up here is there a grace point up here
yeah she's still alive she's working hard she works hard for the money so hard for the money
okay uh and then we go back down
oh sorry i forget my flask is like super strong now i don't need to like chug them
like glug glug glug glug glug as there's an instrument as long as you have today three streams
back to back to back as they're the endurance uh the hidden endurance streamer actually and you
as long as she's happy that's the main thing
i've been fighting with the copyright system in azura azura actually sings
so well when you know how she just like her random humming and all of that
she actually sings so well she's uh got been caught by the copyright system who the
who's doing this who reveal yourself at once oh trebuchet's are back
another seed oh my god there's so many seeds here okay make sure you don't get hit by trebuchet though
right i think there's a safe station up here
i want to say there is oh no you're leading me this way sorry you're leading me this way
and there's something here and they're invented singing so they're actually just yanking it from
her so there's an instrument
hope her monetization stream went well i don't know what happened but i hope it was good and
she was having good time i don't even know what diddle she made she sent me like a little preview
like this is what the setup will be like because i was like please be super safe and please don't
show anything and please be this and please do that and she's like yeah don't worry i'll show you
and then she uh put a she'd made a little love heart with her hand when she showed me the preview
of the hand cam and i'm like oh how cute she's such a wee sweetheart on the phone
little roma boy oh no what's wrong he's covered in it's okay we won't hurt you
it's okay you don't have to be brave all the time
me damage bar is coming on i'm getting scared she's too good for you ships to handle she posted
the diddles on swear oh nicole tried it oh uh it's a very quick twitter and then i'll talk to myself
in a bit to the back
her stream was awesome oh i'm so glad she even did me
i wish i could have been there to annoy her and be like
and i want to request a new happy on the beach in the Bahamas i'd be like that's not doodle that's
a whole extra mission i'm like yeah you're right i'm sorry you're right i'm sorry
it's your profile pic wait did she like proper doodle at the wazoo i said to her you you might
need to be careful like kind of zoom in past something um but i would absolutely love to
see more doodle streams i'm probably gonna watch her monetization stream if i have time
uh because i i don't know about you guys i absolutely love doodle request streams i find
them like so adorable oh look it's a reefling putting me to bed look there it's you see my
sword pointing to us for real for real that's what you look like when you pull me to bed
uh anyway i'm a simp for a little doodle stream oh i got lightning ram
did you beat a ram up with lightning
um
sorry my brain's shutting down only i'm gonna pretend otherwise
running diagnostic three issues found critical failure in the butthole critical failure in the brain
i'm enjoying being a bit free unless i have to admit wait where's my third critical failure
oh there's a yes hello oh you're oh i just oh look look look look apparently
i'm
for a reefling right now nightly a reefling well yours uh where are we heading to next
i might confess a little bit to the tiredness slowly coming into me i don't remember feeling
as tired on other stuff on this and just wait you've got a torch that means i follow you if you've
got a torch but you know where it goes you both know where it goes
where's the other reefing i'm missing a reef i found the other reefing
i think the last years are in the realm of the giants so you'd have to clear marg yet to get there
if only i had some mlg pro reeflings
uh if only
truly
okay so then once all my flaws are not our level dot we shall do the dlc
and we'll see if we can go back to that guy that's absolutely well within us
at least i can heal no that's probably the biggest thing
i was gonna be mean in clip i am insent out of my face but i didn't ask you
on me did i say that
was she in kaolin uh yes we did kaolin we're now moving on to the giants
realm maybe
true you seem a lot more set up now than i did a few years
yes so maybe we could quickly sneak into the dlc just to see what's ahead of us
i can't remember even what we got stuck on and we're just getting walloped in general
oh
i think i'll grab that on the way
oh he's so tired
we're claiming the mountain plain well we're in a fight apparently
oh what's this
who or what why are we fighting oh it's you and for the reefling
whoa no it's not oh we're not bothering you so don't bother us how about that
i wonder what the originals games were like
is it the same development team
i would be curious i don't know if any franchises ever lasted like that even have the same developers
like on multiple editions it's sorry multiple renditions or storylines of the game unless it's
like indie owned that's probably the only instance 11 hours did you know memory loss is one of the
signs of insomnia just saying not really into anything yeah i don't have insomnia okay there
we can't progress because we're looting into a new area but i can see uh site ahead of me
you're thinking why why must they go
something maybe hunting us then look at the longer sword
it's so pointy as well that's dangerous good it's jaggy too so as well
i see them just summoning you then some
summon them
let's discover this and maybe let's upgrade into another class
if someone wins some day i have no idea what you're talking about
no i don't have insomnia i just i have bad
rest asleep at the moment just a little hmm so many things
but it will come down to tm oh we can talk to millenials
my lady spoken echoes of queen marica linger here as well
shall i share them with you yes please and marica's own words hear me demigods
my children beloved make of themselves that which he desire be it a lord be it a god
but should he fail to become awed at all you will be forsaken amounting only to sacrifices
so basically if you don't become something big you're gonna be meat for the tarnished
um curious there's a difficult boss up ahead
oh yeah if only i had some backup but who have i not had them you weren't in last thing no
where's panini in last time you're getting called panini
hi i'm getting delirious but we're gonna do it we're gonna oh i'm not had you in a hot second
either oh no there was a new one here sugar i don't know if that was someone who's not
being in for a while but thank you for your patience
at east we are all getting incredibly delirious at this stage i think however we're leveling
up my flasks and stuff so we can actually do the dlc area because we may or may not have got
absolutely whacked uh oh hydration check actually so i don't break my voice
wow what i dropped my voice
don't overdo it i've literally got 50 minutes i got less than 50 minutes now
okay and first we do our righteous ceremony should it have i got a run up i do have a wee
bit of a run up just a little one though oh good
i wish i could turn that thing so cool it almost like the base and it's like
okay where are we heading follow the stuff like
like
time to take a new one oh oh i didn't realize there was enemies all over here
jeez there's so many lovely flowers though i love it
who's that
who are you and who do you think you're talking to by an attitude like that
honestly being scared of a tarnish are you
honestly then you then it even be disrespectful the guy from the braided
up here i want medallion
greatly raises maximum stamina but come on
game team one point look at our sacrifice
oh good good good no i'm not yawning it's it's actually just an audio
a sensory process and issues oh there's another thing oh there's two golden seats here
that's pretty cool uh we're heading over here
i'm following the flame they're truly yawning simulation yeah it's just like because of the
whole hypnosis thing it probably sounds like yawning but i'm actually just straight up rewiring
your brain to do my bidding at any point in time um and i'm actually getting so good
that you can't even tell when i'm tapping into your cerebral cortex like i'm already in there
the reason why i'm telling you this right now is because you're not even going to remember
me telling you so any emotions that you feel of shock of despair there's no point because you're
you're not going to remember or feel it again in about 15 minutes time it's a relaxed battle cry
that's actually really creative is that why i'm watching you all day every day recently
i'm already in we're even done the hypnosis for you well i've done a little
someone really complimented my like asmr hypnosis i did by accident when i wasn't like yawning on it
whoa two golden seats i guess the game's like yeah you gonna need this touch three
stony keeps saying she hasn't done any hypnosis yet but that's all we remember truth is
we were hypnotized before debut are you clicking your fingers for hypnosis
okay we're a little bit against the clock so i'm gonna have to be good and get going
i get going and be good i think this is around the point when you need like six
beats for a plaster song
i don't know what she's on my head why do you think you're so selfless towards me huh
how are we playing why do you think you're so selfless to carry me through the game
carry me through of the stuff i want to explore the other reason
it's like we got in
a
i just did three really good
what is going on
i braped for one second and oh sorry sorry what is you i don't remember going against this
did you guys carry me through him last time
oh my goodness
i do not remember going against that
and a golden seat from him too
to hike this entire area is a gold mine
a golden seat mine
there's a pun there somewhere but it's not gonna work in zen structure of english
we didn't kill any of these yeah i don't even remember him
can't wait for more hypnosis
i think on the writing stream we're gonna get a lot of work done on the writing stream
but like good work not like boring work like the work you want to hear
hopefully it's not boring if it is obviously i don't have to do a stream like that again
i don't want to like bore you
you don't need every golden seat to max out class you need 30 to get 14
okay that's fair oh you got a 14 flat
right however we pick up the next and then we'll go back in the dlc and see what we're looking at
what the situation in hand is
because i don't know if it's going to be as bad as i remember
but maybe we go for smithing stones next or if we just focus and behave and see what happens
i'm not going that way
i'm never born as always a good thing
i feel like when i get sleepy though i ain't i ain't doing my best you know i ain't beating
everything out the way i should or like being a gift ball and coming up with like all my
my little tangents like disappear because my brain's like i'm too tired to even connect one
one real reference or something similar to what you've just read good night
wow
who's that is he just contemplating like we'll leave him to contemplate
make you thinking about jumping don't do it it gets better
oh
the battlefield wait are we just on a massive u-turn
i think we might have
the press giant
i almost killed that boss but he's still beating me up
maybe i should raid into your guys's games and be the fighter
although that'd be really hard to stream but it no
it's a wagon i remember
wagon
whoa and air since that attack
i'm gonna just keep running you turn to
wow
life has ups and downs you just have to remember the ups and downs
can't be good all the time okay fuck that i'm not even saying these guys i'm too scared i'm too
scared i'm just running
oh is there a painting in the shot or
or anything in the shot oh there's a trader i see him
hello is someone there yeah me customer yes well money money money money money
no
uh um you get me anything
i don't think so
thank you
hello little horsey i wish you could tell
really oh you do a great job
i'm working so hard oh the healing
and feel the healing and breathe
get this
score
oh
oh got it oh you don't like my little my little hip lamp look at that boom you're like that
come on that's cute where are we heading at
uh okay
the cookbooks are always worth it even for dumdums like me that don't cook
oh that's rude how are you even aim ball and i'm moving about the play
it's a quest time for later in the game oh i didn't know that
uh right jeez you're going really far ahead when you're gonna go out of bed
i just run past them all honestly some sections are like that actually this is controversial
and no one's gonna like it
uh do we have to make sure we don't freaking congle line into an arrow
hold on wait i might actually have to use my brain not to perish here
oh he's he's doing deforestation no no no that's the one that's the one mate
wait why are we skipping him
why are we skipping him is it better to do the arrow guys
wait arrow guys first question mark right arrow guy first because that's ridiculous
let me re let me get my stamina back and take this and that and this
he's going over
sorry okay i'm okay wow
uh sages cave has one in the altos
bless you thank you
oh sugar okay we have buffs we have buffs we have buffs
so
third guy can't even get ahead and he's getting staggered beyond belief
it's hard to tell him to listen at all that's the only
thing we're all ganging off on an enemy
that's right take it uh uh uh that's right take it uh uh look good look good
what do you mean we're super over leveled and shouldn't be surprised that we win these
phase don't mind don't ruin my buzz we're just having a goofy goober fun
i've torn on speed dial okay no there's a save station
gotta do the inside for the last palace man squad oh okay we're getting upgraded
okay do i get to summon or do i not get to summon those questions
oh we don't someone's here
okay i'm totally not supposed to a little bit but we'll be nice and quiet
so
no enemies locked on
oh
he's very quiet here's an author
he's gonna pick this up clearly yeah i would like to call in the reef lens robin in my face
i think we're in trouble
we can't go back
all right there's a few enemies let's just keep our going can't call torrent because that would be too easy
no they don't go there
oh my god be laying in it be laying in it
okay we're safe
i'm gonna go like we're making dinner okay continue keeping moments safe
don't burn yourself making sure it's so dangerous
archive yourself when you're talking to this one no go to
this is the castle rampart is this no go through
oh wait should i rest i should probably rest again
oh hi melena
my utmost thanks for bringing me to the base of the urd tree you can come to the base of my urd tree
any time thank you thank you still got it
i shall depart to ascertain the purpose i was given farewell i shall leave torrent
right and the power to turn into strength one here i'm actually i don't have a clap
i wish you luck in realizing your ambition you have fought long and hard i have no doubt
you will become elden lord yeah you believe in me may you take the throne
okay last we can have one more
two more flasks from i'm unstoppable i'm just a hp chugging machine
the soundboard audio is doubled oh it comes out of desktop and stream thick
thing
there's only one reefling that can able to do this at the location
did i miss the map i've i'm not discovered it yet
it must be up ahead wherever the heck i am
i can go i'm gonna just wait okay i wait
put away put away i don't have any interest in
i'm gonna change what do you want is it nice i like polite by both
to be my sin if you're at disadvantage anything the girls do it's all me it's all me
oh nothing oh
i guess people at the end game can't get some in here wait really
i just woke up and you're so going god you're so precious
stop it reefling you're precious do the reason why i have strength
oh sorry wrong one
i think you're the only there's only one more reefling that can make it
it's because the city changes after the realm of the giant
it's not looking good i put down a sign
is your password
every time look i gotta bless the reeflings before i send them in
oh no i think the game's really limited you're gonna have to carry everything
reefling like no pressure if you're the only one that can load in you have to carry this entire
section i guess if we burned the tree we would actually be in a different area
oh no okay we have a second reefling i don't know if any invaders can make it i don't think so
i think everyone's cooked so we need to try and get through this area as fast as possible
without being invaded somehow
i'll literally we need to do as fast as possible are we ready
oh wait no there is a reefling there's a reefling that can be the invader oh my god we don't have
to like panic thank god
i'm getting nervous i'm getting shaky
this is the east coast patrol rampart
look at my cloak honestly i need a quilt creature right now
i'm so down for our quilt oh we're safe we're safe we don't have to worry about people beating us up
right are we ready reefling i don't know where we're going or what we're doing but let's do it
let's do it a quick adventure try a minute adventure reefling
i'm guessing if we go this way open the door
it does not do a single thing like that
okay we're beating up snowmen we said global warming
rid of them snowmen right now i got 10 no i got one 10 i can't bring
which is easy
oh he's a chicken nuggy he's got knee arms knee legs and he looks in the castle
oh my gosh this room's gorgeous look at all the plants it's just like the farm food thing
i'm gonna have all these plants around and then when you come home tired from work i'm going to
tell you all about my plants and you're gonna be like god she's so dumb i want to fight her
and it's the good life for her
oh oh no reefling reefling quickly quickly so you don't take fall damage
okay that was good reefling
the sea collection grows
capital area so i think because it shows like mild civilization in between like all this death
and decay uh possible because i always wonder i'm always like how how do people travel in the
roof and stuff in this game because isn't it too dangerous for the average person because if
we're having to do all of this stuff or is it the average person like everyone has to learn
like some sort of skill or craft and in order to like go anywhere there's no cities
oh sorry sorry
but it's oh sorry am i gonna just wall try something oh i think i'm not very uh
this is magic unfortunately that's
happy being those games are always basically supposed to pull off everything's falling apart
not to stay for anymore um okay i'm gonna say like how do you people eat
like i don't see any farms the carrot is growing aren't you guys hungry
like who sits up the food does anyone even eat
does anyone even need to eat maybe it's like a car okay you guys have split one reefling
two reeflings are gone oh there's a fight hold on are we fighting or are we
okay we're fighting we need to help that reefling
don't wait you carefully dodge that
uh i will say i pressed b but i was already locked into the big boy animation okay
i'm sorry i just blocked you
okay when they're taking a critical you actually can't
there's a guy on the stairs as well over to him where are you going
oh this grace had a lot of problems i don't think i can summon you guys properly after that
i feel like run through this whole area on my own
it's not even in some big on my own i had to run through this whole area
i'm scared there's actually a lot of areas in the like later game
that you can't hit anything wait oh there's an enemy there oh no sorry they weren't even
attacking me oh i feel bad for them
hold on i need to get my stamina back stop it
stop it i need my stamina back before i can start swinging you understand
oh i need my stamina shit oh wow stagger time that was awesome
pillage corpse yeah i will pillage the corpse
we made it oh we're going up okay let me grab something
something here
the rag and wind
oh i remember oh my god how do i not even see that when we entered
did they like perfectly hate to view this i feel like when you look up you'd notice like a dragon's
empire like it's got the old scale you've already
rune art that helps me in fate
oh no we're running out of time
hmm
i've laced in 25 minutes when it seems like i'm going to be dead
please don't fall off the map
do you mind
don't hurt my wraithlings don't give them jump scares either that's not nice
i think we can keep going
okay there's a bit of a fate
do you not have kills
okay oh i see the seed i see the seed right let's go wait do i take the seed
i don't fuck let's go
flying
it's going for my bullsack
have you gone
no it's targeting me and i'm in a corner this is a terrible idea
i
i just healed the undead
i like welcome welcome welcome oh wait it's a week
i'm so happy here okay we go to seed
there we go
uh whatever do seamless co-op mod um i would have to do it with one of the girls because
i think there's ip issues if i did it like that whereas when doing it this way it is through
and
it's through the servers which keeps me safe as strummer
oh they can jump i was like haven't seen you over here they can jump
it's not i think it's not a crazy concept that any of you can jump but you did see here
it's
we are beating up these plant men
i suppose it's mushroom if it's the score it's not plant them
oh no is there not a save point no there's only a save point after the fight
is this a solo fight
seamless yeah i was going to do seamless with sin
oh no right i don't know if you guys can come in i hope you can
oh thank god i get so nervous
um
i actually like his attack pattern because i have enough brain power to like respond a little bit
now i know i'm getting walloped don't get me wrong but
do i need to bring him in the open i think we need to bring him in the open a bit
he's like really swinging weirdly in that way which i think they're like hitting us so well
okay it's rolling pit
okay hold on
oh he changes like the last second
oh wow i feel like that's going to when he's lost on the ground is pretty cool
play safe and heal again oh i said i'm gonna play a safe and heal again
oh my gosh okay god free has been banked there we got it i got
poachers thank you replays okay what can we put on we just put on
the critical hit one because it probably got gone right now are you coming out no the game's just
yeah i was gonna say the game's just slowly kicking you out
the spawns you're tanking i'm literally just tanking all the hits
it's a lovely ds on this sheening i just connected to the very last second
i mean it worked out um
can't what what do we do now
did i just talk for the last bit i don't think we have enough time to like achieve anything
do you have time for margot only if you guys can like fucking bum rush them
do you want me to go is it this way i'll go to get margett up on those stairs
i don't go there
oh no my bavish goes up past the way
up to you i guess and i can't spawn you guys at this one up the tree branch this tree branch
right here
let's see if we have time i don't want to corrupt the vod though that's the only thing
it annoys me so much
all the babushkas
there's a wee bastard ahead i remember him
do i have enough IQ to kill him right now i don't know
i don't think i have enough is that great can i ignore him
wait i can summon you why corrupt the vod um for some reason if it goes at over 11 hours
is that all you've got
um for some reason after the 11 hour mark the thing 11 hours and 55 minutes the vod
becomes corrupted even though you can still stream appropriately i could keep streaming past it
and you guys would see it fine but if someone comes to watch it it doesn't like it like at all
wait is it is that someone over there riefling why are you all the way over here is that you
it is lol why are you all the way over here
okay you think google would have done something about it so many years ago
okay okay you guys are gonna have to like wipe him out
we've probably got a few attempts maybe what three max
does the other person get in
where's he not bringing you in
i think the loot doesn't work
saw the blood on me
depends on how fast i die that's my secret cap i don't go anywhere near the enemy unless i have to
okay there we go two reeflings it's time you need to prove
thyself youtube already a huge money thanks for google and the stores were told our vod would
make it even worse for them well we need to specifically request that we need to be like
hey are you guys ready let's see what happened oh wait am i going to get cutscene oh yeah i was
gonna say i have not unlocked the cutscene yet because i've not done this guy yet
graceless tarnished oh is it his voice our hair that was so disapproving of me
what is thy business with these thrones become elden lord
ah god rick the golden
the twin prodigies michela and millenia
general bradarn prytor righard
luna princess runny
willful traitors all
thy kind are all of a piece we're all the same
pillagers emboldened by the flame of ambition
have it rid upon thy meagre grave
f
felled by king morgott last of all kings
uh hi i've forgotten everything you do and your taming i've forgotten your taming
okay the reflins are coming in clutch i've completely forgotten his timing and everything
okay i wouldn't mind going for a cheeky wallet though okay make the rain make you stun us in
oh i missed it i missed it
oh wait i only have one healing cost wait did i not
i forgot to lie down
uh reflings you might have to do it between you i'm sorry i'm just gonna cover behind the chair
but mind me i forgot i i i'm i'm gonna cover i forgot to heal hitting him what orbel and moon
okay that went really well that went insanely well freaking first attempt thank you reflins
that was fantastic right oh he he's drinking to the occasion are we celebrating okay that went
freaking fantastic um is there like a i don't know if there's like an interaction that comes up
well literally reflins coming in clutch right i think we interact with this and then we get a
safe station down touch the wall of thorns impenetrable thorns refuse all none may enter the urge tree
i don't know i have red eyes i'm watching you i've probably got blood in them to be honest
okay i can't do anything about it i think melena is going to tell me what's up and i need to
basically i will sit down because i think she needs to talk you know or i need to talk to her
hi darling
hello again old friend allow me a moment to converse with you you are unable to enter the urge
tree no you're prevented by the mantle of bars the thorns are impenetrable a husk of the urge
trees being that spurns all that exists without the only way to stand before the elden ring
and become the elden lord is to pass the thorns my purpose serves to aid in that very act
so i'd like you to undertake a new journey with me to the flame of ruin far above the clouds
upon the snowy mountaintops of the giant so i can't remember i can set the urge tree a flame
she still stays with me after the burn to becoming elden or am i being dumb
she doesn't say with me after the burn
uh shall i turn your rooms to strength maybe let my hand rest upon you now for her to
wait a moment share them with me your thoughts your ambitions the principles you would follow
you have to like chaos take the world and burn the tree that way
but she's unhappy if you do i don't want her to be upset with this
read message one after her therefore offer faith
and i will call it there this game always says i'm like 99% sure i am going to see if a zero
is still gonna be screaming but she's been asked it for fucking 12 hours like me both of us are
gonna be crashing very shortly absurdly yeah you saved up mommy it's over that i limit well
yes this is true okay she's live on the clock shot let's see oh she's doing just talking
hi is there are you still streaming uh this is orange this is not yellow this is orange
she's steaming and she can't even tell the difference between colors this is orange
and i orange thank you am i still streaming a little longer i'm actually about to end it soon
in like 10 minutes okay okay we're just chatting a little bit hi strong me hi strong me hi
can you show me hi i want to lick your face
but your face would be nice and soft she's steaming
oh my god she's absolutely steaming be nice and soft
do you guys have fun exclamation mark
sure there are things for her internet sign for me thank you mass uh 16 18th of coming
to member as well i appreciate it since is there a steaming i'm not sure it's the best
uh she's also gonna be offline this is confined is there any umi plus members online
there is mimosa's on legal legend
oh what a punishment mimosa
this cannot be true my eyes must have seen me from what i've just witnessed
i'm gonna buy
that has been stained are you seeing oh i can't buy any more available potions
i'm putting you in the league i'm sorry but we'll just get one of these i guess
league oh that's cringe i see am i staying up longer
yes are you good are you gonna what are you gonna do to me i'm scared
oh she's gonna redirect into okay my hole is ready
no god i gotta pull i gotta pull it together guys i gotta i gotta pretend like i know how to play
league okay guys i'm gonna go into bottom lane and i'm gonna go kill this ash yeah i know what
i'm fucking doing oh i'm not getting my ass left mimosa was like that okay i'm just gonna
confirm we're redirecting our mimosa um unfortunately i am at the time because we're
about to explode into flames um i don't know how
um yes thank you so sorry my brain isn't fully here right now thank you so so much
my little reeflings for carrying me through the game tomorrow we will explore more of the dl side
of the lc side of things and it comes to elden ring thank you to everyone who is able to stream
snipe i apologize to anyone who was unable to get in but please don't worry we are playing a lot more
elden ring until i am satisfied that i have beaten the clc to our pulp and by beating i mean me and
the reeflings and by me and the reeflings doing that i mean you guys do roughly 99% of the work
and i do the 1% and have an amazing time because i get to enjoy elden ring experience without being
frustrated or upset because i'm a little baby thank you so so much my little reeflings i will
see your cutie buttootie booties tomorrow for another uh 11 hours 55 minute endurance since
we can't do officially 12 hours thanks to youtube for that um but it's been amazing thank you i hope
you're able to rest well sleep well or work well whatever you may be doing right now i mean you can
ink well if you also like uh thank you for your patience i'm going to try and flip my sleep which
means i will try to upload the audio as soon as i get it on up um yes i'm going to try and go to
sleep now which may actually be the wisest thing and then i can wake up early and actually get some
work done and then i think i will be able to actually keep up with all the work i've given myself
out with out with streams question mark i've got to prepare my back for the carry tomorrow yes
if you are playing the dlc right now thank you so much if you plan on like helping me out during
the dlc section move well this game is big it's not easy it's it's a massive game massive thing
okay i believe it there i love you all so so much i will see your cutie buttooties tomorrow
you're going to be redirected into mimosa she's actually pretty cool i think she's probably the
same comfort levels as long as you don't you know spell it out but uh i won't speak for a streamer
because i actually don't fully understand but for me you know i think mimosa is pretty legit to
be honest i think she's pretty cool um but that's just me that's what anyone should be um i will
um see you guys tomorrow as i've said now for the third time because my brain cannot fathom
anything else at the moment uh i'm gonna go pass out i love lots of you feeling please look after
yourself please get some more please stretch because it's gonna be a big r stream just like my
r something something i don't know i don't know anymore right see see you tomorrow hold on see
you tomorrow um oh wait hold on professional streamer moment hold on um
did i do it did i do a professional streamer moment ha ha professional okay see you tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow be there or be hit inside wait that's that's not punishment hold on okay bye i go